[musique]
Natacha Boluni, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Comment allez-vous ?
Bien.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bien sûr. Donc je suis née en 1975. J'ai
donc un demi-siècle à mon actif. J'ai
été professeur de français. J'ai je me
suis engagée en politique
avec Jean-Pierre Chevenement en 2002 et
puis je suis devenue journaliste au
journal Marian que j'ai ensuite dirigé
pendant 6 ans et demi. Et là maintenant,
je crée une revue qui s'appelle
l'audace, une revue trimestrielle
papier. Voilà, une revue euh dont le but
est de bah de rassembler tous ceux qui
qui ont pas envie de se résigner à voir
ce pays s'effondrer. En fait, c'est ça
la base. Voilà. Donc des gens euh qui
pensent pas la même chose parce que je
crois qu'on doit pouvoir débattre euh
quel que soient les opinions. C'est le
principe de la démocratie, l'engueulade
civilisée. Mais avec un impératif, nous
sommes rassemblés par le fait que nous
croyons qu'il faut défendre les intérêts
des citoyens français. notamment en
Europe, les intérêts des Européens dans
le monde et la conviction que on ne
redressera la France que par la
production sur le sol français. Voilà,
ça c'est la base et à partir de là, on
peut défendre des options différentes,
une vision des choses différentes et
cetera du moment que voilà, on est on
est rassemblé par ces impératifs là.
Alors aujourd'hui, on va parler liberté,
journalisme, l'Union européenne, BBC,
Emmanuel Macron et et tout un tas de
choses. Comme on vient de se taper 2h30
d'embouteillage, on est chaud comme la
braise.
Natacha, est-ce que vous avez suivi ?
Est-ce que tu as suivi ce qui s'est
passé à la BBC ?
Alors, je n'ai pas suivi ce qui s'est
passé à la BBC. Euh,
je fais un résumé. Ouais, je veux bien.
Donc le résumé, ils ont trafiqué une
vidéo, ils ont fait un montage gras et
crasseux pour faire dire à Trump ce
qu'il n'avait pas dit. Ils n'ont pas
respecté, malgré des alertes internes,
la l'équilibre de de du traitement de
certains conflits. Ils ont été rappelés
à l'ordre et ont continué et on continue
on continue.
Ça vous fait te fait penser à quoi je te
dis ça a entraîné la démission du grand
patron et de de son bras droit de sa
bras droit.
Ça ça fait penser à quoi est-ce que ça
existe dans les salles de rédaction
du ménage, du pilotage, du militantisme
politique, de je te rends l'appareil à
gauche, je te rends l'appareil à droite,
je je je fais le le bon journaliste
ménagère.
Déjà déjà, il y a des démissions, c'est
pas mal. C'est c'est la base. Ça ça peut
paraître étonnant
vu de France des gens qui démissionnent
quand il y a eu des fautes parce que il
me semble que ce qui caractérise
actuellement la France d'ailleurs pas
seulement dans les médias enfin
l'ensemble du système
médiatico-politique c'est
l'irresponsabilité totale c'est le fait
que on peut faire n'importe quoi. On
peut avoir un bilan absolument
épouvantable. on peut euh ne pas euh
répondre au on va dire au aux demandes
des citoyens et c'est pas grave. Voilà.
Donc ça c'est ma première réflexion
et je pense que c'est un élément
absolument essentiel, l'irresponsabilité
des élites hein. Le on va citer le
président Mao, le poisson pourri par la
tête et je crois que ça a des
conséquences sur la cohésion de
l'ensemble de la société et ça a des
conséquences sur l'avenir de la
démocratie. Euh 2è point, je pense qu'il
y a en effet un problème majeur de
confiance entre les citoyens et les
médias.
et que aujourd'hui on est là en train de
s'affoler sur les ingérences, les
réseaux sociaux et cetera. Les discours
sont absolument martiaux et volontaires
pour nous expliquer que attention on
essaie de nous manipuler.
Il y en a eu, il y a eu des tentatives
de manipulation.
Mais on est on est entièrement d'accord.
Il y a des manipulations et peut-être
qu'on pourra y revenir. Ça me semble un
enjeu absolument fondamental.
La bonne manipulation et la mauvaise
manipulation. Alors voilà, c'est un peu
ça le sujet et surtout euh je veux dire
les les réseaux sociaux n'ont pas
inventé la manipulation. Je veux dire il
faut lire par exemple le livre de
l'historien David Colonne la guerre de
l'information.
Et alors
vous l'avez lu, vous l'avez lu c'est un
bout un bout de un bout qui nous qui
parle de nous.
C'est du rédigé Wikipédia. Non, mais ce
qui est très drôle là-dedans,
on l'a rencontré à l'école de guerre, le
mec regardait ses pompes.
Bah, bien sûr, mais ce qui est ce qui
est euh ce qui est très drôle dans ce
qu'il raconte, c'est que toute la
première partie du livre est
intéressante sur justement le toute
l'histoire des liens entre la CIA et les
rédactions de journaux euh en Europe sur
la grande manipulation au moment de la
guerre en Irak en 91. Et puis
curieusement donc il décrit toutes les
manipulations des médias hein. C'est
bon. Puis curieusement au moment où on
arrive, on dépasse 2010 à peu près et là
il y a plus que les Russes et les
Chinois qui manipulent. Les autres
manipulent plus.
Les Britishes non. Catarin voilà c'est
ça. Les Américains, non. Non. Tout ça
est bien. Bon passons là-dessus. Mais ce
que je voulais dire, c'est qu'en
revanche, quand on le lit, la partie
sous le début est très intéressant sur
la façon dont en effet la CIA se vantait
dans les années 1970 d'avoir un
correspondant dans chaque rédaction d'un
grand journal européen.
Comme les Russes avaient des
correspondants, c'était chez qui ?
L'humanité. Voilà. et puis l'expresse
l'expresse c'était donc il faut avoir
conscience de ça et surtout il faut
comprendre que au-delà de ça, au-delà de
la manipulation,
il y a eu pendant des années
on va dire une forme de conformisme dans
les médias qui a abouti à ce que petit à
petit sur certains sujets, il y ait une
uniformité totale et une pression qui
est extrêmement dangereuse. use et qui
fait que bah aujourd'hui je veux dire le
la confiance dans les médias de la part
des des citoyens est absolument
catastrophique. Je pense que alors
évidemment le moment de bascule où on
s'aperçoit vraiment du décalage entre
les médias et les citoyens c'est
évidemment 2005 où là vous je 54,5 % des
Français ont voté non au sur le
référendum sur le traité constitutionnel
européen. 90 % des médias non seulement
voter oui, mais on fait campagne pour le
oui en expliquant que ceux qui votaient
non étaient des racistes, des
xénophobes, des ringars et cetera. Et ça
a été, je pense comment dire une
fracture
qu'on paye encore.
Non mais on la paye non on paye pas. Si
on parle de corporation journalistique.
Ah non mais je vous dire non non mais la
corporation ne ne paye pas.
Le châtiment prendra quelle forme à ton
avis ?
Non, je vais je vais éviter de de
blaguer
à 13 novembre.
Je je je j'évite toujours de de blaguer
sur les les châtiments que je peux parce
que
alors le châtiment dans les abonnés,
dans les rédactions, le châtiment dans
les audiences, le châtiment dans les
subventions parce que comme le le
pouvoir va switcher forcément à
l'ultradroite dans pas très longtemps,
alors
leur rente leur rente de subvention va
s'évanouir comme pot de chagrin.
Alors, il y a plusieurs choses là. Je
pense que ça se paye par ça se paye très
conc très concrètement maintenant par
une baisse de la diffusion des médias
traditionnels qui est énorme par un
paysage notamment de la presse écrite
qui est absolument catastrophique mais
vraiment catastrophique. Or pour ma
part, malgré tous les défauts des
journalistes, je crois qu'il faut des
médias et des médias, on va dire
traditionnel installé parce que il y a
des éléments de journalisme qui ne
peuvent être faits que de cette
manière-là. Donc je ne suis pas pour
l'éradication des médias traditionnels,
de la presse écrite, surtout pas. Je
connais, j'en connais tous les défauts.
U sélection darwinienne.
Non, il faut pas une sélection
darwinienne. Il faut,
on va dire, une remise en question.
Il faut une
une prise de conscience du rôle
démocratique des médias et donc de ce
qui nous oblige. C'estàd que je crois de
toute façon que dans l'ensemble de la
société ou plutôt dans l'ensemble des
différentes institutions et élites de la
société, il faut tout à coup une prise
de conscience de voilà du de la
nécessité de respecter les citoyens,
d'avoir le sens du temps long, le sens
de l'État. Alors, on est d'accord, on en
est très très loin, mais il n'y a que
comme ça qu'on s'en sortira parce que
sinon, en effet, on va à la catastrophe.
Mais c'est tout le problème. Est-ce
qu'il faut avoir juin 40 et
l'effondrement pour voir surgir des
résistants pour voir de Gaulle ? Je ne
sais pas. Moi, j'espère que non.
C'est-à-dire que je pense qu'il y a
moyen de se réveiller avant. Et quant à
la question de savoir si on va vers un
pouvoir d'extrême droite en France, là
aussi c'est pareil. Je pense qu'il y a
des moyens de faire autrement et qu'il y
a des moyens de convaincre. Pourquoi ?
parce que les citoyens eux
majoritairement ils attendent une offre
politique et on voit très bien l'offre
politique qu'ils attendent
malgré le l'éclatement du système
politique.
Oui.
Je vais être dur, je vais être je vais
être vilain
quand je t'entends défendre
la profession qui
est pour toi dans je pense la plus haute
estime. Non.
Ah non pas du tout.
C'est quoi la plus haute estime ? Ah
non, je n'ai aucune estime pour la pour
le pour pour les journalistes, le
journalisme. Je suis pas je suis pas
journaliste dans l'âme. Moi, je suis je
suis euh une citoyenne qui croit en la
France et en la République, c'est tout.
Bon,
OK. Quand j'entends les arguments,
est-ce que je les entends, ça ça nous
réchauffe le cœur, c'est beau,
c'est il faut qu'on se réveille avant le
choc, mais le choc, il est peut-être
déjà là. Et quand j'entends les
arguments, j'ai l'impression d'une nana
qu'on vient de plaquer et qui essaie de
me raconter que de me raconter que
t'inquiète pas, j'ai changé euh on va se
rattraper, j'ai identifié les problèmes.
Non,
on va reprendre les choses à la base.
Alors, je laisse faire reprendre les
choses à la base. Première technique
d'interview, bien joué. Voilà, on
reprend les choses à la base.
La France est dans un état absolument
catastrophique. Il faut
la communauté
la communauté nationale.
Non non non mais je je construis un
raisonnement et après on verra en effet
s'il faut des chiffres pour appuyer. Je
les mettrai.
La communauté nationale est en train
d'exploser. On le voit. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des haines qui montent, il y a
des tensions qui montent. On a une crise
qui est une crise non seulement
politique mais une crise démocratique.
Toutes les institutions sont en train de
s'effondrer. D'abord parce que il y a un
pouvoir politique qui utilise ces
institutions contre le peuple, contre la
volonté majoritaire des citoyens. Tout
ça appuyé sur une crise économique,
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes en train là
le nombre de de défaillances
d'entreprise l'an dernier c'était 66000
et aujourd'hui c'est encore plus fort là
sur les derniers mois. Donc ça veut dire
qu'on va vers l'éradication de ce qui
nous reste de tissu économique.
La part de l'industrie dans le PIB est
passée en dessous des 10 %. Donc tout
ça, ce sont des indicateurs qui montrent
qu'on on est en train de payer 40 ans
d'aveuglement. Voilà, 40 ans
d'aveuglement soutenu par
le système médiatico-politique.
C'est-à-dire que les médias n'ont pas
joué leur rôle normal en démocratie qui
est un rôle de contrepouvoir, d'alerte,
de décryptage sur des questions qui moi
pour moi sont les questions
fondamentales, c'est-à-dire les
questions de souveraineté. Le mot même
de souveraineté était interdit. Moi, je
me suis fait traiter de réactionnaires
et cetera parce que je parlais de ces
sujets-là. Ils ont réussi à faire en
sorte que les gens qui parlaient de
souveraineté soient qualifiés de
souverainiste, ce qui revenait à dire
vaguement d'extrême droite, complotistes
et cetera. enfin tous ces termes qui
permettent de décrédibiliser
et on a petit à petit raté le coche.
Tous les coches les uns après les autres
quand il était temps d'agir. Je crois
qu'il est encore temps d'agir. Il y a
des politiques à mener et je crois qu'en
plus le pire c'est que là on arrive à un
moment où ils se sont pris le réel dans
la figure. Donc le début Ah quand même
si si si
le franchement se retrouver pendant le
Covid avec des médecins qui sont obligés
d'utiliser des sacs poubelles parce
qu'ils ont plus de blouses, qu'on
s'aperçoit que oh mon dieu on fabrique
plus de respirateur qui s qu'on
s'aperçoit que on ne fabrique plus de
masque, qu'on est incapable, que toutes
les chaînes d'approvisionnement sont
coupées. Il faut se souvenir en plus
extraordinaire de ces moments où on
décide de confiner, on ferme tout et
puis il faut 3 4 5 jours pour se dire
"Mais en fait, on a laissé les magasins
ouverts mais si on a interdit la
circulation des camions et fermé les
stations service euh comment on fait
pour que les magasins soient
approvisionnés ?" Ah oui, vous voyez
tout est comme ça. Tout est comme ça.
Bon, on s'aperçoit que le quel est le
réel qui se sont pré aussi dans la
figure ? La guerre en Ukraine. La guerre
en Ukraine. Et tout à coup, alors crise
de l'énergie et cetera. Ah, on avait pas
prévu en effet que il fallait assurer
l'indépendance énergétique du pays,
qu'il fallait assurer la souveraineté de
de l'ensemble des pays européens en
matière d'armement et cetera. Rien,
rien. Donc tout ça, on est en train de
le payer. Alors, on le paye très cher
parce que le le fait que les entreprises
euh européennes payent leur énergie
trois à quatre fois plus cher que les
États-Unis, que la Chine, ça, on en est
pas encore sorti. On a toujours un
discours politique qui est une un
discours de fuite en avant par rapport à
cela. C'est-à-dire au contraire un
discours béliciste alors même qu'il
faudrait comprendre que les États-Unis
sont en train de se de se dégager et de
tirer profit sont en train d'essayer
d'ailleurs de nous écraser
économiquement et que c'est pas la
meilleure idée de dire formidable, nous
allons remplacer les États-Unis en
Ukraine, ce qui est faux puisque nous
n'avons pas les moyens d'armer
l'Ukraine. En fait, on paye des armes
américaines que Donald Trump nous
surfacture 10 % pour les offrir à
l'Ukraine et on donne de l'argent à
l'Ukraine pour qu'elle puisse acheter
des armes américaines avec donc les
fonds européens. Donc tout ça, on ça se
voit maintenant. C'estàd qu'on est en
train de voir qu'il n'y a aucune
réflexion sur l'indépendance de l'Europe
et sur la façon de préserver notre
routil industriel, de préserver notre
capacité à réagir en cas de crise. On
est en train de détruire tout ça. Bon,
ça c'est le réel tel qu'il est.
Ça aboutit à quoi ? Les citoyens eux ont
parfaitement compris. Ils sont compris
qu'en effet euh la souveraineté c'est
pas une lubie. La souveraineté ce sont
des éléments extrêmement concret. Ils
ont compris que quand on a une Union
européenne qui explique qu'on va faire
le Green Deal, c'est-à-dire que on va
euh interdire les les voitures à moteur
thermique d'ici 2035, que on va se
s'acheter une conscience écologique en
interdisant des tas et d'état de choses
tout en continuant à importer en Europe
des produits qui eux ne respectent
aucune de ces normes. On va achever de
tuer l'industrie et on va tuer notre
agriculture.
On achète aussi une conscience
géopolitique en achetant du gaz de
chiste américain.
Ah bah oui. Non mais ça c'est là aussi
c'estàd le gaz de chiste dont on ne
voulait pas avant la guerre en Ukraine
parce que il est polluant parce que
voilà accessoirement parce que là les
Américains nous le font payer là aussi
trois quatre fois plus cher hein que ce
qu'ils font payer aux entreprises
américaines. Bon, on n'en voulait pas.
La guerre en Ukraine a abouti au fait
que nous achetions du gaz de chiste
américain.
La guerre en Ukraine qu'ils ont pas vu
venir. Bon, les Britishes l'ont vu venir
à partir de 2016 parce qu'ils ont
commencé l'ingérance en Europe à partir
de 2016.
Et nous nous euh on a fait quoi nous ?
Nous les Français, nous 40 ans où ça
part à volot, on est censé être
français. On est censé identifier
les les crétins, on est censé identifier
ceux qui nous font des croches pas de
l'intérieur et de l'extérieur et on est
censé prendre des mesures proactives et
leur expliquer
tu continues à faire ton malin, il va
t'arriver des bricoles. Et là, on a
laissé faire. On a laissé faire pourquoi
? Parce que le journalisme
aimait bien le rondron quotidien et la
subvention quotidienne. On a profité
pour faire un petit peu de militantisme.
Les oligarques,
on en profité pour acheter quelques
titres pour projeter leur vision des
choses.
Alors, c'est c'est pour cette raison
exactement que avec Jean-Michel 4
points, nous avions créé le comité
Orwell en 2015. Le comité Orwell,
c'était un groupe de journalistes
et l'idée c'était c'est Jean-Michel 4
points qui en a eu qui en a eu l'idée.
Je je rappelle qui il était. Jean-Michel
4 point était un journaliste qui avait
journaliste économique qui avait
travaillé au monde, qui était cfondateur
de la tribune de la lettre A, qui est
l'auteur d'un livre en 1976. C'était son
premier livre sur le plan calcul, le
torpillage du plan calcul par les
Américains avec d'ailleurs l'acceptation
de de Giscar. Et ça veut dire pourquoi
je rappelle ça ? Parce que dès 1976, il
avait conscience de la nécessité de
défendre la souveraineté industrielle
française et il a passé toute sa vie à
se battre pour ça. C'est lui qui a écrit
le premier livre sur le scandale
alstomstom, scandale d'État. Et donc il
avait voulu créer ce groupe pour essayer
de réfléchir à la manière dont on
pouvait faire entendre les sujets
géopolitique économique d'une autre
manière dans les médias parce qu'il
considérait que c'était sur ces
sujets-là qu'il y avait une forme
d'omerta et c'est par hasard en effet si
ce sont essentiellement des journalistes
économiques qui nous ont rejoint au
comité Orwell. d' certains avaient été
virés parce que ils avaient osé défendre
le protectionnisme, critiquer la manière
dont avait été conçue l'euro en
expliquant queune monnaie surévaluée
allait tuer le l'industrie française.
Enfin, tout ce genre de truc qu'il était
totalement interdit d'écrire. Et
d'ailleurs, vous remarquerez que par
exemple plus personne ne parle des
questions de monétaire actuellement.
C'est extraordinaire. Il y a eu à un
moment il y a quelques années, on a pu
éventuellement discuter de l'euro. Là
aujourd'hui, ça a l'air de déranger
personne. L'euro s'est surévalué de de
15 % depuis le début de l'année. C'est
personne ne prend conscience du fait que
il n'y a pas de pilotage de la monnaie,
donc aucune politique possible pour
gérer le fait que cette monnaie est
totalement surévaluée pour l'économie
française alors même qu'elle est
sous-évaluée pour l'économie allemande.
C'est-à-dire que il y a c'est d'ailleurs
un signe tank allemand qui a qui a
calculé ça. Donc les Allemands, ils sont
sérieux. C'est pas
les Allemands, ils sont pas sérieux.
C'est non mais je plaisante, c'est mais
je veux dire c'est pas une lubie de
d'excité antie-européen. C'est le
Conseil pour les politiques européenne
qui a calculé que l'euro est surévalué
de 10 à 12 % pour l'économie française
alors qu'il est sous-évalué de 6 % pour
l'économie allemande. Obama he ça c'est
les chiffres Obama. Donc vous voyez le
différentiel. Donc ça raconte le
décrochage de l'économie française par
rapport à l'économie allemande depuis le
passage à l'euro. On peut citer d'autres
chiffres par exemple faut que je dois ou
ça va
juste je juste un autre chiffre qui est
extrêmement intéressant. En 2004, au
moment du de l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne à l'est, la moitié des des
régions françaises avait un PIB
au-dessus de la moyenne du PIB européen.
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus que
l'Île-de-Fance. Voilà, ces chiffresl,
ils sont implacables. Sauf que ça,
personne ne le raconte, personne
n'essaie de comprendre les mécanismes et
personne n'essaie de se demander comment
on en sort.
Alors personne, c'est qui ? On interdit
les sujets de souverainisme à l'époque,
c'est qui ?
Alors
maintenant, il faut mettre des noms. Il
faut mettre des noms sur les gens
qui nous ont mis dans la panade pour
éviter qu'on puisse recréer le même
genre de chose. Non, mais
bien sûr.
Donc les noms en question avec des
preuves de tu ne parleras pas de ça ou
je te dis que tu es un mec d'extrême
droite parce que tu as parlé de
souverainisme ou tu es dans le camp des
hallucinés.
qui faisait ça dans quelle salle de
rédaction et il touchait combien de
subventions de nos impôts ?
Alors, il faut bien comprendre que c'est
largement majoritaire dans les médias
qui ont pignon sur rue, hein, les médias
mainstream comme on dit largement
majoritair et que c'est pas une forme de
complot. La plupart des gens sont
convaincus qu'ils font leur travail dans
le sens de la vérité. simplement ils
arrivent à se convaincre de ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une un
conformisme, il y a une, on va dire une
peur de sortir du lot. Le drame
d'ailleurs
oui, le drame des journalistes, c'est
qu'ils ont des amis journalistes
et donc dans
les sectes,
bah quand ils vont dîner le
des amis d'autres sectes.
Alors, c'est surtout quand ils vont
dîner le soir, ils dînent avec leurs
amis journalistes qui leur disent "Mais
comment tu as pu écrire ? Comment tu as
pu écrire ça ? Mon dieu !" Mais voilà,
c'est ça le sujet. euh au lieu d'aller
discuter avec des des Français, des
citoyens.
Vous avez beaucoup d'amis journalistes ?
Assez peu.
J'ai quelques amis journalistes qui sont
ceux par exemple ceux avec qui euh j'ai
j'ai fondé l'audace et encore euh c'est
pas on est on est un petit groupe et il
y a pas une majorité de journalistes.
Mais moi je fréquente pas des
journalistes dans ma vie, je fréquente
des des Français
des Français moyens normaux. Voilà, une
diversité de gens, c'est fondamental.
mieux pour prendre la température d'un
pays.
Non mais c'est la base. C'est d'ailleurs
enfin quand j'ai commencé dans dans le
journalisme, c'était avec Jean-François
Cann à Marianne qui était le seul patron
de presse qui passait sa vie en province
à faire des rencontres avec les lecteurs
sur c'est ce que devrait faire n'importe
quel patron de presse. Donc vous voyez,
c'est une forme de microcosme
qui empêche de voir la réalité. Si on
ajoute à ça qu'il y a des tas de sujets
qui n'intéressent pas, c'est-à-dire que
par exemple les questions de
géopolitique, c'est très compliqué de
faire de mettre ça à l'agenda des dans
les dans les salles de rédaction. Ça
c'est compliqué de le mettre dans les
agendas parce que les mecs sont très
panés,
ont une incapacité à traiter les sujets
parce que comme ils ont pipoté pendant
leurs années de scolarité en école de
journalisme de M2,
ils se retrouvent en salle de rédaction
pour jouer de la flû du violoncel et
faire oui oui patron je vais écrire ce
que tu as envie.
Donc la population pas informée
correctement pour prendre ses décisions
de conscience.
C'est quoi ? C'est une gabide fumiste
parce que sur les sujets qu'on maîtrise
sur les sujets qu'on maîtrise
type renseignement géopolitique
des des sujets où même à la DGSE il
blémissent quant à nos capacités d'aller
chercher l'information.
Quand on entend les espèces de de
trépanés
fumistes, que ce soit à la télé ou quand
on lit leur tribune, ça sent quand même
la grosse fumisterie. Nous, on le
détecte parce qu'on a le nez dedans, on
se tait. Bon, on râle un peu sur notre
petite chaîne YouTube.
Ça ça vient de quoi ? Ils ont été
sélectionnés par le même grand trépané
qui crèche sur de la moquette de 3 cm
payé par nos impôt depuis un certain
nombre d'années. C'est des écoles de
journalisme qui ne forment plus que des
militants pour continuer à faire le
rondron quotidien.
C'est comme dans une secte, on
sélectionne que des gens qui peuvent
être malléables, qu'on peut mettre à
notre chaussure, à notre pied.
Premier point, il y a un principe
économique, c'est-à-dire que dans un
métier dans dans n'importe quel métier,
quand quand il y a une tension sur
l'emploi, ceux qui sont employés, les
salariés sont en position défavorable.
Il y a pas assez de boulot. Donc si tu
fais pas ce qu'on te dit, tu iras voir
dehors si s'il fait chaud.
C'est le premier point. Donc vous avez
des journalistes qui sont en position de
faiblesse et qui donc peuvent avoir
tendance à écrire bah ce qu'il faut
écrire pour ne pas perdre leur boulot.
Tout cela c'est ce sont des non dit. On
va pas vous dire évidemment si tu écris
ça, tu seras viré. Non, c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe. Mais je le disais
tout à l'heure, dans les gens qui ont
rejoint le comité Horwell en 2015, il y
avait il y avait des journalistes qui
avaient été virés parce que au moment où
il fallait faire des des licenciements
économiques, on a pris ceux qui
pensaient mal et ils ont été dégagés
ou qui dérangeaient.
Voilà. Ou dérangeait.
Donc un bon journaliste, c'est un
journaliste qui pense mal. C'est un
journaliste incarcéré. Un bon
journaliste, c'est un journaliste mort.
Un bon journaliste, c'est un journaliste
qui se fait virer. Un bon journaliste,
c'est un journaliste qui vit dans un
appartement de 12 m² où il fait 13°gr où
il mange des boîtes à chat. C'est quoi
un bon journaliste ?
Sans aller jusque là. Mais c'est vrai
que moi quand je me suis fait virer,
c'était en 2017, juin 2017, je me suis
fait virer d'Europe 1 et de
Paris-première d'un coup dans l'espace
de 15 jours. Et c'est Jean-François Cann
qui m'a dit : "Et alors, c'est une
médaille pour un journaliste d'être viré
si vous avez été viré de nulle part.
c'est que vous avez pas fait votre
boulot, vous avez dérangé personne.
C'est voilà
la plume, la plie, tout ça.
Donc je me répète ce ce mantra.
Après
le il faut bien comprendre que dans
l'économie des médias, la concentration,
le fait que les médias mainstream
coûtent de plus en plus cher à produire
et rapporte de moins en moins que la
mane publicitaire est captée par les
gars femmes. Du coup, les journaux ne
vivent plus de leur lectorat affaiblit
évidemment le poids des journalistes.
C'est-à-dire que le la baisse de la
manne publicitaire fait qu'on va de plus
en plus incité à capter la moindre le
moindre annonceur. Donc on va pas fâcher
les annonceurs.
Le le coût de tout cela fait que ce sont
des milliardaires qui peuvent posséder
ça. Vous voyez ? Donc c'est c'est un
système en en chaîne. Et si on ajoute à
ça le fait que il y a évidemment une
propagande notamment
on le voit c'est alors sur les par
exemple le fait qu'il y a une majorité
de journalistes qui soient même sans
sans même s'en rendre compte d'un
atlantisme absolument total.
C'est de la bonne propagande.
C'est voilà. Mais il préfère ne pas se
poser la question. Je dire c'est plus
simple de se dire que c'est parce que on
est dans le camp du bien que on va pas
creuser trop de choses. Et évidemment
le on sait tous que plus il y a de
tension internationale et plus le la
vérité est la première victime de des
choses.
Donc on comprend à quel point dans un
dans un moment géopolitique
tellement violent,
il est beaucoup plus difficile de mettre
à distance les choses, d'avoir une
vision qui soit une vision équilibrée,
complexe. C'est beaucoup plus facile de
bah de en gros de de tenir le discours
qui est le discours majoritaire et
commun.
Vous savez comment on appelle ça nous ?
Comment on juge ça ? On appelle ça un
bon grand réflexe de Laurence.
Ouais,
je je pense que c'est Oui, c'est un
principe
euh
Est-ce que c'est un un réflexe de
Laurence ?
Je j'ai déjà entendu l'expression mais
j'étais en train d'essayer de réfléchir.
Faut pas faire des trucs comme ça ici.
En général, ça ça non mais je sais c'est
pour ça que vous avez dû tout de suite
remarquer que j'étais en train d'essayer
de chercher dans ma tête. Voyons où
est-ce que j'ai entendu cette expression
et très honnêtement je voilà
réflexe de Laoren c'est quand un animal
a peur
il commence à faire sa toilette et il
avale. [rires]
Oui.
Est-ce que on a des bons gros
journalistes en bon gros réflexe de
Laurence qui ont peur pour leur boulot
qui sont précarisés
dès qu'on leur fait bou
ils avalent. Mais encore une fois, il
faut
je veux dire, il faut pas pointer les
individus. Le problème c'est pas les
c'est pas les journalistes en tant
qu'individu, de même que c'est pas les
politiques en tant qu'individu. C'est le
l'ensemble du système qui aboutit à ce
que ces gens-là soient incapables de on
va dire de sortir.
OK. Comment on fait pour abattre ce
système
en terme stratégique ? Je parle pas de
on va écrire des poèmes là les pauvres
individus c'est un système. OK, on fait
comment ? On va on va parler militaire.
Ouais.
Objectif stratégique abattre le système.
Quelles sont les vulnérabilités ?
Les vulnérabilités c'est que ça tient
plus.
les vulnérabilités, c'est que les
citoyens se sont réveillés et que là,
ils ont parfaitement conscience que tout
ça est en train de s'effondrer, que
la confiance dans cette ce système qui
qui leur disait "Ne vous inquiétez pas,
surtout arrêtez de penser, on fait ça à
votre place et cetera, ça ne marche
pas."
Et je pense que la crise démocratique
politique que nous vivons aujourd'hui,
c'est le signe de ça. Donc il y a une
attente. Il y a une attente.
Il y a une attente de quoi ? Du public
ou il y a une attente du public pour se
venger ?
Non, pas se venger. Non, moi je crois
pas. Non, non, je crois pas. Évidemment
qu'il y a une colère absolument noire
contre, on le voit bien, contre les
politiques, les médias et cetera bien
sûr, mais je crois pas à l'esprit de
vengeance. Je crois que les gens
attendent tout simplement qu'on leur
établisse
la promesse de 1789,
le gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple, le peuple souverain. Moi
ça m'a frappé au moment des gilets
jaunes.
Rappelle
non mais au moment des gilets jaunes,
souvenez-vous, c'était extraordinaire de
voir des gens qui n'étaient pas
politisés, qui n'avaient jamais milité
dans quoi que ce soit. J'ai le souvenir
d'une une femme mère célibataire et
cetera et qui tout à coup sur un plateau
de télé dit "Mais enfin, nous sommes
citoyens, nous sommes souverains."
C'est fabuleux. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
dans l'inconscient du peuple français
1789.
OK.
Et tout simplement,
il y a l'idée que bah va falloir faire
tomber les Bastilles, c'est tout. Et
qu'on va le faire. Mais moi, je fais
partie des gens qui considèrent que ça
doit se faire sans violence.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai la conviction
qu'on peut réussir à renverser les
choses sans sans aller au à la la
révolution le s. Tu
as écouté Chantal Goya quand tu étais
petite ? Non. Un lapin. Non. Non. Non.
Non.
Un chasseur.
Pas du tout. Moi j'ai écouté De Gaulle,
j'ai écouté Jean Dark. J'ai voilà
Jean Dark. Non, vous l'avez pas écouté.
C'est elle qui a écouté. Oui,
elle a entendu des voix. Non, non, c'est
je veux dire mes convictions à moi,
c'est l'idée que dans l'histoire
systématiquement et par quelque biais
que ce soit, il y a un moment où en
particulier le peuple français reprend
la main. Ser
je je me fais l'avocat du diable et je
vais continuer à grossir le trait comme
je fais d'habitude.
Un bon petit régici à l'ancienne
mais d'ine France.
Alors
Cocorico pap
on va faire un exemple puis ensuite on
va faire queiner toute la cour
à la française
on se met avec une petite bouteille de
vieille chartreuse.
La chartreuse, je veux bien. La
chartreuse, je veux bien la pé jaune
ouverte.
Mais
jaune ouverte la chartreuse ?
Moi, j'aime les deux.
J'aime les deux. La verte est ma
préférée en général mais j'aime les
deux. Moi, je suis assez ouverte. Ça
dépend les dangereux pour la santé.
C'est bien de
la jaune, la jaune le midi, le le la
verte le soir.
Revenons, revenons. Belle belle
temporisation.
Revenons à notre régicide. Bon, on a
plus droit. un président, il est à 11 %
dans les sondages, il prend des risques
à se maintenir où il se croit investi
d'une vérité, une justice immanente,
d'une mission sacrée.
Alors
c'est pour ça qu'il dégage pas ou c'est
parce que il doit tenir
tous ses petits copains qui risquent de
se venger contre lui s'il lâche les le
manche ?
Déjà, il y a quelque chose qui est
inacceptable, c'est le fait d'utiliser
les institutions de la 5e République
pour se maintenir euh contre
pour se maintenir, c'est très bien. Mais
pour faire sa campagne quand on est à
Bersi, ça peut être sympa aussi, non ?
Oui, mais tout le problème est là. La 5e
République, elle a été pensée pour alors
le rôle d'une constitution, c'est ça,
c'est de faire émerger la volonté du
peuple. Et la 5e République, elle est
pensée pour que le président incarne
cette volonté.
Napoléon avait commencé à mettre les
choses sur les rails.
Oui. Simplement
le problème, c'est quand vous utilisez
ces institutions qui sont stables pour
justement se maintenir à tout prix et
forcer à mener une politique qui va
contre la volonté du peuple. Et c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer. Ajoutons
ajoutons à ça le fait que on est dans
une démocratie
qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
dysfonctionne. Pourquoi ? Parce que les
politiques ont acté l'idée qu'ils
étaient minoritaires et que c'est pas
grave. C'est-à-dire que ils ont
du parti socialiste là ou de tous les
politiques.
Ah tous tous ils sont tous minoritaires
et tous ça les dérange pas et ils
espèrent faire passer leur politique.
Mais pourquoi on en arrive là ? C'est ça
qui est extrêmement important parce que
au fur et à mesure de depuis les années
7080,
on voit petit à petit s'installer un
système un système économique dont le
but est de contourner toutes les
conquêtes sociales des des deux siècles
précédents
grâce à la dérégulation, à la
mondialisation et à la division mondiale
du travail. et on va aller fabriquer
ailleurs. Ça permet de pas payer les
ouvriers, de pas voilà. Donc tout ça est
avec des institutions qui contournent la
démocratie, que ce soit l'OMC, que ce
soit l'Union européenne après la tunique
de 86 qui permettent donc la libre
circulation des capitaux, des
marchandises et cetera. Et le but, c'est
de pas payer les gens pour leur boulot,
c'est tout. D' de trouver des gens qui
qu'on ne rémunérera pas.
l'environnement
par pertes et profit et ça fait penser
un peu au journalisme ça non ?
Et donc oui, c'est ça. Donc ce système
là petit à petit sur 40 ans, on
l'amplifie et tous les politiques mènent
la même politique. Justement, c'était la
fameuse phrase de Philippe Séin. Droite
et gauche sont des détaillants qui se
fournissent chez le même grossiste,
l'Europe. C'est c'est à peu près ça,
c'est résumé. Mais attention, pas
l'Europe en tant qu'idée, l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle a été
construite, c'est-à-dire comme poste
avancé de la mondialisation néolibérale.
Sauf que au bout d'un moment, vous avez
des citoyens qui qui comprennent qu'ils
sont les dindons de la farce. Vous avez
une destruction des classes populaires
puis des classes moyennes et tout à coup
bah ils se disent "Attendez, c'est on
nous a pas demandé notre avis." Voilà.
Donc ils se mettent petit à petit à
taper, à cogner sur le système. Et
comment ils font pour cogner sur le
système ? Ils utilisent le vote qu'on
leur accorde de temps en temps. C'estàd
que le principe de la démocratie a été
totalement dévoyé. C'est on vous donne
le droit de voter de temps en temps.
Alors en France tous les 7 ans puis tous
les 5 ans et puis de temps en temps un
référendum. Et là le les citoyens votent
mal. Oh bah on fait plus de référendum.
Voilà. Faut se souvenir de de la du
texte de Philippe Muret au lendemain du
du 21 avril 2002 quand il dit "Écoutez
le le peuple a l'impression qu'on ne
l'entend pas. Donc il s'est saisi d'un
gourdin pour cogner sur le système et il
a pris le gourdin qui ferait le plus mal
pour cogner le plus fort possible. Et
Philippe Puret disait "Ça ne veut pas
dire que le peuple soit gourdiniste. Ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il aspire à ce que
le gourdin gouverne, il a juste voulu
qu'on l'écoute." Et bien on a vu petit à
petit des insurrections par le vote
s'exprimer. Ça a été aux États-Unis
Donald Trump en 2016, ça a été le Brexit
et en France donc on voit la montée du
Front National puis du Rassemblement
national. Sauf que qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait face à ça les autres ? Et bien ils
ont considéré que c'était formidable
d'être face au Front National parce que
ça permettait d'être lu à tous les
coups.
Nous a fait le coup.
Ah ben bien sûr, c'est lui qui a
commencé. Mais du coup en face puisque
plus le Front National, les
Rassemblement national montait là
maintenant il gèle 35 % de l'électorat.
Donc les autres à côté sont forcément
mathématiquement minoritaires. C'est et
ça les dérange pas. Ils peuvent se
maintenir grâce aux institutions de la
5e République largement tordue. On a vu
ce que ça a donné quand il s'est agit
d'utiliser le 493. Le 493 est un est un
système qui a été qui a été inventé par
Michel Debré et de Gaulle. pour
permettre de contourner ce que Deg
appelait la politique des partis.
C'est-à-dire quand les partis à
l'Assemblée bloquaient, le pouvoir
exécutif pouvait forcer pour faire
passer la volonté du peuple contre les
arrangements entre parties. C'était ça
l'idée du 493. Ça n'a jamais été conçu
pour imposer une politique dont les
Français ne voulaient pas. C'est
totalement contraire à tout l'esprit de
la de la de la Constitution. Mais donc
on aboutit à ce moment où l'ensemble des
représentants politiques sont
minoritaire et veulent appliquer un
programme dont les citoyens ne veulent
pas. Ça ne peut pas fonctionner, ça
n'est plus la démocratie. Alors, il faut
revenir aux causes de tout ça.
Je mettre une petite parenthèse.
Oui.
La marmotte, le chocolat. OK. Le peuple
ne veut pas, c'est bien. Le peuple est
fliqué, le peuple est surveillé. Le
principal canal de diffusion, le
journalisme,
c'est un délitement, un pourrissement
à l'image de la France.
Oui.
Euh Internet va être fliqué, ils ont
déjà commencé.
Oui,
c'est c'était un peu àégal ce qu'il
faisait. Maintenant, ils vont le
légaliser.
Le peuple fliqué avec de l'intelligence
artificielle pour détecter les futurs
leaders ou détecter les les
rapprochements un peu dangereux.
La rébellion, elle va vite être mise
sous cloche là. Non,
c'est le risque. C'est le risque. Et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il faut très
rapidement empêcher cela. C'est-à-dire
faire en sorte que les citoyens prennent
conscience de ça, d'où le rôle de tous
ceux qui peuvent informer et de ceux qui
se battent. Je vous faites quoi depuis
des années sur Syerview ?
Justement
éclairé,
on est en train de se faire neutraliser.
Euh euh on l'a remarqué tout de suite
euh on est en train de comme c'était
dans notre stratégie qu'on savait que ça
allait arriver, on se finance pas par
YouTube. On avait compris depuis bien
longtemps comme on a des copains qui
travaillent aussi chez chez YouTube.
Là va y avoir une stérilisation des
canaux de diffusion. On rentre en guerre
dans pas très longtemps. Euh bon, le le
chef d'étatmajor est un peu en retard,
mais il va vite comprendre que ça va
arriver plus vite qu'il ne pensait. On
va se faire verrouiller.
Et puis si si tu es pas contente parce
que on fait la guerre pour la les petits
enfants, les petits enfants ukrainiens,
les petites écoles ukrainiennes, la
liberté de penser, nous le bien contre
le mal. Et ben si tu es pas contente au
goulag ou à la prison ou au camp de
redressement ou au stage d'intérêt
général pour la bonne propagande.
Disons disons en tout cas qu'il y a
moyen en effet il va y avoir moyen de
neutraliser
les voies qui peuvent essayer de ne pas
rentrer dans ce discours officiel. On
voit le l'établissement par Urso la
VERleyen du fameux Démocraty Shield.
Alors, on sait pas encore quelle forme
ça va prendre, mais évidemment que c'est
une façon là aussi de pousser le
discours officiel face au
Elle se fait un service de renseignement
à Sabotte d'ailleurs.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. Mais bien sûr, elle
est en train Bien sûr. Ah,
une grosse problème. Alors, c'est un
élément absolument essentiel ça parce
que euh on voit à quel point petit à
petit l'Union européenne est en train
d'organiser
sa propre défense.
Non seulement sa propre défense mais en
fait un système le passage à un
fédéralisme contre les contre lesquels
le peuple ne n'a pas enfin voilà contre
lesquels le peuple se se soulève dès
qu'il le peut. Regardez par exemple le
28e régime, c'est quand même un truc
extraordinaire, c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'agit d'inventer un 28e état fictif
pour euh permettre aux multinationales
de contourner les droits des différents
pays européens. Parce que vous
comprenez, avant quand une
multinationale voulait infiltrer
différents marchés, il fallait se
conformer aux droits de chacun et puis
s'il y avait un conflit, il fallait
passer devant les tribunaux de chaque
pays. Là, ce sera beaucoup plus simple.
Il y aura un régime, on fait un paradis
fiscal,
ben c'est un paradis fiscal. C'est un
paradis fiscal à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne et qui permet de pas
s'enquiquiner avec les lois qui ont été
votées par les peuples européens. C'est
formidable. Tout le monde s'en fiche,
personne n'en parle. De même, en effet,
la façon dont la Commission européenne
essaie de prendre la main sur la
défense, sur l'industrie de défense, va
y avoir un truc extrêmement important,
c'est qu'en fait derrière c'est la
capacité à décider à qui on vend des
armes et selon quelles conditions. Je
veux dire, ça relève de la souveraineté
des États. La France doit pouvoir
décider quel type d'arme elle produit, à
qui elle les vend. Or, la commission est
en train d'essayer de prendre la main
là-dessus sous prétexte que ça relève du
marché et que tout ce qui relève du
marché le le la concerne. Donc, on voit
dans énormément de domaines comment
petit à petit on grignote ce qui restait
de démocratie, c'est-à-dire de capacité
des peuples à décider de leur destin.
Donc, il va falloir là aussi se
réveiller, c'est-à-dire faire en sorte
que les peuples européens, parce qu'il y
a des mouvements dans chaque pays
européen qui prennent conscience de ça
et qui essayent de lutter contre ça.
Genre la FD en Allemagne,
non, pas la FD, non, mais en revanche,
il y a eu différentes tentatives. Alors
là, je sais que par exemple les Sarah
Wagen Knest pas particulièrement en
forme en ce moment, mais c'est la le la
montée de son mouvement était une façon
justement d'essayer de protester contre
ça. C'était un mouvement qui était assez
intéressant de ce point de vue-là. Il
existe différent. Il
fait quoi ? Il fait combien de pourcent
aux élections ?
Non non mais là là il s'est planté aux
dernières élections. Non c'est pas il
s'est planté c'est qu'il n pas
2 3 % 2 3 %
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait que ça là ?
Non mais 2 3 % c'est genre les
écologistes qui tambourinent avec un
prisme de lecture économique
géostratégique d'ord. Mais on est
d'accord. Sauf que la question
avec les socialistes d'ailleurs, pardon,
je vous je ne vous dis pas que je vous
dis pas que pour l'instant
tout ça est en train de réussir. Je vous
dis qu'on a vu surgir à certains moments
différents mouvements. Ça s'est passé en
Grèce euh et actuellement le il y a des
il y a différents mouvements politiques
en Grèce. Ça s'est passé le au moment de
la révolte agraire dans tous les pays
européens en aux Pays-Bas, en Allemagne,
en Pologne. Bon, tout ça montre que ça
bouillonne de toute parts. Le problème,
c'est qu'il y a pas de voix pour
l'instant. Il y a pas de tout simplement
parce que les Allemands eux sont en
train d'essayer d'étouffer ça. La seule
chose qui les intéresse, c'est de sauver
leur modèle qui est déjà mort. Donc
le je le la guerre en Ukraine a tué le
modèle allemand. Le problème, c'est
qu'entre-temps, on les avait laissé
prendre la main sur l'ensemble des
institutions européennes. Donc ça, on
voit comment la tentative de sauver les
exportations vers la Chine, vers les
États-Unis sont à peu près l'unique but
de l'Allemagne en ce moment. Alors je
parenthèse dans la parenthèse dans la
parenthèse
on va se positionner on va se focaliser
un peu sur l'Allemagne. Donc nous en
France on a des stupides, des des
crétins de la géopolitique, de la
stratégie de la guerre économique ou une
chaîne de conmandement qui n'est pas
respectée. On va leur laisser le
bénéfice du doute.
En Allemagne, ils ont des débiles
profonds. Non.
Alors là, les dépiles profonds sont en
train de se rattraper en voulant faire
1000 milliards de dettes pour se
réarmer, refaire le service militaire,
une Allemagne réarmée avec un service
militaire. Nous français, on sait ce que
c'est, ce que ça va donner.
C'est justement pour ça, c'est pas du
tout débil profond avec un système
aussi, c'est des débiles profonds. Non,
on fait pas les malins avec une
puissance nucléaire comme ça.
Ah non, mais attendez, ça oui, mais
c'est pas des débiles dans le sens.
Et donc les Allemands, du moins le
pouvoir politique allemand parce que
c'est sensiblement les mêmes crétins
qu'on a chez nous,
il va faire quoi ? Il va nous faire une
bonne guerre pour effacer leurs
conneries, ils vont saisir l'épargne
pour effacer leurs conneries. Ils v ils
vont faire les malins combien de temps
encore ? que ser armé 1000 milliards,
faire passer la dette française comme
une vieille prostituée âgée notre dette
parce que quand les Allemands débarquent
à mon avis nous on va être moins frais
hein. Il serait 1000 milliards, ils
commencent à concentrer tout ça, ils
vont forcément partir en guerre derrière
leur système hypergivore basé sur la
haute technologie hyper dissipatrice
d'énergie et ils sont cuits. Quand vous
avez une nation avec des trépanés
qui se réarment, il se passe quoi à la
fin quand ils ont les chien au cul et
qu'il y a plus rien dans les frigos ?
Ils sont dans la position du noyer qui
va essayer d'entraîner par le fond tous
ceux qui veulent les sauver. C'est ça le
truc. Donc, ils sont en train
d'entraîner par le fond le reste de
l'Union européenne parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas admettre que leur modèle est
mort et que ce modèle qui a d'ailleurs
été encensé par toute la classe
politique et médiatique française
pendant des années. Il faut se souvenir
quand même Anguela Merkel qui était une
espèce de divinité, c'était fabuleux.
Moi, j'ai écrit des trucs sur le le
enfin d'ailleurs, j'ai écrit non, j'ai
permis j'ai fait écrire des trucs
notamment par Coralie de l'ôme qui était
tu voilà qui qui a écrit des choses
formidables sur le le la façon dont
Anguela Merkel avait tout simplement ben
organisé. C'était il y avait trois trois
dépendances, he on le sait, la
dépendance au gaz russes pas cher,
dépendance aux exportations vers les
vers vers la Chine et dépendance au
parapluis américain. C'est-à-dire que
enfin, on parlait de souveraineté tout à
l'heure, avoir encensé pendant des
années un modèle qui était dépendant de
l'extérieur, c'était une folie. Et
pourtant en France, quand on écrivait
ça, on était traité de germanophobe.
Donc maintenant, on s'aperçoit à quel
point c'était une erreur. Sauf
queentre-temps, les Allemands, eux, ils
ont bossé. Contrairement à notre classe
politique, eux ils envoient, c'est très
simple, les les Allemands quand il quand
ils doivent envoyer des du personnel à
Bruxelles, ils prennent les meilleurs.
Ils prennent ceux les les haut
fonctionnaires, les avocats qui sont les
plus pointus et qui vont aller défendre
les intérêts allemands. On a on a une
vidéo en tête euh d'une délégation
allemande
à Bruxelles où Nations- Unies se foutant
royalement de la gueule de Trump qui les
alertait concernant le gaz russe où on
voyait leur délégation
pouffer de rire. Bon maintenant il
pouffent moins de rire.
Ouais il pouvent. en peut-être pas les
meilleurs, ils envoient peut-être les
les plus laorenciens, ceux qui ont un
bon réflexe.
Ils envoient ceux qui sont là pour
défendre les intérêts allemands ou en
tout cas ce qu'ils croient être les
intérêts allemands. Nous, quand on
envoie des fonctionnaires à Bruxelles,
on envoie ceux qui ont envie d'y aller
et qui ont et ils ont envie d'y aller
parce que ils trouvent que l'Europe est
une belle idée et qu'il faut la défendre
et cetera.
Je suis pas d'accord avec votre
raisonnement. Nous on a envoyé le
meilleur. On envoie les meilleurs.
Ouais.
Harlem avant
comment
Arlem Désir aussi il y a eu en ministre
de l'Europe.
C'est Non non, on a vraiment on
sélectionne. Non non, je vous jure c'est
enfin pardon mais on voit à quel point
on ne défend pas les intérêts français.
Je c'est on sait pas faire de guerre
économique. Or l'Union européenne a été
créée sur la mise en concurrence des
espaces. Donc vous avez en permanence
des des pays européens qui soutiennent
leur PME et qui essayent de torpiller
les PME des pays concurrents. C'est
c'est des principes très simples.
Regardez, je vous cite un exemple, une
boîte néerlandaise
qui qui fait en sorte que on finance une
étude lancée donc financée par le
Parlement européen sur fond européen sur
le le bien-être des coiffeurs, les
conditions de vie des coiffeurs. C'est
un exemple très con mais c'est très
c'est très parlant. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
le Parlement européen, on demande au
Parlement européen de faire ça ? parce
queon va découvrir que dans les lacs et
cetera, il y a des produits
cancérogènes.
Pourquoi la PME néerlandaise, elle a
demandé, elle a fait en sorte que le
Parlement européen via les députés
néerlandais paye ça ? B parce que elle
elle a un autre produit à mettre dans
des lacs donc elle peut avoir le
monopole et donc elle torpie tous ses
concurrents. C'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne l'Union européenne. Sauf que
si les Français eux ils soutiennent pas
leur leur leur PME, bah on se fait on se
fait totalement avoir. Les aides d'État
par exemple, il y a eu des aides d'État.
C'est c'est il a fallu se battre pour ça
puisque surtout ça c'est considéré comme
le mal absolu quand un État aide son
économie. C'est le le dogme européen, le
dogme de la concurrence. Mais depuis le
Covid,
il y a des aides d'État qui ont été
autorisées.
Alors, évidemment, quel pays a demandé
le plus de droits à fournir des aides
d'État ? L'Allemagne, bien sûr. 45 % de
des demandes, c'est l'Allemagne.
Ensuite, il y a eu la France qui a
demandé, voilà, et ça nous a été
accordé. L'Allemagne
a, si j'ai bonne mémoire sur les
chiffres, l'Allemagne a donc versé
80 milliards d'aides d'État si je me
souviens bien. Voilà, la France, ben on
a versé 3 % des aides d'État qui nous
étaient accordé. C'est qu'on aurait le
droit d'aider notre économie. On ne l'a
pas fait. On ne l'a pas fait. Tout est
comme ça. Je pourrais vous citer des
dizaines d'exemples. Donc ça veut dire
que on a une classe politique qui ne
fait pas le boulot. C'est pas le
problème, c'est pas que l'Europe est
faible. Enfin si bien sûr qu'on est on
s'y prend comme des trucs, mais le
problème c'est que la France est faible
en Europe. C'est que la France ne défend
pas ses intérêts en Europe.
OK. Nous, on a eu de la chance, on a été
formé par des vieux cons. On a eu
l'autorisation de s'aiguiser les canines
sur leur vieilles carnes et de le faire
sans aucun filtre. quit à de temps en
temps friser les combats de chaises des
vrais jouatoires à l'ancienne
les vieux qui nous ont former
en guerre économique
en ingénierie
ils avaient la France chevillée au corps
et au cœur là c'est quoi nos politiques
c'est de la forfaiture
c'est des crétins. C'est des crétins qui
sont polyaddictés addictif ou de
polyaddiction pardon. Ils ont des
polyaddictions et y compris au pouvoir.
Ils sont mégalot, c'est des capsis.
Est-ce que c'est pas des capsis
ou c'est simplement des gros crétins ?
Premier point,
sélectionné par des écoles de crétins,
allant à des rally de crétins, [rires]
dans des dans des buffets de crétins où
l'objectif c'est de s'échanger des
petites cartes de visite en levant le
petit doigt et en ayant la plus belle
cartonnée.
Ouais.
Vous connaissez cette ambiance là ? On
jamais infiltré ce genre de soirée. Ça
mourir de rire.
Je non, je ça ça me moi
faut qu'on y aille ensemble.
Ça me rend ça me rend dépressif. Je peux
pas. Non, il faut parce queil faut
alors soyons clair, moi je c j'ai foi en
l'être humain, donc j'ai envie de garder
cette foi en l'être humain. Donc je
n'irai pas dans ce genre d'endroit.
Voilà. Donc premier point, oui, il y a
euh un problème avec alors ça c'est au
plus haut niveau, je la le le régime des
partis associés à l'élection du
président de la République au suffrage
universel,
potentiellement, ça sélectionne ceux qui
sont obsédés par le pouvoir, ça
sélectionne les narcissiques. Ça c'est
le premier point. 2è point, il y a
indéiablement une baisse de niveau. Mais
dans tous les domaines, dans toutes les
échelles de la société, il y a une
baisse de niveau. Je vous discutez avec
des secrétaires des débats à
l'Assemblée, ceux qui sont chargés de
noter tout ce que disent les députés. En
général, ils ont une culture immense ces
gens-là. J'en connais qui connaissent
tous les grands discours de la 3e
République et cetera. Ce qui m'explique,
c'est que maintenant les références les
plus employées par les députés à
l'Assemblée, c'est alors le sparadra du
capitaine Adoc,
le serpent KA, alors pas celui de Rodiar
Kipling hein, celui de Disney et vol de
mort. Ça c'est ce que vous trouvez comme
référence.
Vol de mort ça.
Voilà. Mais c'est d'accord,
je veux dire alors pas encore mais ça va
venir. Je le et je pourrais ajouter les
phrases que je ne supporte plus
d'entendre. Un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités. Ça c'est les
mecs qui ont regardé Spider-Man. Alors
voyez c'est autrefois on citait Pascal,
on citait Château Brillant. Là
maintenant, c'est ça. Donc
indéiablement, il y a une baisse de
niveau, c'est très clair. Et euh moi, je
suis de ceux qui estime que euh
n'importe qui qui prétend exercer le
pouvoir devrait avoir lu, par exemple
les vies parallèles de Plutarc pour
avoir un tout petit peu de recul sur ce
que c'est que le pouvoir, l'appétit de
pouvoir, ce que c'est que la guerre, ce
que c'est. Voilà, ça ça c'est pas mal.
Ça devrait être obligatoire comme
lecture. Mais
il faudrait déjà commencer par des
concours de lecture.
C'est ça.
Non. Alors, donc on était là-dessus.
Donc, il y a le narcissisme, il y a la
baisse de niveau et après il y a
l'absence totale de patriotisme en
effet. Alors, la question c'est pourquoi
? Pourquoi quand on regarde sur les 40
dernières années, ce sont les Français
qui ont dérégulé comme des fous, qui ont
accepté toutes les les règles de l'OMC ?
Je veux dire Jacques Deor, l'acte unique
européen, Pascal l'ami mis à la tête de
l'OMC. Globalement, c'est le le
socialisme français a quand même excellé
dans l'adhésion au néolibéralisme. C'est
fabuleux. Alors, je pense que il y a
d'abord une espèce d'universalisme
français dévoyé. C'estàd que
l'universalisme
a été tordu pour aboutir à cette idée
que finalement la nation c'est médiocre.
On est tellement mieux quand on pense à
l'échelle du monde. C'est une forme de
prétention totale. Et du coup, ces
gens-là ont considéré que la nation
c'était méprisable actuellement.
Accessoirement la nation c'est aussi
c'est le peuple en fait. Et le peuple
pour ces gens-là c'est méprisable.
Voilà, tout tous ces gens, c'est dégueu.
Ben évidemment, mais vous voyez la la
quintessence de la technocratie
française, c'est l'idée euh ces gens
sont bon, ils sont pas très compétents,
on va faire leur bonheur malgré eux
parce que nous on sait. C'est ça, c'est
ça que pensent ces gens. Ils sont
convaincus. Quand vous avez des mecs qui
dans un bureau vous disent "On va mettre
les 80 km/h parce que ces gens savent
pas conduire et voilà, ça va être pour
leur bien et que à aucun moment ils ne
perçoivent la colère qui monte petit à
petit un peu partout. Il suffisait de se
balader en France pour voir le sentiment
d'humiliation des gens face à ce genre
de décision. C'est et c'est pas grave,
on continue puis ensuite on va leur
mettre une taxe parce que ils sont bien
mignons, vous vous souvenez à fumer des
clopes et rouler au diesel. Voilà hein,
c'est pareil quand on voit ça c'était
Benjamin Griveau et alors le top du top
souvenez-vous Grivu c'est celui qui
s'est fait enfoncer au Fenwick. Voilà.
Donc le mieux c'est quand même les
premières manifes de gilets jaunes, le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque qui
parle de peste brune quand il voit des
gens qui manifestent juste pour demander
le droit à vivre de leur travail.
C'était qui ce ministre de l'intérieur
de l'époque ? Christophe Castaner qui a
été embauché par Chine pour faire le
lobbing d'une entreprise chinoise qui
détruit ce qui nous reste d'industrie et
ce qui nous reste de commerce. C'est
vous voyez le c'est un travail comme un
autre.
Non mais c'est quand on parle d'absence
totale de patriotisme de sens de de
l'état mais c'est monstrueux. C'est un
scandale absolu.
Ça c'est rien ça.
Non c'est c'est caractéristiqu non par
Staner qui va chercher un peu de de flou
chein là.
Absolum c'est absolument pardon je
rarement ce mot là c'est dégueulasse.
OK. Non mais c'est simple un général
français qui va bosser chez Microsoft
sans respecter le d carence.
Non mais c'est pareil. C'est
non mais c'est pareil tout ça. C'est
alors je sais pas lequel c'est
insupportable. C'est insupportable.
Voilà c'est c'est le c'est lequel
ça ? Je sais pas maisons à tout temps.
Donc oui non mais c'est tout le temps,
c'est tout le temps, c'est tout le
temps. Et les Français ils continuent à
se comment comment on pourrait dire ça
d'une façon suffisamment pas vulgaire
pour éviter de se faire striker notre
chaîne YouTube mais qu'on comprenne bien
le fond de notre idée.
Les Français, ils vont arrêter de se
passer de la vaseline sur les fesses
encore combien de temps ?
Bah pardon, mais les Français ils
expriment leur colère, leur indignation.
Ça surgit de façon sporadique. Il y a eu
les gilets jaunes. Il y a eu les
alors les gilets jaunes qui ont été
réprimés façon euh état du tiers monde.
Ouais.
En France.
Oui. Oui. Tout à fait.
Les journalistes ont craché sur les
gilets jaunes. Euh nous, ils nous ont
fait des papiers. Ils nous ont fait des
papiers sur nous comme quoi on avait
pris beaucoup d'abonnés pendant les
gilets jaunes et donc forcément on était
gilets jaunés et donc forcément on était
d'extrême droite ou forcément on était
d'extrême gauche.
Ouais. Mais bon, c'est
Non, non, mais
un jour, on vous expliquera pourquoi on
a ce surnom là.
La vengeance vient toujours du ciel.
Revenons à notre caste journalistique
main dans la main avec notre caste
politicienne.
Bon, le niveau est affaibli. On se
demande d'ailleurs comment ils font pas
comment ils font pour pas se faire caca
dessus avec les trois neurones qu'il
leur restent.
Là, ils se feront attraper par la
réalité. Il y a la guerre en Ukraine qui
est une guerre de ressources qui était
une guerre qui couvait depuis avant
2014. Oui,
on voit la biené depuis les années 90
2000. C'est-à-dire qu'on voit la façon
dont les États-Unis ont poussé le chacun
son tour.
J'ai pas le droit de
Non, mais je je termine, je je mets la
la
je mets la le contexte. On se retrouve
avec notre classe de clerger médiatique
qui a nous indiqué toi tu es gentil, toi
tu es méchant, toi tu es un popof, toi
tu es pas un popof, toi Bon là ça
commence à piquer un peu. Ça va être
compliqué de soutenir ce genre
d'argumentaire avec la réalité qui va
frapper. Nos politiciens, nos
journalistes, notre upper classe
intellectuelle,
ils vont terminer comment ? Parce que
nous, on s'intéresse aux fondamentaux
énergétiques de l'industrie, au genre de
conneries qui pue, qui fait des
particules, mais qui fait bouffer les
gens. On s'intéresse à la guerre
économique. Quels sont les dispositifs ?
Qu'est-ce que fait la Chine pour dinguer
le dollar en se positionnant sur l'or,
en rapatriant ? Et que fait la Russie
qui s'était préparé bien avant
2022 ? Évidemment,
on a essayé d'alerter mais on a eu la
patrouille.
Vous cracher dessus. On a rencontré
Laavrof en 2019 en marge du forum pour
la paix. On l'a regardé droit dans les
yeux et on lui a dit il y a la guerre
qui arrive. Nous prenez pas pour des
cons.
Derrière on a eu le baiser de la mort de
Zakarova qui a publié les photos. On
leur avait bien dit qu'on voulait pas
voir notre tête. Derrière on a eu la
patrouille payée par les Anglais qui
nous est tombé sur la gueule.
La patrouille payée par les Anglais
depuis 2016.
Depuis 2016. Oui, ça c'est s'appelait le
integrity
intégrity initiative. Mais ils vont
pouvoir vous dire "Oui, mais c'était
pour faire de la contre-ingérence
russe." Voilà. Bon, il va falloir nous
expliquer un peu comment ils ont fait
pour recruter des mecs d'active
sur certains de nos ministères
et comment la DGSI et la DGSE a laissé
faire.
Donc on rencontre machin machin derrière
on se fait dépouiller comme on est un
peu avec le cuir dur,
on spotte ces gens-là
puis quand on les voit ressurgir on
continue de les spotter pour voir pour
se remettre en question aussi. Peut-être
que c'est interdit d'aller discuter avec
l'ennemi parce que l'ennemi, il est con.
L'ennemi il sait pas que c'est l'ennemi.
Mais nous on est peut-être con parce que
comme on discute pas avec l'ennemi, on
sait pas comment pense l'ennemi, où ce
qu'il va faire.
Donc ça qui est infusé distyé dans nos
médias.
Le français, il a plus le temps là de
s'endurcir le cerveau, de se trouver une
classe politique, de se trouver un
beau-parleur ou un mec qui va dédier sa
vie à crever pour la France. On a plus
le temps, on prévient notre communauté
maintenant. Ça va tellement s'accélérer
que vous allez même plus voir le jour
passer.
Natacha Poloni, les objectifs pour
inverser la vapeur.
C'est quoi ? Point 1, point 2,3.
Point 1. Alors en effet le temps est
compté, il faut aller vite mais il faut
rassembler tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
partagent ces ces idéesl partagent cette
vision et qui sont majoritaires dans le
pays. Je parce que attention qu'il y ait
des gens qui est lâché qui disent je
veux plus m'enmêler. Oui, on le sait
tous. Il y a des gens qui ont fait ses
sessions, on dit "Attendez, ils font ce
qu'ils veulent. Moi, je vote plus, je
m'informe plus, je cherche pas." Voilà.
Même ceux-là, ils attendent tout
simplement qu'il se passe quelque chose.
Ils attendent qu'à un moment donné, il y
a une fenêtre, il y a quelque chose qui
s'ouvre. Donc ça nécessite de préparer
les idées. Moi, c'est pour ça que je
crée une revue. C'est parce que cette
revue, elle permet de rassembler tous
ceux qui justement ont pas envie de se
résigner. Je tout ce que vous décrivez,
je le vois venir. Oui, je vois venir les
dangers. Oui, je vois venir les
tensions, je vois venir potentiellement
la guerre parce qu'on est lancé dans une
course aux ressources et qu'on voit très
bien, on voit très bien qu'on est dans
une guerre de course aux matières
premières, aux terrar rares, enfin
toutes les toute la la politique de
Trump se s'analyse à l'ône de la
conquête des matières premières. Ça se
voit. Donc, on voit très bien à quel
point l'Europe est totalement au frais
là-dessus. Il faut absolument faire
entendre ça et rassembler tous ceux qui
ont dans l'idée qu'on doit pouvoir mener
une politique qui soit différente.
Voilà.
Vote quoi ?
Ça, on verra.
Non,
il y a il y a un principe qui est un
principe gram chien. On prépare d'abord
intellectuellement
Ouais.
On prépare les idées
et une fois que les idées sont là, on
inverse la vapeur. C'est c'est
fondamental. En général, c'est juste on
se prépare puis ça ressemble de la
pougette d'intellectuel, pas du tout
opératif.
Non non non, ça c'est pas vrai. Non non,
c'est pas c'est ça. Je suis désolé. Euh
je provoque là, on s'énerve un peu
Natacha. Mais bien sûr, mais je suis
d'un naturel calme. Voilà justement.
Oui, il faut se méfier de l'eau qui
dort.
Moi, j'ai j'ai une capacité
d'indignation,
j'ai une capacité de colère,
mais je garde mon calme, je m'affole
pas. C'est quoi ? C'est une colère
froide ?
Ouais.
C'est c'est comment on appelle ça ?
C'est passive agressif.
Alors non, ça c'est pas ça du tout. Non
non, c'est simplement que moi il y a des
trucs qui me rendent dingues,
c'est-à-dire justement l'incompétence,
l'absence de patriotisme, l'hypocrisie,
le l'injustice. Tout ça me rend dingue.
Pour autant, j'estime que mon boulot à
moi, c'est de pas juste m'exciter euh
dire me donner le beau rôle en venant
gueuler sur tel ou tel truc.
c'est de concevoir les différents
éléments qui permettent de changer,
d'inverser la vapeur. C'est de
rassembler tous les gens qui croient que
on n'est pas condamné à ce scénario.
Donc on les rassemble, on fait des
conférences partout en France. C'est ça
le but de l'audace. L'audace, c'est pas
seulement une revue papier, c'est une
agora. On va aller partout et on va voir
si ça répond, si ça prend, si les gens
sont OK pour nous suivre et pour
proposer. On est force de proposition et
là on va voir qu'on est potentiellement
majoritaire dans le pays.
OK. Quand vous allez être identifié
comme potentiellement, passez-moi
l'expression, casse-couille,
on va vous neutraliser. Alors, ça
prendra peut-être la forme d'un contrôle
fiscal, ça prendra peut-être la forme de
on va trouver un cocaïnoman dans votre
équipe ou on va trouver un petit kilo
chez vous ou des choses comme ça.
[rires]
Ce ser ce serait pas très crédible. On
peut on peut trouver quelques bonnes
bouteilles, ça oui.
Pourquoi quelques Merde, Pericot ?
Perico, il doit connaître les bonnes
bouteilles. Merde.
Ça oui, ça on a
Et vous vous connaissez les bonnes
bouteilles ? Ça
? Oui,
c'est de la faute de Péricot. Vous
l'aviez déjà avant ce talent ? Vous
croyez vraiment que j'aurais pu me
mettre en couple, me marier avec un
critique gastronomique, défenseur du
patrimoine culinaire, du vin et cetera
si j'aimais pas ça ?
Franchement, je vais vous dire un truc.
Pour moi, c'est tout. C'est la France,
ça. C'est la France. Et la France, c'est
un mode de vie. C'est une façon d'être
au monde. D'abord parce que on aime on
aime ce qui est beau et on aime ce qui
est bon. Non non mais je suis désolée.
C'est moi qui suis désolé. Ça c'est
fondamental.
Pourquoi com une phrase par je suis
désolée ? Il faut arrêter d'être désolé
maintenant. On est français on n'est pas
français. On est français et on est
heureux et on est fier de l'être parce
que c'est un modèle la France. Vous
savez dans le le discours au mort de
Périclè dans la guerre du péloponaise il
y a un truc absolument génial. Donc
c'est le plus beau texte qui a jamais
été écrit sur la démocratie parce que
donc j'explique un peu le contexte.
Guard du péloponaise qui est déclenché
depuis un an. Donc conflit majeur dans
tout le monde grec entre Athè et Spart
et tous leurs alliés. Et euh Péricles
qui est le chef de guerre athénien au
bout d'un an prononce un éloge funèbre
pour les morts de la première année de
guerre. Et évidemment quand on s'adresse
aux morts, on s'adresse aux vivants.
Donc il explique pourquoi on se bat.
Voilà. Et donc il dit voilà on se bat
parce que nous notre système c'est la
démocratie. Et il décrit ce qu'est la
démocratie. C'est extraordinaire.
Premier point, la démocratie, c'est la
liberté d'agir comme on veut. Donc il
explique, nous sommes libre dans notre
vie. Personne va venir nous enquiquiner,
regarder ce que fait le voisin et cetera
du moment que dans l'espace public, nous
respectons les lois. Donc c'est la
liberté appuyée sur la séparation entre
espace public et espace privé. Ensuite,
il dit "Nous accordons les postes euh
non pas en fonction des de la naissance,
mais en fonction du mérite. C'est
l'égalité. On est égau devant la loi,
mais on sélectionne en fonction du
mérite, égalité, méritocratie. Et
derrière, nous respectons les lois et en
particulier celles qui protègent les
plus faibles, c'est la fraternité.
Alors, on y ajoute un truc
spécifiquement grec puisqu'il dit en
particulier les lois non écrites, celle
que dont la transgression rejette
l'opprre sur celui qui a transgressé. Ça
c'est un truc hélas qui nous manque. Les
Grecs appelaient ça aidos. Et l'aidos,
c'est la vergogne. Rien que le mot, il
existe plus mais c'est un des plus beaux
mots de la langue française.
Aujourd'hui, on ne parle que de ceux qui
n'ont pas de vergogne, qui sont sans
vergogne. Justement parce que plus
personne n'en a. C'est le sens de
l'honneur, la pudeur, le fait d'exister
sous le regard des autres. Mais
derrière, il a cette phrase
extraordinaire. Il dit "Voilà et puis
nous nous aimons la beauté, nous
arrangeons bien nos maisons avec goût et
cetera parce que en fait dans cet esprit
démocratique, il y a aussi ça aussi les
plaisirs de la vie." Alors, évidemment
qu'il y avait des esclaves mais ça c'est
une dimension de comment dire d'un
principe économique de l'époque et on
n'est pas obligé de de croire que la
démocratie ne peut exister que comme ça.
Mais en revanche, cette description de
la démocratie en disant voilà dans la
démocratie il y a le il y a l'amour du
beau et le plaisir. C'est-à-dire on on
vit pas, c'est pas une culture de mort,
c'est le but, c'est que les gens soient
heureux. Et bien moi ça m'évoque en fait
quand j'étais euh jeune journaliste,
c'était en 2006,
il y a 5 ans,
c'était il y a beaucoup plus longtemps
que ça. Donc en 2006, j'étais à Marianne
comme jeune journaliste et Jean-François
Cann qui avait toujours des idées assez
délirantes, euh voulait organiser des
reportages pendant l'été 2006 pour
préparer des reportages politiques pour
préparer toute la campagne
présidentielle. Et donc il me dit vous
allez aller faire un reportage sur le
centrisme en région centre.
C'était pas complètement idiot. Il y
avait un pôle modem en région centre.
Mais je me retrouve donc sur le marché
de de Valençais avec la photographe du
journal assez parisienne et cetera.
J'arrive dans la boulangerie. Bonjour
madame, est-ce que vous connaissez
François Bairou ? Boulangère me regarde.
Qui ça ? Excusez-moi. Non, je c'est mon
mari qui suit la politique. Moi non.
Enfin, tout était comme ça. Bon, et je
tombe sur le serrurier coordonnier
ambulant du marché de Valençais. Et là,
le mec m' commence à rentrer dans une
colère. Il me dit "Écoutez, moi, mon but
dans la vie, c'est d'emmener mon gamin
pêcher dans la rivière et on nous
l'interdit, nous mettre des normes à la
con, des trucs." Voilà. Et puis mon but,
c'est d'aller faire de la moto avec mon
mom et de l'emmener et on peut plus
parce qu'il faut respecter les trucs et
cetera. et moi j'en ai marre et je le
système pète et j'ai voté Front National
et je vais recommencer et cetera.
Et je me souviens, on s'en va de là et
la photographe était toute traumatisée
me dit "Mais mais ils sont horribles ces
gens." Je dis "Mais enfin tu es
démocrate." Voilà. Bah la dé
ils sont horribles ces gens parce qu'ils
étaient pas lavés parce qu'il vot Front
national. Non non parce que c'était pas
bien, il vota Front National et
je dis mais enfin quand tu es démocrate
ton but c'est le bonheur de ces gens. Ce
mec il veut juste voilà son bonheur
c'est d'aller pêcher à la ligne avec son
mom. C'est ça le bonheur. Bah la
question c'est comment tu inventes un
système qui permet aux gens d'être
heureux tout simplement sur c'est
quelle était ma question ?
Je sais pas et ça nous rien à
C'est ça.
Voilà, vous venez avec vos questions,
moi je viens avec le Ouais. Qui est-ce
qui disait ça ?
George Marchet. [rires] C'est ça. Paix à
son âme. George Marchet, c'est celui qui
voulait qui était communiste et
qui voulait tous les immigrés
dehors. C'est ça.
Alors, il voulait pas les immigré
dehors, mais il considérait que la
préservation du comment dire de du de
l'industrie française permettait de
payer correctement les salariés et que
donc l'importation de gens qui faisaient
baisser les salaires, c'était une ça
servait avant tout les intérêts du
patronat. Vous a fait vous savez imiter
l'accent de George Marchet ?
Non, je me lancerai pas dans les
imitations.
D'accord. Donc quand vous allez être
identifié comme casse bonbon par le
pouvoir politique parce que vous donnez
une tribune à des gens qui pensent pas
bien ou qui pensent pas comme vous ouz
avec des gens comme c comme ça comme ça
que vous commencez à avoir de l'impact
que les gens vous écoutent vous lisent.
Bon, quand on va commencer à vous couper
les
les tendons d'Achil de la visibilité
médiatique sur YouTube ou sur Facebook
ou sur X réseaux sociaux que votre
plateforme d'abonnement
ça marchera pas. Vous allez faire quoi ?
Comme tous les vous allez faire comme
tous les journalistes, vous allez faire
quoi ?
Vous allez faire une cagnotte, vous
allez faire la manche ? Vous allez
demander des subventions ? Non non, moi
j'irais Alors, je pars du principe
d'abord, je je réagis pas en
journaliste, c'est pas ça la question.
Je
passe par tous les biais où je peux me
sentir utile. Voilà. Donc d'abord le le
shadow banning, les trucs comme ça. Moi,
j'ai vu ce que ça donnait quand je
dirigeais Marianne, hein. On y a eu
droit. Bon, notamment à un moment où il
s'agissait de se battre contre Google
sur les les droits voisins, les choses
comme ça. C'était assez marrant de voir
les le le comment dire sur le site
internet Google s'amusait à nous faire
jour nuit, jour nuit comme ça d'un jour
à l'autre. C'était assez curieux. Donc
donc oui, je sais comment ça fonctionne.
Bon bah il y a il y a d'autres moyens,
on les utilise tous. Il faut les
utiliser tous en même temps.
Ça ça s'attaque pas au à la cour à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme ?
Alors là e ouais c'est ça, on va aller
demander l'autorisation sur la vente
derleyenne aussi et puis on va hein
c'est on va signer des pétitions
revenons donc revenons à à jour nuouit
journuit donc vous êtes identifié comme
il faut vous faire terire
vous allez avoir une campagne de
calomnie comme quoi votre mari porte des
tutus ou vous vous baladez en cuir avec
des fouets que vous avez
et je me balade en cuir très souvent
vous savez [rires]
je le sais
Euh ce qui vous va d'ailleurs très bien.
Ben j'espère.
Oui. Merde. Euh
quand vous
C'est quoi la question ?
Ouais. La sisigie, l'alignement des
planètes de votre cascouiri, le fait que
vous ayez un cerveau, que vous soyez
patriote et que la France bah c'est
votre première maman et vous allez la
défendre quoi qu'il en coûte.
Le pouvoir essaie de vous neutraliser.
C'est quoi votre stratégie face à ça ?
L'obstination,
c'est tout. C'est-à-dire que il y a un
moment où je pense que quand on lâche
pas,
ça passe. Alors, on verra bien. Encore
une fois, il y a différents moyens. J'ai
la chance moi, d'avoir pour l'instant un
accès, on va dire, à une certaine
visibilité dans différents domaines.
C'estàd un peu sur les réseaux sociaux,
dans les médias, dans les médias
mainstream. Voilà, j'ai une voix qui est
audible. Pourquoi ? parce que j'ai eu
j'ai eu de la chance dans dans ma dans
ma carrière, c'est-à-dire que j'ai eu
j'ai pu participer à des émissions où il
y avait une certaine liberté et j'ai
utilisé cette liberté. Voilà. Donc j'ai
fait en sorte de défendre ce que je
croyais juste et j'avoue que je me suis
jamais posé la question de savoir si ça
allait m'être reproché. Donc, il a pu
m'arriver d'être bah blacklisté de
certaines chaînes, de certains trucs,
peu importe. J'ai continué, j'ai tracé
ma route. Donc là actuellement, j'ai une
visibilité, une notoriété qui fait qu'il
y a des gens qui savent quelles sont les
idées que je défends et qui ont l'air de
considérer, en tout cas quand je les
croise dans le métro ou en fin fond de
la France, dans de voilà que euh bah je
dis ce que je pense. D'ailleurs, vous le
voyez, c'està-dire que je a priori je
sais très mal mentir.
Personne entière. Alors, on confirme
parce qu'on vous connaît depuis 10 ans.
Personne entière de paroles.
Deux paroles.
Bah ça
on peut avoir des joratoir ensemble sur
des sujets. On n'est pas d'accord.
Oui.
Tout en se respectant et ma question
c'était on vote pour qui aux prochaines
élections ?
Alors là pour l'instant
c'est pas gagné.
On va être on est d'accord là le paysage
est absolument constant. Mais
consternant. C'est-à-dire qu'on a que
des gens qui à mon avis n'ont absolument
pas compris quels sont les enjeux. Je
disais tout à l'heure que de toute
façon, ils acceptent d'être
minoritaires, c'est pas leur problème.
Ils se pensent que ça va passer quand
même et qu'ils vont pouvoir faire leur
truc. Donc là, l'état actuel du paysage
politique, mais c'est c'est un problème
d'offre en fait parce que très
franchement quand on est là et qu'on
regarde le fameux la fameuse
tripartition de du paysage politique, la
l'assemblée, c'est très simple. On voit
qu'il a à chaque fois 2/3 qui détestent
le dernier et qui veulent surtout pas
que le dernier tiers euh gouverne. Donc
vous avez 2/3 qui euh ont identifié que
le système économique défendu par la
Macronie nous nous emmène dans le mur
qui donc veulent une rupture. Sauf que
ils sont des deux côtés. Vous avez 2
tiers qui ne veulent pas du
Rassemblement national. Ça s'est vu. Je
c'est pas le le il y a eu un front
républicain qui consistait en des
désistements de politique, mais il y a
surtout des des gens des Français qui
ont dit mais on veut pas que le
Rassemblement national euh gouverne
parce que il considèrent que ça va
amplifier les fractures. Voilà. Et puis
vous en avez de tiers qui veulent pas
d'un parti qu'il considère comme
communautariste qui qui
amplifie là aussi les les fractures, qui
considère qui explique que la police tue
et cetera et cetera. Bah là, je voulais
dessiner en creux, mais ça veut dire que
si on va en plein, on l'a l'offre
politique majoritaire.
C'est ça. C'est la le mariage entre la
gauche républicaine et le gaolisme
social. C'est-à-dire, on change
économique pour retrouver un système
économique qui défend la production, qui
défend donc la possibilité pour la
France de défendre ses intérêts. On
défend l'ordre parce que et la
République parce que la République c'est
la méritocratie, c'est la c'est la
promesse que vous allez pas être jugé en
fonction de votre naissance mais que
vous pourrez vous élever. Donc ça
nécessite accessoirement parce qu'on en
a pas encore parlé mais un léger travail
sur les conditions d'éducation sur la la
politique éducative qui est le sujet
dont tout le monde se fiche qui
n'apparaît jamais dans les campagnes
électorales. Voilà et donc vous le voyez
c'est pas baissé on n pas baissé le le
budget de l'éducation nationale pour
aller payer des pensions de boomer.
Bah c'est tout le problème. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait le budget de l'éducation
nationale on vous explique à chaque fois
que il augmente.
Alors, d'abord d'abord en effet, il y en
a toute une partie qui sert à payer les
retraites des enseignants. Donc qui va
pas pour payer le système éducatif, mais
même accessoirement, on avait fait le
travail euh c'était Jean-Michel 4 points
qui avait fait ça. Il avait fait tout un
travail pour calculer, c'était bien
avant que Emmanuel Macron fasse son
émission à TF1 avec ouvons 1000 € de
dépenses publiques et cetera. Nous, on
avait fait le boulot en en à l'époque,
c'était 1997.
Vous vous aperceviez que en fait si on
si on dépensait si on je si on
consacrait la même proportion de
dépenses à l'éducation en 2017 qu'en
1997, il y aurait 11 milliards de plus
par an pour l'éducation. Voilà, c'est
que petit à petit ça se réduit. Tout le
régalien se réduit. Alors c'est le
évidemment les dépenses sociales qui ont
augmenté sauf que les dépenses sociales,
elles sont la conséquence de quoi ? de
la désindustrialisation.
C'est que quand il faut payer le chômage
de masse et heureusement qu'on on
indemnise le chômage de masse, mais
quand on a laissé partir tous les
emplois et qu'on garde plus que des
emplois de service qui sont souvent des
emplois sans aucun statut sous-payés,
par exemple toutes les aides, tous les
services d'aide à la personne qui sont
souvent des emplois payés par la
puissance publique, ah ben évidemment,
il y a plus aucune richesse. Quand en
plus vous laissez des multinationales
échapper à l'impôt parce que vous êtes
dans un système de paradis fiscal où
avec des prix de transfert, vous avez
des boîtes qui peuvent payer qui payent
la marque et des tas de trucs bidons à
la à la maison mer qui est située au
Pays-Bas ou en Irlande, c'est sûr que
l'État n'a plus d'argent. Or, c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer. Donc si
on ne renverse pas ce système-là et on
peut le faire à la fois en menant une
politique, prenons un exemple,
vous menez, vous décidez de faire une
loi de programmation de l'industrie.
Vous faites ça, on a moyen de le faire
dans l'état actuel du droit et des
choses.
Une loi de programmation comme la loi de
programmation militaire.
Exactement. Mais vous faites une vraie
c'est que premier point
avec les trépanés qui connaissent rien
l'industrie là. Alors justement, non,
pas avec eux, pas avec eux. Vous faites
vous traitez tous les sujets en même
temps, c'est-à-dire vous prenez, vous
décidez d'abord qu'il y a pas un
ministre de l'économie avec en dessous
un sous-secrétaire d'État à l'industrie
et cetera. Vous mettez un ministre de
l'industrie qui a aussi l'énergie, les
transports, la recherche, très
important. et vous dites voilà c'est à
partir de là déjà on réoriente la
commande publique. C'est-à-dire que ça
ça nécessite de dire à l'Union
européenne écoutez voilà ça c'est nos
enjeux vitaux donc vous êtes gentil dans
certaines filières qu'on va identifier
voilà ça fait partie de nos intérêts
vitaux vous y touchez pas donc nous sur
ces sujets là commande publique on
décide ce qu'on fait ensuite on va
orienter l'épargne. Je il y a il y a
6250 milliards d'épargnes en France,
voilà, qui partent à financer des fonds
de pension américain, des c'est un trou
noir, on ne sait pas où ça va. Par
exemple, l'assurance vie. Donc tout ça,
on le redirige vers les entreprises
françaises. Attention, pas les entre
d'ailleurs pas non pas les entreprises
françaises, les producteurs français. On
sort européen on sort de l'Union
européenne, on continue de croire que le
Père Noël va descendre par la cheminée.
Non non, on on peut par exemple, alors
c'est ce que je disais par exemple sur
la commande publique, je on décide et
ils font quoi ? Ils nous font payer une
amende. Je On est contributeur net.
Voilà, il nous envoie les chars.
C'est pas grave. Bah euh le l'Union
europées euh l'Union européenne ils vont
pas nous envoyer les chars si on décide
de préserver notre industrie. Oui. Union
européenne Bruxelles. Donc
Bruxelles. Exactement.
C'est dommage parce qu'on aime beaucoup
Bruxelles et on adore les Belges.
Bah les Belges sont des c'est un peuple
génial.
Il va falloir qu'on qu'on passe à
l'action là.
Oui mais alors vous voyez il y a
différentes manières. Alors il
les Belges nous ouvriront la route avec
leurs tracteur.
C'est ça. Il y a il y a un élément
essentiel quand même qui est un élément
de droit. La question de savoir quelle
est la hiérarchie des normes, ça c'est
un sujet fondamental. Pourquoi ? Parce
que
qu'est-ce qui prime sur notre
constitution ? C'est ça
exactement. C'est ça le sujet. Là pour
l'instant à chaque fois qu'on essaie de
faire un truc, on nous dit "Ah ben non,
on peut pas." Par exemple, regardez, il
y a un amendement là pendant le vote du
budget qui a été voté par les insoumis
Parti socialistes, le Rassemblement
national sur la taxation du chiffre
d'affaires des multinationales. En fait,
un des enjeux énormes aujourd'hui, c'est
de faire en sorte que les
multinationales payent l'impôt là où
elles font l'argent, là où leurs
produits sont consommés. C'est la base
puisque sinon c'est ce que je vous
disais, il y a ce système de prix de
transfert qui fait que on rapatrie les
les bénéfices dans un paradis fiscal.
Bon et Total, il fait son bénéfice où ?
Ah ben Total, il fait son bénéfice
absolument partout sauf en France. Mais
ça c'est un autre problème.
LVMH LVMH il fait son BFO.
LVMH j'avoue que je maîtrise pas
complètement ce que ce que je sais.
Il y a combien de personnes qui payent
l'impôt sur le revenu en France ? Euh il
y a un petit peu moins de la moitié des
Français qui des foyers fiscaux qui
payent le l'impôt sur
du combien de foyers fiscaux en France ?
Alors, j'ai pas non j'ai pas en tête le
chiffre des foyers fiscaux très
honnêtement euh ça je veux pas en
revanche sur LVMH, il y a un point
intéressant qui est que c'est pour ça
que c'est pas forcément le meilleur
exemple parce que malgré tous les
défauts, la capacité à faire des eux ils
maintiennent de l'emploi en France mais
c'est très facile pour eux. C'est parce
que le luxe c'est
un domaine où même si on est beaucoup
plus cher en fait, on vend sur le fait
que c'est plus cher. Donc à quand
j'étais à Marian, on avait organisé un
observatoire du patriotisme économique,
c'est-à-dire un calcul sur on prenait
toutes les entreprise du CAC 40 et alors
c'est c'était extrêmement précis parce
qu'il fallait regarder quelle était leur
part de d'emploi à l'étranger, quelle
était leur part d'emploi en France,
quelle était leur part de chiffre
d'affaires à l'étranger, quelle était
leur part de chiffre d'affaires en
France, comment ça avait évolué et
cetera. et on aboutissait pour essayer
de savoir si ils avaient baissé le
nombre d'emplois en France davantage que
ce qu'impliquait leur baisse de chiffre
d'affaires. Enfin bon, on arrivait à
quelle conclusion ? Ceux qui étaient les
plus patriotes dans le CAC 40, c'était
les entreprises du luxe, c'était Hermes,
c'était LVMH et dans le fond du
classement, on avait Stéantis, on avait
Michelin et cetera. Bon, ce qui est
assez logique, c'est encore une fois le
luxe est moins soumis à ce principe de
concurrence internationale. Mais
d'ailleurs, on se souvient de la la le
la sortie du patron de St de Stellantis
qui avait Tavares qui avait expliqué
"Écoutez, si vous nous mettez en
concurrence avec le reste du monde
systématiquement, faudra pas vous
étonner que on aille fabriqué ailleurs."
Et il avait terminé d'ailleurs, j'avais
été assez frappé de cette interview où
il disait "Et de toute façon, ça ça se
perra dans les urnes."
Oui, j'ai ça avait dit un truc très
intéressant aussi sur les les voitures
électriques.
Qu'est-ce qu'il avait dit sur les
voitures électriques ? Bon, en gros que
je résume trivialement qu'on a encore
des trépanés qui ont eu des bonnes
idées.
Oui. Bah oui, voilà. Non mais ça ça on
est bien d'accord. C'est enfin c'est une
dinguerie totale mais le ce qu'on fait
sur la voiture dingerie totale, on fait
une expérience de pensée ensemble parce
que vu que ça part dans tous les sens.
Oui, c'est pas très structuré. Ouais,
mais vous inquiétez pas, je je reprends
la structure de au départ de la BBC dans
pas très longtemps. Donc,
on fait une expérience de pensée entre
vous et moi.
Ouais.
Et ceux qui nous écoutent,
imaginez-vous que le fait de passer à la
voiture électrique, même si ça consomme
20 fois plus de minéraux, de machin
et on en passait des meilleurs sur le
recyclage et bon. OK.
Admettons qu'on est une classe politique
européenne et française. En fait, on a
rien compris. Ces gens sont
brillantissime.
Ils ont été touchés par la foudre
divine.
Ça m'a échappé mais je bien c'est c'est
d'une expérience de pensée extrêmement
Ouais. Vous voulez qu'on la fasse façon
auteur français ou [rires]
non ?
J'ai des grains de café autour des yeux
si vous voulez.
Revenons, revenons. Euh, merde !
Donc imaginons
donc imaginons que en fait c'est pas des
trépanés que nous on a tout faux qu'on
qu'on sait pas travailler et qu'ils ont
compris que il faut passer à
l'électrique le plus rapidement possible
parce qu'il y a plus de pétrole et que
nos copains qui ne sont plus nos copains
vont plus nous donner de pétrole à bon
marché et que nous avec nos 56 réacteurs
nucléaires français sous licence
américaine
et ben en fait ça va être un amortisseur
au choc économique et qu'ils ont tout à
fait raison de tout électrifier
tout tout tout tout électrifier même si
on a pas le cuivre que le cuivre pour
électrifier 10 fois plus cher et que et
que va y avoir une bataille pour
l'uranium.
Oui. Oui.
Ils ont peut-être raison ces gens-là non
?
Alors tout le problème et c'est pour ça
qu'on en revient à ma loi de
programmation sur l'industrie, c'est que
ça c'est très bien de faire ça, mais
encore faut-il organiser les filières.
C'est-à-dire que moi je veux bien qu'on
considère que on va subventionner les
voitures électriques ou les pompes à
chaleur, mais on le fait quand on a
conçu les filières de pompe électrique
ou de enfin de de voiture électrique ou
de pompe à chaleur. Voyez, on
subventionne le photovoltaïque quand on
fabrique des panneaux photovoltaïques.
Mais quand on a laissé la Chine détruire
tout le photovoltaïque européen parce
que les Allemands voulaient vendre leur
berlin en Chine, derrière si on met des
subventions pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques, on enrichit des
entreprises chinoises qui sont déjà
subventionnées par le par le
gouvernement chinois parce que c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer. On est
les champions du monde de la subvention
à nos concurrents. Vous pouvez demander,
il y a des fabricants de pompe à chaleur
française, ils essayent d'alerter le
gouvernement là-dessus, ils sont allés
les voir en leur disant "Vous savez, nos
concurrents chinois, ils sont ultra
subventionnés. Donc si vous nous donnez
aussi des subventions, nous on veut bien
être compétitif." On leur a répondu
"Mais non, le problème c'est que vous
êtes pas assez compétitif."
Non, mais c'est voilà. Donc tout est
comme ça. On subventionne, on file du
pognon à nos concurrents pour se donner
bonne conscience. Donc encore une fois,
la règle ça doit être qu'on ne n'impose
pas un passage à une technologie ou un
truc quand on n' pas organisé la filière
avant. C'est tout.
Ça veut dire quoi forfaiture ?
Oh bah la forfaiture c'est une haute
trahison. C'est un mensonge. C'est c'est
une c'est le
Ouais, c'est c'est ce qui conduit au
ploton d'exécution normalement. Non.
Vous aimez les métaphores guerrières ?
Non non, j'aime pas les métaphores
guerrières.
Par contre, les plotons d'exécution, on
peut
Oui, j'ai bien senti. J'ai bien senti.
Moi, je dans ces cas,
vous êtes plutôt Mara ou Robespierre ?
Ah je non, je suis pas du tout Mara et
je suis j'ai je suis
Vous décrivez pas dans le bain, c'est ça
?
Non, déjà
et ensuite parce que euh je déteste le
dogmatisme.
Donc je suis davantage Robespierre mais
pas toujours. C'est-à-dire par exemple
le Robespèpierre qui dit "Je suis
impitoyable avec les tyrans parce que je
suis compatissant envers le peuple." Ça
oui. En revanche, je me méfie beaucoup
de la vertu. Je préfère la vergogne
parce que la vertu, c'est une espèce de
recherche de pureté qui peut-être
profondément dangereuse et malsine. La
vergogne, c'est l'idée ce que je disais
tout à l'heure, qu'on existe sous le
regard des autres, qu'on se doit aux
autres. Et ça, je pense que c'est le
l'élément fondamental.
Et bon après j'avoue que j'ai une
tendresse juste je termine
j'ai une tendresse pour Denton plus que
Robespierre c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
ça s'appelle l'audace à revue
2 septembre 1792
de l'audace encore de l'audace toujours
de l'audace et la France est sauvée.
C'est ça le discours de Denton. Pourquoi
? Parce que toutes les monarchies sont
coalisées pour essayer d'écraser la
révolution. Et 18 jours après le
discours de Danton, il y a Valmi.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a les citoyens qui
prennent les armes pour aller défendre
la révolution, pour aller défendre le
peuple souverain. C'est génial.
Accessoirement, il y a la discussion
apocryphe entre Robespèpierre et Danton.
Robespierre qui dit à Denton : "Alors,
Denton, tu conspires ?" Et Danton qui
répond "Non, je jouis. Quand on jouit,
on ne conspire pas.
Bon, pour revenir à nos peines à jouir
qui nous font de la forfaiture à
longueur de temps,
on se retrouve dans un pays, la France
où il y a des gens qui sont censés
identifier ça. On va pas parler des
journalistes parce que bon, ça fait bien
longtemps qu'ils aiment bien faire des
des papiers sur des moquettes.
Il y a d'autres services en France ?
Non, pour identifier euh les failles
logistiques, euh les chaînes
d'approvisionnement.
Il y a il y a des des services qui
pensent qui pensent la guerre, la guerre
économique.
Mais on a petit à petit déstructuré tout
ça. Bon, d'abord on est ça fait enfin on
a quand même un retard en terme de
guerre économique mais c'est le
politique qui pêche. Pourquoi ? Parce
que par exemple si vous êtes pas
Attention, j'ai parlé de forfaiture
juste avant, il pêche ou il met le
forfait ?
Ouais. Non mais on est d'accord
parce que il y a il y a plaidé
l'incompétence.
Non mais vous savez ce que dis vous
savez ce que disait Rocard hein entre
l'onire. C'est pas de ma faute c'est ça
non ?
Alors non Recard disait entre le complot
et la bêtise faut toujours pr faut
toujours privilégier l'hypothèse de la
bêtise. C'est un rasoir de cam inversé
le complot ça nécessite quand même de
des compétences justement. Non non après
vous avez quand même Bruno Lemer qui est
extraordinaire qui vient faire des des
merci. Non mais
enfin quelqu'un qui reconnaît son
talent.
Ah bah oui, un talent magistral.
L'interview récente dans le Figaro dans
laquelle il explique que la technructure
bruxelloise nous empêche de
réindustrialiser et cetera. Je veux dire
Bruno Lemire a été ministre de
l'économie pendant 7 ans. 7 ans. Je
parlais tout à l'heure
d'irresponsabilité, c'est exceptionnel
quand même. Donc justement le on parlait
de de guerre économique, d'intelligence
économique, mais si on veut justement
défendre une industrie, donc
réindustrialiser véritablement,
c'est-à-dire pas ce qu'ils ont prétendu
faire là où ils ont créé quelques
emplois, je rappelle, on avait fait le
l'étude à à Marianne sur les la création
de des 127000 emplois industriels depuis
2017. On était allé regarder les données
d'Ursaf. C'est très intéressant les
données du SAF. On s'aperçoit que 29 %
de ces emplois industriels sont dans les
boulangeries, vous savez, c'estàd les
boulangeries qui s'installent en
périphérie pour que les cadres puissent
acheter des sandwichs. C'est considéré,
voilà, c'est considéré comme de
l'industrie agroalimentaire. Donc 29 %
là-dedans. Bon bref, ça c'était une
parenthèse. Mais l'intelligence
économique, ça nécessite quoi ? que
l'État fasse le boulot, c'est-à-dire
dire vote une loi pour dire bah voilà,
j'ai un droit de préemption sur le
patrimoine immatériel des entreprises.
Donc quand une boîte étrangère veut
racheter une entreprise française, bah
s'il y a des brevets qui sont absolument
essentiels, moi j'ai le droit de préter.
Voilà, je protège. C'est quand même la
base. C'est pas très compliqué de faire
ça.
Vous connaissez la blague des gars qui
font réellement de l'intelligence
économique ?
Non.
Et ben en France, ils font toujours de
l'économie de l'intelligence.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est exactement ça.
Ça me fait pas marrer et puis vous avez
été totalement
vous avez brisé mon petit cœur avec
Bruno Lemè.
Mon idole mon idole vient d'être
saccagé. Je suis désolé. Mais enfin en
même temps là maintenant c'est alors
Bruno Lemire il est responsable ou c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui porte ?
Alors
soyons clair, il y a
est-ce que c'est Jupiter ou si c'est
Hermè ? Parce que amermes picos euh vous
connaissez le discours de Paulo le mer
en anglais. Ah bah c'est du rafarin mais
en very better.
Ah j'ai raté ça.
Ouais il y a ce petit un petit ce petit
côté que Rafarin n'avait pas trop ça se
voyait pas ce côté mégalomane.
Ah oui oui.
I am Hermes the messenger of Jupiter.
Mon
dieu
the beautiful French accent.
Bon alors revenons à
Ne faites pas de mal à mon idole Bruno
Lemire.
Je me permettrai pas, mais je me réjouis
tout de même que pour des raisons de, on
va dire de politique interne au
républicain, il ne soit pas devenu
ministre de la défense parce que dans un
moment où on a besoin de préserver
l'industrie de défense française qui est
attaquée de façon extrêmement violente,
il vaut mieux
espérer avoir des gens d'abord que vous
êtes dur avec Bron le maire, cette
personne
lumineuse
à sauver l'industrie française. Du
moins, c'est ce qu'il m'a dit. C'est ce
qui
Oui. Alors moi ce qui m'a expliqué c'est
euh ben écoutez enfin d'accord
réindustrialisé mais il faut aller vers
les les technologies à haute valeur
ajoutée. On va quand même pas fabriquer
des des grripins. Alors j'aim j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi en fait parce que des
grripins tout le monde en utilise hein.
Donc et puis si écologique
puis quand on connaît un peu
l'industrie, on s'aperçoit que il peut y
avoir de l'innovation dans n'importe
quel domaine industriel et que c'est
justement en fabriquant sur place qu'on
permet d'avoir d'entretenir un
écosystème d'innovation. C'estàd c'est
quand on rapproche les chaînes de
production et la recherche, la recherche
et développement. Donc tout ça est
absurde. Accessoirement, on sait que un
emploi dans l'industrie crée au moins un
emploi et demi voire deux emplois de
services autour, ce qui est une
évidence. Les emplois industriels étant
des emplois qui permettent un dégain de
productivité, qui permettent des
salaires plus élevés et qui en plus sont
distribués dans l' sur l'ensemble du
territoire parce que la destruction des
territoires français, la
désertification, c'est aussi lié à la
désindustrialisation. Et quand il y a un
truc qui est passé totalement inaperçu,
moi ça me rend dingue, ça fait quand
même des années que on n' pas de
politique de logement en France. Tout le
monde s'en fiche. On est là en train de
parler du pouvoir d'achat des Français.
30 % du budget des ménages est consacré
au logement.
C'est pas plus que ça.
Au dernière nouvelle pour moi, c'était
30 %.
Donc vous imaginez, ça veut dire que la
question du logement c'est le sujet sur
le pouvoir d'achat. Or c'est lié à quoi
? C'est lié à des tas de choses. Les
évolutions dans les dans les modes de
vie, par exemple, les couples qui se
séparent, ça nécessite beaucoup plus de
logement. Mais c'est aussi le fait que
quand vous désindustrialisez, quand vous
tuez des pans entiers du territoire,
vous avez une démographie qui bouge.
C'est-à-dire que là sur les ce le
chiffre date d'il y a 5 ans, hein, mais
il y a 5 ans, le chiffre c'était 82 %
des emplois créés dans les 15 années
précédentes l'avaient été dans les
métropoles. Donc, quand vous créez tous
les emplois uniquement dans les
métropoles, bah les gens sont obligés
d'aller habiter là. Donc il faut
construire. Vous avez du bâti ancien qui
est totalement abandonné partout sur le
territoire. qui s'effondre et pendant ce
temps-là, on bétonne des territoires et
on crée de la tension. Donc la crise du
logement est aussi liée à la
désindustrialisation.
Donc il faut inverser toute la
mécanique. C'est pour ça que venir
raconter que on va se contenter de faire
de les de la réindustrialisation sur les
la haute valeur ajoutée, c'est d'une
bêtise crasse. Accessoirement quand on a
détruit l'école, c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de faire des de faire de la de
la haute valeur ajoutée parce que c'est
ça aussi l'escroquerie de toute ce
système. Je me souviens dans les années
90000 où les ces toutes ces ces élites
brillantes nous parlaient de la société
de la connaissance. C'était quoi la
société de la connaissance ? C'était
l'idée que bon euh on laissait fabriquer
les t-shirts par les Chinois, donc on
éradiquait toute notre industrie textile
mais que c'était pas grave parce que
nous on allait leur vendre des Airbus.
Le problème c'est qu'on leur vendait les
Airbus mais avec la technologie, les TGV
pareil. Et en plus pendant ce temps-là,
on détruisait notre système scolaire.
Donc moralité, on se retrouve
aujourd'hui, on a plus assez
d'ingénieurs, on a une un décrochage
dans les matières scientifiques qui est
absolument tragique. Il faut quand même
voir les enquêtes les enquêtes PISA, les
enquêtes internationales sur le niveau
scolaire.
le alors évidemment que les systèmes qui
sont les plus performants sont des
systèmes asiatiques
qui sont des système ultra compétitif
mais tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
compris qu'il y avait une guerre
cognitive et que ça nécessitait de
développer l'intelligence des mots mais
accessoirement là aussi de lutter contre
les écrans, contre l'abretissement
généralisé par les réseaux sociaux. Je
c'est pas pour rien que les Chinois nous
envoient TikTok et que eux ils
préservent leur jeunesse pendant ce
temps-là. job interdisit à ces momes
d'utiliser les tablettes.
Revenons à notre
idole, notre on a un hôtel de la
dévotion avec une petite statuette
vaudou à l'image de Bruno Lemè chez
nous. Le matin, on lui dit "Merci Bruno
pour
cette aura lumineuse que tu projettes
sur notre pays et sur notre industrie."
Bruno Leire, ministre de la défense. Oh,
ça a quand même de la classe, non ?
C'est un peu comme c'est ces journées à
l'Europe.
Ah oui oui. Non si on est sur cette
échelle de comparaison. Oui et puis
surtout
depuis de gou je crois
c'est une chasse gardée du président de
la République. Le ministère de la
défense il met quiil veut au ministère
de la défense.
Donc il a mis Bruno. Il a mis Bruno
parce qu'il est compétent. Il a mis
Bruno parce que c'est son meilleur pote.
Il a mis Bruno parce que Bruno ne
trahirait jamais. Il a mis Bruno parce
que
on n'attaque pas la France quand il y a
Bruno le maire. Non parce qu'il parle
allemand
de nos amis allemand
v
non c'est au moment où justement il va
s'agir de
de on va dire de
d'avoir son réflexe de leur
industrielle. Voilà, parce que les
Allemands euh là, il suffit de regarder
toute l'année Rine Metal a signé des
partenariats avec UIN, avec Anduril,
avec Loqu de Martin pour fabriquer alors
certes sur le territoire européen,
d'accord, mais sous licence américaine.
Ça veut dire qu'en fait on est en train
de se verrouiller pour les 30 ou 40
prochaines années. Donc si on ne
maintient pas une industrie de défense
française avec évidemment des produits
qui sont pas sous norme ITAR, on est
mort. Et le je
flû sur l'autonomie stratégique
européenne, ça ne voudra rien dire.
Alors, ce qui est profondément
inquiétant, c'est que l'affaiblissement
économique de la France fait que pendant
que les Allemands vont investir dans
leur industrie d'armement et donc dans
leur dans leurs alliances avec les
États-Unis, nous euh les carnets de
commande sont toujours pas pleins.
C'est-à-dire que quand on discute avec
des cadres de grandes entreprises de
défense américaine française, pardon, il
vous explique que bah le l'économie de
guerre, ils l'ont pas encore vu. Je l'an
dernier sur 2024
le par exemple Talè avait des carnets de
commande plein sauf que sauf que en fait
c'était que de l'extra européen. Pour ce
qui est des commandes intraeuropéennes,
ça avait baissé en volume. Donc le
réarmement, il se fait pas exactement là
où il devrait se faire et dans le bon
sens.
Le rar moment démographique. Ah non non,
on va continuer juste une petite une
petite c'est pur plaisir.
Bruno Lemer, ministre de la défense
sur une idée brillantissime de Jupiter
Jupiter de l'Élysée,
il a tenu 12h avec ses 11 % et sa
décision de mettre Bruno.
Oui. Alors
comment ça se fait qu'il y a pas eu
toute la classe politique
qui qui elle aurait dû débarquer de de
LFI en passant jusqu'à Marine Le Pen en
disant bon maintenant ça suffit tes
conneries, tu vas repartir avec maman,
tu vas finir ton adolescence
puis maintenant tu vas arrêter de
le bordel.
Alors, je
habituellement enfin je j'essaie de me
garder de personnaliser systématiquement
les choses
qui vous dérange ses mamas.
Mais il y a un problème en effet avec la
façon dont Emmanuel Macron exerce le
pouvoir. J'avais dit en
c'était je pense que c'était en 2018 au
moment des gilets jaunes ou peut-être
même un peu avant. Enfin que le le
problème d'Emmanuel Macron, c'est qu'il
avait pas de culture démocratique. Je
c'est clairement sa façon de de
d'écraser tous les tous les corps
intermédiaires, de justement de se vivre
en Jupiter, c'est quelqu'un qui qui au
fond de lui n'a pas la tripe
démocratique. Voilà. Je m'étais fait
évidemment
agonir d'injure pour avoir osé dire ça.
Je pense quand même que la suite m'a un
petit peu donné raison. C'est-à-dire que
une Cassandre à l'époque.
Oui, mais vous savez,
on fait justeir.
Non, mais c'est d'ailleurs très
intéressant ce terme Cassandre parce que
c'est une des expressions préférées de
d'Emmanuel Macron. N'écoutez pas les
Cassandres. Bah ouais, mais Cassandre
dans la mythologie, c'est celle qui a
été condamnée à annoncer ce qui va
réellement arriver et à n'être jamais
cru. Donc, il vaut mieux écouter les
Cassandres en fait. Et
et Europa, qu'est-ce qu'elle a fini ?
Elle finit comment ? Europa ?
Ah, Europa alors attendez euh Ah, j'ai
un trou de mémoire. Je me souviens plus.
Ça c'est la honte parce que pardon mais
en ayant fait
8 ou 9 ans de grec ancien et j'oublie ce
que comment est devenu comment est passé
repas là pardon mais vous m'avez prise
en défaut et je je me couvre.
Fais pas semblant d'avoir de la culture
en cherchant sur Google. Arrête.
Non je suis désolé. Euh
à à l'exécution du pouvoir de notre
Jupiter lumineux, brillantissime.
Ce demi-dieu sur terre qui nous a été
fourni par d'ailleurs on ne sait pas qui
qui a poussé sa campagne. Je me rappelle
de Henri Hermand. Oui,
feu en rièement qu'on a bien connu avec
son yupala et son garde du corps et et
quand il nous a annoncé 3 ans avant que
Emmanuel Macron allait être président de
la République, on s'est regardé avec
Jacques Andréani, Jacques Andréani,
ancien ambassadeur de France à
Washington
à qui j'ai eu l'autorisation de
maiguiser les chicots sur ces vieux
molets.
Jacques, tu nous manques énormément.
Euh, on s'est on s'est regardé quand
Yupala nous a annoncé que Macron
brillantissime allait être élu. Vous
avez cherché un peu qui est-ce qui a
poussé Macron mis à part tous les
médias. Votez ce que vous voulez mais
voter Macron. Vous avez cherché un peu
qui a financé la campagne, comment il
s'est financé, comment il a été cherché
du Free à gauche à droite.
Oui, bien sûr.
7500 € mais dans toute la famille il son
Oui. Bah c'estàd voilà c'est enfin toute
la famille donne 7500 €. C'est comme ça
que ça ça marche. Non, après je n'ai pas
d'information précise sur les les
financements de d'Emmanuel Macron.
Il va terminer comment Emmanuel Macron ?
Il va terminer gentiment avec les
voitures qui partent de l'Élysée
tranquillement avec les portes qui se
ferment. Au revoir président ou il va
terminer, ça risque de mal se terminer.
Alors il il le dit, il dit ils vont
finir par m'avoir.
Moi ce qui m'assure veut m'ass partir
flamboyant
comme comme celui qui a essayé de sauver
la France avec Bruno d'ailleurs ou
est-ce qu' il se rend pas bien compte
qu'il est en train de jouer avec le feu
français ? Il joue vraiment avec le feu.
Mais ce qui me moi m'a profondément euh
attristé, effaré, consterné, c'est quand
même l'épisode là en marge de de
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU.
C'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron va au
nom de la France de déclarer la
reconnaissance de la Palestine, ce que
pour ma part, je trouve enfin il il
était t jour le jour de quoi d'ailleurs
? C'était le jour de quoi qu'il avait
annoncé ça ?
Une fête juif très connu.
Euh oui oui oui.
Les lumières, comment on dit ? Les
lumières ? Non, c'était pas les
lumières. Non, c'était pas c'était pas
c'était pas Rana, c'était non, je sais
plus. Enfin, mais en marrétin d'ailleurs
pour faire ça,
en marge de ça, que fait-il ? Il va à la
petite cérémonie de remise des du Global
Citizen Award de l'Atlantic Council.
C'est fabuleux cette scène. Alors,
l'Atlantico Global Citizen. Award. Ah
bah le le prix le prix du citoyen
global, c'est du citoyen du monde, le
fameux décrit par Athalie Patride qui
voyage partout qui travaille partout. Et
donc l'Atlantique qui est un un lobby
proatlantiste quoi lui remet ce prix.
Ils remettent ça tous les ans. Donc
l'année d'avant c'était Georgia Méloni
qui l'avait eu de les mains des mains de
son ami Elon Musk. Et donc Emmanuel
Macron reçoit ce prix des mains de son
ami Larry Fink, patron de Black Rock et
euh nouvellement coprésident du forum de
Davos. Enfin, pardon mais c'est
extraordinaire. Enfin, j'aime On peut on
peut s'amuser à reprendre justement la
fameuse phrase qui est devenue
maintenant imponsif. Mais imagine-on le
général de Gaul recevoir le Global
Citizen Award ? Enfin pardon, c'est
c'est dingue. Je trouve ça complètement
fou. Et ça raconte quelque chose de là
aussi de de l'espèce de de fierté qu'on
certains de nos politique à se vivre
comme des citoyens du monde plutôt que
comme des représentants du peuple
français.
Je moi je
je considère qu'il y a pas grande fierté
à
à favoriser les intérêts de
multinational et de de d'entreprises qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les intérêts du
peuple français. Je pense que on est
dans une période au contraire où il faut
mais Mordicus défendre
nos producteurs, nos entrepreneurs, nos
intérêts.
On se souvient à quel point Emmanuel
Macron quand il est arrivé au pouvoir a
largement ouvert les portes à toutes les
plateformes américaines. On se souvient
de ses liens avec Uber, on se souvient
enfin bref, non seulement il y avait une
une absence totale de compréhension du
monde tel qu'il était parce que ça aussi
c'est ce qu'oublie tous les les médias
qui l'ont soutenu, c'est quand même que
si on en est là aujourd'hui, c'est parce
que le diagnostic que faisait Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 était complètement faux.
C'est faut se souvenir, il nous
expliquait que euh la mondialisation
heureuse, c'était génial, ça allait
continuer et qu'il allait falloir euh
adapter la France à cette
mondialisation. C'est qu'il avait même
pas vu la montée des tensions, les
empires qui se réveillaient, la
fermeture des différents blocs
régionaux. Il avait rien vu de tout ça.
C'est c'est quand même extraordinaire de
se planter à ce point. Non, mais c'est
pas se planter. C'est peut-être qu'on
l'a mis là pour faire le pentin.
Ça, j'en sais rien.
Comment euh les guignoles les
marionnettes elles sont agis c'est des
ficelles ou on leur met une main
derrière ? C'est ça.
Ouais, mais je sais pas ça je moi je je
ne parle jamais que de ce dont j'ai la
preuve.
Donc je n'ai pas réponse
de preuve d'autre chose.
Donc moi je juge auraiit dû vous
présenter en
je peut-être. Moi je je ce que je sais
c'est ce qu'Emmanuel Macron défendait
comme idée et c'est les positions qu'il
a pris, c'est les gens qui l'a soutenu
ça. Oui, ça je peux juger. Donc c'estes
liens avec Uber, avec Black Rock, ça
c'est voilà la façon de favoriser
totalement Min le fait d'avoir des gens
de Mckins dans sa campagne et cetera,
tout ça, on le sait, ça c'est documenté.
Donc ça, je sais.
Donc ça, je peux parler là-dessus et je
considère en effet que c'est euh que
c'est à la fois extrêmement grave et
tragique pour la France. Voilà. Après,
le reste, j'en sais rien donc je me
prononce pas. On
on on on va faire une expérience
croisée. Donc Emmanuel Macron, il
bossait chez qui déjà ?
Chez euh la banque Rothsild, ça
et donc il est sorti de la banque
Rothield, il avait pas un Copec.
Alors
alors il a pas un copec, il connaît rien
la géopolitique,
sa culture est relativement théâtral.
Euh moi quand je vois un banquier sortir
de chez Rochill, il a pas un copec, je
me dis euh c'est quoi ce crétin là ?
Non mais
c'est quoi ce crétin ?
Non mais il sort de Chirochi, il a pas
un copec. Mais là aussi par exemple,
mais moi j'ai pas les preuves, j'ai pas
les enfin déclaration de patrimoine.
Si si justement, ben comme tout le
monde, je me suis dit quand même c'est
en effet soit il était pas doué, soit il
y a un problème. D'accord, mais il y a
des gens qui ont enquêté là-dessus. J'ai
pas de réponse. Quand j'ai pas de
réponse, allez, je ne me permets pas de
je n'ai pas les moyens d'investiguer là.
Donc la pour l'instant
Ouais,
parce que peut-être que vous allez avoir
les moyens,
on sait jamais.
Revenons revenons à à notre brillant
Jupiter premier roi de des Français.
Donc il voit rien venir. Il est à 11, il
est à 11 % maintenant. La balance
commerciale c'est au moins 148 146 158.
Ça ça dépend des années. Alors ça le
les prévisions de TVA fait à la louche
aux doigts mouillés. Euh, on voit pas 40
milliards et puis bon, c'est pas de
notre faute. On avait pas vu, on a fait
des mauvaises prévisions.
Là, ça commence à faire un peu beaucoup.
Non,
ça commence à faire un peu beaucoup.
C'est-à-dire que moi, si je devais
débarquer là-dedans,
dire "Toi, tu es prévisionniste, tu
racontes un peu comment tu t'es trompé
là. Tu vas me ramener ton chef, ton
sous-chef, ton ton gruyot qui t'amène
les cafés. Je vais faire ça à Ber, je
vais faire ça à l'armée, je vais faire
ça un peu partout.
Et je vais dire maintenant c'est quoi
ton bilan ? Alors le problème c'est que
nous on a Emmanuel Macron. Son bilan
c'est c'est ça c'est 11 % 3300 milliards
de dettes.
Ils sont où les contrepouvoirs là-dedans
? On va attendre qu'il soit à 4 %
qu'on soit à moins 200 milliards de
balance commerciale qu'on soit englué
avec les pop-of qui vont nous fumer.
On on va faire quoi là avec un qui est
d'orset qui se fait obber la tête par
les lesons. On passe encore par pour des
crétins finis
et ce mec a ruiné la parole diplomatique
française. Alors, il faut avouer que le
bilan des il faut avouer, je me suis pas
baladé mais je lis suffisamment pour
savoir où on en est de ce point de
vue-là. Bien sûr que
où ils sont les contrepouvoirs là ?
Bah,
on va attendre
le les contrepouvoirs, ils étaient
prévus par la 5e République, sauf
qu'elle a été distordue par tous les
différents partis de gouvernement
précédent. Parce que quand vous décidez
de mettre en place le quinquena,
l'inversion du calendrier, quand vous
faites en sorte de déséquilibrer
entièrement la Constitution, il y a plus
de contrepouvoir. C'est ça le sujet.
Cette cette constitution, elle était
équilibrée et elle permettait justement
de à la fois d'incarner la France à
travers la figure du président de la
République et en même temps, vous aviez
une vous aviez des possibilités de
législative. Alors évidemment la
première entorse c'est la cohabitation
en elle-même, même si c'est le seul
moment où on applique la la lettre de la
Constitution, l'article 20, c'est-à-dire
le gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation. Ouais. Mais à
part ça, voilà, vous avez détruit petit
à petit le truc. Et puis deuxème point,
vous avez des instances juridiques qui
petit à petit ont utilisé leur pouvoir
pour contourner la volonté des citoyens
ou pour en tout cas la brider petit à
petit. Ça aussi ça réduit la marge de
manœuvre des politiques pour leur plus
grand bonheur parce que en fait ils ont
aucune intention de se battre contre ça.
Mais petit à petit ça empêche le bon
fonctionnement de la démocratie. Quand
vous avez le Conseil constitutionnel par
exemple qui décide alors ça date de 7
conseil Conseil constitutionnel
le la planque pour le Parti socialiste.
Alors oui, enfin nomination de
différentes de c'est une tradition hein
de nommer des gens qui sont pas qui sont
plus des politiques que des que des
juristes bien sûr. Le problème c'est que
normalement ils sont accompagnés par des
juristes mais depuis 71 ils ont décidé
par exemple que contrairement à ce qui
était la ce qui était prévu en fait dans
l'idée de la constitution quand de
Gaulle crée un conseil constitutionnel
pour vérifier que les lois sont
conformes juridiquement à la
Constitution. En 71, le Conseil
constitutionnel considère que enfin il
fait rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle le
bloc constitutionnel, c'est-à-dire ce
sur quoi il s'appuie. non seulement la
Constitution, mais le préambule de la
Constitution. Le préambule de la
Constitution, c'est la déclaration des
droits de l'homme, la Constitution de
1946 et cetera. Et donc ils disent bon,
on doit pas seulement voir si la loi est
conforme à la Constitution, l'article 40
machin et cetera, mais aussi à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme. Mais
la déclaration des droits de l'homme,
c'est pas un texte juridique, c'est un
texte politique. Donc le Conseil
constitutionnel s'arroge un rôle
politique. Mais vous avez d'autres
problèmes comme ça qui déséquilibrent
petit à petit la démocratie. Regardez la
CEDH, la cour la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
qui donc euh est constitué de 46
juristes nommés par les différents pays
qui ont reconnu la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme. La Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme, c'est
un texte, voilà, qui détermine les
grands principes et cetera. Donc là
aussi, des principes politiques,
philosophiques quasiment. Et donc vous
avez des juges qui ont été nommés comme
ça et qui décident si par exemple
l'expulsion de tel prêcheur islamiste et
cetera est conforme ou pas à la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et qui vous disent bah écoutez
dans la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme il y a le droit à la vie
privée. Donc ce monsieur il a une
famille, donc son droit à la vie privée
fait que on va le garder hein, on va on
va le garder sur le sol. Mais dans en
démocratie pour ceux qui ont lu
Montesqueux, il y a un équilibre des
trois pouvoirs et une indépendance de
ces pouvoirs. Donc le principe c'est que
vous avez l'exécutif, le législatif et
le judiciaire. Le judiciaire applique
les lois
quand le judiciaire
aboutit à des décisions qui conviennent
pas, on change la loi. Voilà. Et pour
ça, bah le peuple s'exprime et il change
la loi.
Quand la loi, c'est la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui est
un texte qui a été écrit et qu'on peut
pas toucher, qu'il y a personne, il y a
pas de pouvoir législatif pour le pour
le modifier, on fait comment ? plus tout
à fait une démocratie équilibrée.
D'ailleurs, vous avez neuf pays là au
mois de mai-juin qui ont écrit une
lettre ouverte pour demander à la CEDH
de revoir un peu sa jurisprudence en
disant "Écoutez, nous on peut pas mener
les politiques pour lesquelles on a été
élu à cause de ça. Donc il serait bien
quand même de réfléchir au problème.
Dans la mesure où parmi ces neuf pays,
il y avait l'Italie de Georgia Méloni,
le journal Le Monde a titré "L'extrême
droite attaque l'état de droit
européen."
Dans les autres, les neuf pays, il y
avait Donald Tusk, le Polonais,
c'est pas vraiment l'extrême droite, il
y avait Mux Frédéricen, les
socio-démocrates danois, pardon, il y
avait les Belges. Donc c'était
absolument pas l'extrême droite. C'est
tout simplement que à un moment donné,
il faut se poser la question de
l'expression démocratique, la volonté
des citoyens des différents pays
européens. Oui, j'ai un chat dans la
gorge. Donc petite pause, on va
un petit chat. Euh, revenons, revenons.
Le monde écrit Non, c'est pas le monde,
c'est le journaliste du monde validé par
sa rédaction.
Enfin, là, c'était la c'était le le
titre. Donc le titre, c'est le c'est
décidé par les instantances. C'est pas
le journaliste qui décide du titre de
son article. Voyez, dans un journal euh
c'est le la le titre, c'est une
décision, on va dire du rédacteur en
chef, du directeur de rédaction. Euh
c'est d'ailleurs
revenons à la BBC parce que c'était
notre toute première question. La BBC,
le scandale avec Trump, le numéro 1,
numéro 2, la numéro 2 qui dégage
et que voilà et que les fake news et que
Macron les fake news et que Popof
l'ingérance et que les ingérences
étrangères et que bon c'est pas de notre
faute, c'est la faute des étrangers qui
nous veulent du mal. H et que de toute
façon les citoyens sont pas capables de
distinguer
les choses et que d'ailleurs tous les
votes qui nous ont déplu, c'est parce
qu'il y avait des ingérences étrangères.
On est bien d'accord. C'est ça qu'on
nous explique. C'està-dire que ça ça
commence à devenir très dangereux.
D'ailleurs, quand on en est à
interrompre un processus démocratique
parce qu'on considère qu'il y a eu des
ingérences étrangères, il y a eu des
ingérences étrangères, elles sont
dangereuse bien entendu. En revanche, à
quel moment enfin quel est le curseur
pour décider qu'on va interrompre un
processus démocratique ? C'est là où ça
devient dangereux. Si c'est la seule
réponse qu'on a, on se met dans une
situation qui est profondément
compliquée.
Vous trouvez que la la contre-ingérence
russe en France, elle est bien gérée ?
Gen on a quand même France Télévision
qui a 4 milliards de budget. 4 milliards
4 avec 90
joke qui avec notre communauté [rires]
France Télévision ça devrait être notre
bouclier de Sparciat contre ces méchants
qui nous envahissent dans nos petites
têtes de citoyens tellement cons parce
qu'on apprend rien dans notre école de
demeurer à 45 par classe où il fait
40°gr et que vous inquiétez pas Macron
il a dit qu'il allait purifier purifier
l'air.
mais que non. Euh, revenons à ça. La
contre-ingérence russe, cette guerre
hybride, cette guerre pilotée par une 5è
colonne.
Vous connaissez cette petite musique
d'espèces de très pané mais de très
pané. Vous n'imaginez
quand on va commencer à ouvrir notre
gueule, je peux vous dire qu'on va se
pisser dessus de rire et je pense qu'on
sera pas tout seul parce que là ça
commence à suffire. Ils ont fait une
grossière erreur, c'est qu'ils m'ont
énervé.
Ça
Ah là, vous n'imaginez même pas mais bah
DGSE, ils savent que
qu'il y a pas plus patriotique que nous.
Comme disait Odi, j'ai bon caractère
mais j'ai le glève vengeur et le bras
séculier.
Eh oui oui surtout le glève.
Même le petit Nicolas, il sait que il
faut pas nous chauffer.
Pour revenir à notre beau pays,
le fait que bah en fait il y a que des
crétins depuis 40 ans qui s'en mettent
plein les fouilles et qui s'amusent bien
à faire des collections de montres, à
mettre leurs copains à gauche à droite
parce que tu comprends, ça renvoie
l'ascenseur et puis c'est cool.
Il y a pas que ça quand même.
Il y a pas que ça. Moi je vois 3300
milliards de dette, je me dis c'est des
crétins. Ah non, mais ça je suis bien
d'accord mais euh attention dans le
personnel politique, moi je peux vous
citer des gens aussi qui sont sincères
quient voilà je grossis le trait il y a
des fonctionnaires qui font correctement
le le à Ber ils font tous un boulot
extraordinaire pour essayer de récupérer
un peu de blé euh proprement gentiment
de façon très pédagogique
aux douanes. Les douanes on nen parle
jamais des douanes.
Mais bien sûr tout le monde s'en fiche
des douanes. Non c'est extraordinaire
les douanes et les douiniers sont loin
d'être cons. Non, mais c'est surtout que
c'est un enfin, ils sont absolument
indispensables. On les a petit à petit
éradiqué. Ils ont quand on fait comme
ça, c'est pas éradiqué. Ça c'est castré.
On les a castré. C'est ça.
Oui, sans doute. Mais en tout cas, en
tout cas le je la question de du de la
capacité des douan réguler, à faire
appliquer la loi et cetera, c'est un
sujet de dingue ça aussi parce que là on
a vu tous les politiques cette semaine
aller ouvrir les les produits Chines
pour vérifier s'ils étaient conformes.
Mais c'est un sketch. Bon, ils ont lui
pété un câri. Ils ont pas un rally, ils
ont pas un rally. Je veux dire il y a un
container sur 1000 qui est fouillé dans
ceux qui arrivent à Rotterdam. C'est des
fond
qui sont déversés.
On vit une une démocratie médiatique
avec une petite corte ou cour de
journaliste, une upper class
journalistique permettant en fait d'être
le relais de l'information
gouvernemente.
C'est la démocratie du faire c'est la la
République du faire semblant. On fait
semblant. Non mais faire semblant, on on
en arrive à ma question qui est aussi
encore mal formulée. Ça c'est les 2h30
d'embouteillage en moto. Il fallait pas.
Merci Annie Dalgo. Merci Emmanuel
Macron.
Revenons à notre beau pays dirigé par
des trépanés.
Là la réalité arrive. Pour ça que on
commence à l'ouvrir.
On va à la guerre
la vraie
avec des morts, avec des pays qui ne se
redressent pas, avec des fondamentaux
énergétiques mondiaux
qui ne sont plus comme avant
où il fallait juste se baisser un peu
chez les bédoins et gratter le sable
pour récupérer un peu de pétrole. Puis
bon le baouin s'il est un peu chiant on
lui met de tartes et au pire on fait un
protectorat avec lui et ce sera notre
tête de pont chez les sauvage de chez
là-bas.
Oui oui, c'était c'était la philosophie.
C'est assez bien c'est assez bien
résumé. Et là
et donc là on est coincé. Notre petit
pays français comme on a plus que des
gens qui nous détestent grâce à certains
qui portaient notre parole diplomatique
concevoir la diplomatie autrement.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la France va
se faire
obliter ?
Alors, si on continue euh sur la même
lancée, oui, très certainement.
C'est-à-dire que euh on voit par exemple
sur la les questions diplomatiques, on
voit à quel point on s'est fait avoir de
partout, de partout. C'est-à-dire que on
sait euh petit à petit, on a absolument
pas vu par exemple la la propagande qui
pouvait y avoir sur les réseaux sociaux
en Afrique parce que faut bien
comprendre que euh
la propagande russe et chinoise contre
nous ou la propagande française où on se
fait topper comme des crétins. Alors, la
propagise
contre nous, ça, il a fallu un temps
infini pour qu'on prenne conscience que
c'était en train de se jouer et euh on
n' pas été capable d'organiser une
contre une contrefensive correcte et on
a petit à petit perdu des pieds perdu
pieds euh dans les pays africains. On a
réussi enfin je l'affaire entre
l'Algérie et le Maroc est quand même
assez caractéristique. C'est-à-dire que
traditionnellement
la France a toujours essayé de jouer de
façon à peu près équilibrée avec la
difficulté qu'il y a étant donné le je
le passif que nous avons avec l'Algérie,
ça a toujours été extrêmement compliqué.
Mais malgré tout, regardez par exemple
la décision sur le Sahara occidental. Je
la France avait cette position qui
consistait à ne pas reconnaître
le Sahara occident, enfin le la le
Maroc, la possession par le Maroc du
Sahara occidental, tout en essayant de
se concilier le Maroc. On a réussi à se
fâcher avec le Maroc, avec le roi du
Maroc
parce que Oui. Comment on a réussi à se
fâcher ?
Alors ça a été raconté euh dans Marianne
par Laurent Valdiguier. Il y a eu
différents éléments, mais celui que j'ai
trouvé le plus extraordinaire, c'est euh
le ce moment où
euh Emmanuel Macron et Mohamed Sit sont
au téléphone et Emmanuel Macron met en
attente Mohamed 6.
Euh vous voyez, enfin commandeur des
croyants dans son paying et cetera. Oui,
excuse-moi, j'ai un autre appel. Bon,
voilà. Et donc
cemm qui m'appelle de l' sur l'autre
ligne, je suis obligé de renouveler mon
crédit. Tu m'excuses un petit peu.
Ça c'est raconté dans un article de de
de Laurent Valdiguier. Enfin des
différents éléments, différentes bourdes
en fait diplomatiques, des petites
vexations, des choses comme ça qui
aboutissent à une crise diplomatique
avec le Maroc. Et donc que fait-on pour
essayer de rattraper le coup
?
On va reconnaître le voilà. Et puis il y
avait l'affaire Pegasus évidemment
l'affaire Pegasus. Et donc là on va
reconnaître la le
comment dire j'ai plus le mot. On va
reconnaître le le la légitimité du du
Maroc sur le Sahara occidental. Et donc
évidemment l'Algérie prend ça comme un
message de guerre. Voilà. Donc comment
réussir à se fâcher avec les uns les
autres puisque l'Algérie c'est la même
chose. On est dans une une conception
totalement ératique des rapports
diplomatiques. Donc Emmanuel Macron,
candidat sur le sol algérien, déclare
que la colonisation est un crime contre
l'humanité. Enfin, je veux dire, je
considère que la colonisation est
philosophiquement le contraire des
valeurs euh républicaine française.
C'est la négation des droits de l'homme.
Donc rien ne justifie la colonisation.
D'accord, mais on ne va pas sur le sol.
Algérien dire, c'est un crime contre
l'humanité. Donc on fait ça et puis
quelques années plus tard, on explique
que le pouvoir algérien profite d'une
rente mémorielle. Donc on est en
permanence dans le je sais pas la
godille on a dit vu mais Natacha vous
n'avez rien compris
le résultat c'est que la France aiguïé
stratégique
souesque clause visienne
vous ne comprenez rien ma pause Natacha
ou pas vraiment de même d'ailleurs au
lendemain du 7 octobre on arrive avec
cette idée dont on ne sait pas d'où elle
sort d'une coalition internation
national sur le sur le modèle de la
coalition contre Da.
Ce qui est effarant et ce qui a fait
évidemment hurler les pays arabes autour
pour ensuite derrière essayer de se
rattraper et d'ailleurs le faire à peu
près correctement sur la suite la suite
de la visite en Jordanie, en Égypte.
Enfin, pourquoi commencer par ça ?
Enfin, vous voyez, c'estàd que il n'y a
pas de de vision, il n'y a pas de
d'architecture intellectuelle sur ce
qu'est la place de la France, sur ce que
doit être sa politique vis-à-vis des
autres pays du monde. En fait, c'est ça,
on navigue à vue. Or, la France est un
pays qui a une tradition, une histoire
fondée sur ce qu'a été sa position dans
le monde, sur la façon dont le général
de Gaulle notamment a positionné le pays
en préservant son indépendance et donc
sa capacité à peser sa voix. Parce que
c'est ça l'intérêt, c'est que la France
peut apporter quelque chose au monde.
Elle l'a fait pendant la la guerre
froide et là où nous sommes dans une
forme de nouvelle guerre froide qui
pourrait en effet devenir très chaude,
très très chaude du guerre froide.
C'est le moment où il faut être audible
et où il faut préserver une
indépendance, une indépendante qui est
assise sur le fait que nous sommes un
pays doté de l'arme nucléaire et que
donc nous n'avons nous ne sommes pas au
même niveau que les autres. Mais ça ça
nécessite de comprendre les rapports
internationaux, de pas changer de
position au gré de tout à coup des des
besoins du moment, de la volonté de
flatter tel ou tel. Il y a il y a une
continuité à observer.
Bon ben moi, je préfère Emmanuel Macron,
c'est comme ça. J'adore quand il nous
partage les échanges diplomatiques
privés entre lui et président Vladimir
Poutine, le méchant, le diable. Non mais
rien que ça. Je veux dire, on fait pas
on ne fait pas de la communication quand
on est dans le quand quand on quand on
est dans une crise diplomatique.
Il nous offre l'ubiguité diplomatique
cet homme-là. Il nous fait comprendre
comment le diable est méchant en face.
Pour ma part,
j'arrive pas à rire de ça dans le sens
où non, je peux pas. Vous vous inquiétez
pas à la fin vous allez y rire quand
même.
Oui. Alors uniquement parce que je me
dépêche de rire de tout de peur d'être
obligé d'en pleurer.
Non mais on discuté très récemment avec
Cor Stéphan
qui est une géologue extraordinaire, un
cerveau brillantissime
et et de temps en temps, on a ce ces
deux petites heures de de décontraction
intellectuelle où on en rigole mais on a
tellement envie de pleurer. Oui, mais il
faut il faut rappeler aux gens que à ce
moment-là Emmanuel Macron était dans un
moment où il essayait de garder le lien
avec la Russie, de continuer à parler à
Poutine et vous aviez toute une caste
atlantiste
qui considérait que c'était un scandale
absolu. Pour ma part, je considérais que
ça faisait partie des intérêts
stratégiques de la France que de
continuer à parler avec la Russie tout
en sachant que c'était un ennemi et
cetera. C'est pas le problème. On parle
avec démocrate
du Biden ou Clinton. Quand je dis
atlantiste, en fait, soyons précis,
c'est cette ce courant néoconservateur
qui à une période a été du côté des
républicains. Soan, c'était chez les
républicains et sauf que ils ont ensuite
migré dans le camp démocrate. Et quand
on regarde par exemple ce le personnage
de Victoria Nand qui est quand même très
intéressante qui est l'épouse
magnifique cette femme du moins elle
était
l'épouse de Robert Cagan donc un des
principaux idéologues du des
néoconservateurs qui a écrit cet article
sur la la politique pour une politique
étrangère
néoréganienne.
Donc il écrit ça, il signe ça en 1996
avec cette phrase que que je trouve
extraordinaire.
Les intérêts
économiques, les intérêts supérieurs des
États-Unis correspondent le plus souvent
avec le la position morale qui est la
nôtre. C'est formidable. et cetera. En
gros, ça résume, je l'ai je l'ai mal
cité parce que je l'ai plus exactement
en tête, mais ça résume la mentalité des
néoconservateurs. C'est-à-dire, ce sont
des gens qui considèrent qu'il y a une
une vocation messianique des États-Unis
parce que c'est l'empire du bien et
parce que ils doivent imposer ce bien au
reste du monde et imposer leur modèle.
Et pour se faire et ben on peut faire la
guerre. par la guerre, on va tout le
toute la doctrine du changement de
régime, c'est on va imposer la
démocratie et il se trouve donc que ça
coïncide assez souvent avec les intérêts
américains. C'est-à-dire que
curieusement, les endroits où on va
imposer la démocratie, c'est des
endroits où il y a du pétrole, c'est des
endroits où il y a des matières
premières. Voyez là, actuellement, on
est en train de considérer que le régime
de Maduro est un régime épouvantable.
Curieusement, le Venéla a parmi les plus
grosses réserves de pétrole au monde.
Mais c'est un hasard. Voilà, c'est les
Canadiens.
H quand est-ce qu'on va apporter ? Ah
non, ils ont déjà la démocratie
canadiens.
Donc les néoconservateurs, c'est ça. Or,
je citais Victoria Nuland qui a été
conseillère de Hillary Clinton.
Attendez, Victoria Inland, c'est elle
qui a emmené des petits pains en Ukraine
sur la place Maidane au moment de la
révolution de Maidane, elle était donc
sur la place en train de de soutenir les
euh postal
les manifestants.
Elle acheté des cartes postales et elle
avait des petits sacs en plastique.
C'est ça. Voilà. Moi, je me pose la
question encore une fois le je je suis
je considère que il y a un droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux-même, que les
Ukrainiens très clairement
là sont dans enfin demandent à
rejoindre, on va dire symboliquement le
le camp européen et cetera bien sûr. en
2014.
Donc on a une représentante du
gouvernement américain qui soutient une
manifestation contre un gouvernement
élu. Je n'aime pas ce gouvernement élu,
c'est pas le problème. Mais vous
imaginez pas
américaine.
Voilà, vous imaginez si le l'ambassadeur
de Russie était allé soutenir les
manifes de gilets jaunes.
Mais ils ont pas fait ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dit ? On
n pas vu Vladimir Poutine dans les
ronds-points Fontaineble. Il y a un
moment où
avec les brochettes chacheliques
nucléaires.
Voilà, pour ma part, je m'efforce de
juger tout le monde avec les mêmes
critères et le même prisme.
Vous avez entendu la vidéo de
Victoriaand où elle insulte copieusement
les Européens ?
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Et où elle
explique "Mais on s'en fout de l'Europe
et cetera." Bien sûr. Voilà. Parce que
il faut se souvenir que les Européens
ont essayé de mettre en place ce qu'on
appelait une architecture de sécurité en
Europe. Notamment Nicolas Sarkozy et
Angela Merkel en alors on remonte un peu
avant en 2008 lors du du conseil de
l'OTAN essae d'empêcher que dans les
conclusions,
il y ait la vocation de l'Ukraine et de
la Géorgie à intégrer l'OTAN. on était
pas prêt à se prendre Poutine dans la
tête à cette époque là. Donc
il est ils estimaient que euh c'était
contraire aux intérêt des Européens et
tel que raconté ce sommet de l'OTAN, ils
vont se coucher le soir en pensant
qu'ils ont emporté la mise et le
lendemain matin le communiqué est publié
avec la phrase le l'Ukraine et la
Géorgie ont vocation à entrer dans
l'OTAN. Donc on voilà, on on a on a
systématiquement vu les États-Unis
imposer aux Européens.
C'est pas les États-Unis, c'est les
démocrates néoconservateurs. C'est ça.
Oui, tout à fait.
Qui ont migré les les néoconservateurs.
Revenons à la BBC.
Oui, pardon. [rires] On s'éloigne à
chaque fois. Allons-y. Oui, mais de
toute façon, s'éloigner de la BBC, ça ne
peut faire que du bien.
Euh, on voit un montage
dégueulasse contre Trump lui faisant
dire n'importe quoi. Donc, la charte de
Muni qu'on s'essuit avec euh tout
tranquille. Le mec qui a fait le
montage, on connaît pas son nom. Le mec
qui a donné l'ordre au monteur de faire
le montage, on connaît pas son nom. Bon,
les États-Unis, ils finançaient la BBC
avec comment ça s'appelle là le leur
fond extraordinaire pour leur soft power
la USD.
Voilà. Extraordinaire.
C'était un gros donateur de la BBC.
Est-ce que vous pensez on met on a met
une hypothèse. Le camp Biden qui avait
besoin d'avoir une campagne mondiale
contre Trump, il a appelé ses petits
copains à la BBC en disant "Bah écoute,
tu te rappelles quand elle fait ton
petit stage à l'anglais payer tout qui
va bien là ? Bah maintenant c'est ton
jour, tu vas me faire un truc
dégueulasse sur Trump parce qu'on a
besoin de ça. Parce que tu comprends si
Trump il repasse ta petite subvention,
ta grosse subvention, on va y réfléchir
à deux fois parce que tu nous sers à
rien comme bouclier contre le fascisme
et l'empire du mal. Est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est on peut l'entendre ?
Est-ce que vous est-ce que vous pensez
que le MI6 il reste encore un MI6 ou un
MI5 digne de ce nom comme notre DGSI,
notre DGSE travaillant pour les peuples,
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont aller
voir si leurs copains des Five Vives
américains du temps de Biden, ils ont
pas passé un petit coup de fil
ou ils ont peut-être envoyé une chambre
garnie pour que la BBC hop, vas-y que je
te pousse, on va le faire sauter. Ce qui
a provoqué l'expression de Trump ? You
are fake news. You are fake news.
Je répéterai ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure. Je parle de ce que je connais
et ce sur quoi j'ai des informations.
Donc là, je vais pas commencer à
échafauder des théories. Bien sûr,
on appelle le MI6 après. D'accord. On
leur posera les questions.
J'accepte, j'accepte, j'accepte. Je
refuse de de commencer à échafauder des
théories quand je n'ai pas les moyens de
vérifier en fait. J'accepte la réponse.
Euh question internet. Euh le contrat
social, on verra ça après. Le contrat
social, pas d'énergie. Donc bon, on s'en
fout du contrat social.
Bah ça va, ça va ça va avec. Vous avez
une société qui explose. Quand vous avez
un pays qui s'appauvrit, quand vous avez
des visiblement un poisson qui pourrit
par la tête, vous avez une communauté
nationale qui est en train d'exploser.
Donc c'est lié. Et le contrat social, il
s'appuie sur d'abord le fait que nous
sommes en démocratie et que donc les
citoyens doivent décider de leur destin
en commun. Or ça, tout le monde sessuit
les les pompes dessus depuis depuis déjà
un bout de temps. Et ensuite sur la
promesse de méritocratie, c'est-à-dire
le fait que vous allez pouvoir vous en
sortir en fonction de euh vos efforts,
votre votre respect des règles. On voit
bien que tout ça est aujourd'hui balayé.
Je il y a pas d'ascenseur social. C'est
fondamental. Regardez le un pays qui ne
renouvelle pas ses élites, à peu près 25
% de ses élites à chaque génération, il
crève. Or, c'est ça qui est en train de
se passer. C'est-à-dire que là euh on a
le combien il y a de de gens de milieux
défavorisés de classe populaire à
l'Assemblée nationale ? Alors, on peut
d'ailleurs rendre hommage à LI parce que
Dieu sait que je peux leur reprocher des
choses, mais ils ont fait monter des
gens vraiment de milieu populaire à
l'Assemblée nationale. Des
gens de milieu populairire qui sont
intelligents.
Oui, voilà. Mais on est ça vient un
petit peu.
Attendez, mais n'empêche que le problème
c'est le renouvellement des élites et
pour ça si vous détruisez l'école vous
pouvez pas faire ça. On a l'école qui
reproduit le plus les inégalités
sociales de tous les pays de l'OCDE.
C'est un scandale, c'est tout. Donc tant
qu'on aura pas réglé ça, on peut
raconter tout le reste. Vous savez,
Aristote définissait un citoyen non pas
comme quelqu'un qui vote mais comme
quelqu'un qui peut gouverner. Vous allez
dans la rue, vous demandez aux Français
est-ce que vous sentez que vous pourriez
être parmi les gouvernants, les
représentants ? Il y en a combien qui se
projettent là-dedans ? Mais une infime
minorité. Pourquoi ? parce que justement
il y a une caste qui se reproduit et qui
sait que ça va ça va lui échoir et les
autres ont l'impression que bah ils sont
totalement exclus de ça.
Vous iriez à la guerre avec cette caste
en question ?
Alors euh
une formation militaire ?
Non, j'ai moi j'ai pas de formation
militaire.
Comment ça ça on n pas appris à tirer
aux famasses
? Alors non, moi j'ai enfin j'ai j'ai
appris à tirer quand j'étais toute
petite fille parce que mon père
m'emmenait faire du dans un dans un club
de tir, c'est tout.
Encore un gars d'extrême droite ça non ?
C'est le c'est le maximum que j'ai fait.
Vous savez quoi ?
Alors là vous savez, j'en ai aucune
idée.
Vous avez quel âge ?
J'étais toute petite, j'avais 6 7 ans.
Oh du du carabine à plomb.
Oui c'est ça. Carabine à plomb. Mais
vous savez
ça faisait pan ou pas ?
Ça faisait pompon. Alors 22 Lon rifles
parce que le 357 Magnum à cet âge-là euh
il faut mettre des gants et un casque.
Non non et puis moi vous avez vu mes
petits bras
je tremble vous savez faut connaître
ça recule pas le fling ça monte donc
faut faire attention comme ça c'est mais
faut faut connaître ses limites mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est parce qu'on
n'est pas
il faut élargir sa sa zone de confort
oui bien sûr mais pour autant on a le
droit de se renseigner d'essayer de
comprendre et cetera, même si on n pas
eu de formation et voilà c'est tout
c'est
vousz la guerre avec les gens qui nous
gouvernent là dans l'état actuel des
choses il y a peu de gens avec lesquels
je montrais au front, j'en vois et ils
sont pas dans la ils sont pas dans les
castes des dirigeants avec
Stéphan ses journées,
il est petit, il passe dans les
tranchées, il est bien, il est bien ce
garslà ou avec Bruno Lemire,
je veux dire c'est très important cette
question là de savoir avec qui on
monterait au front cette question de la
confiance. D'abord, moi j'ai quand par
exemple quand je travaille, quand je
recrute des gens, quand je monte une
équipe, je prends que des gens dont je
me dis justement que je pourrais monter
au front avec. Je prends des gens
d'abord, je prends par principe, je
prends des gens que j'estime meilleur
que moi dans la plupart des domaines.
C'estàd je fais en sorte de voilà de
combler toutes mes lacunes avec les gens
avec que que j'embauche. Donc je prends
des gens plus intelligents, ça c'est la
base, plus intelligents que moi. Et
ensuite
compliqué. Non
non non non. Alors, il y a des gens qui
sont 1000 fois plus dès que moi sur des
tas des tas de choses et c'est cela
qu'il faut prendre. Et ensuite, je
prends des gens qui
comme moi
fonctionne à au devoir, au sens du
devoir, c'est-à-dire du
devoir du sacrifice.
Alors, pas forcément du sacrif, je suis
pas je suis pas dans une dimension
sacrificielle.
Je suis dans le sens du devoir,
c'est-à-dire que on se doit au aux
autres jusqu'au bout. Moi, j'ai été
éduqué comme ça. Tu dois donc tu peux.
Voilà. Donc et d'ailleurs c'est marrant
mais quand on regarde
Non, ça c'est pas pareil. Non non, c'est
tu peux
C'est la stratégie de Macron. C'est ça.
Voilà, tu peux mais tu dois te retenir.
Voilà, tu fais un homme ça s'empêche. Ça
c'est la la phrase de Camu qui vient de
du discours. Faut toujours connaître le
l'histoire. C'est dans le premier homme
et c'est son père en fait qui est qui
était dans les troupes coloniales et euh
il se il est avec un autre soldat, ils
font ils sont en patrouille et ils
tombent sur une autre patrouille qui a
été massacrée par une tribu mais
massacrée de façon atroce.
Et sauf que l'autre soldat dit "Mais
c'est normal, ils sont colonisés, c'est
normal qu'ils se vengent et cetera."
Et le père de Camu dit "Ouais mais enfin
tout de même un homme ça s'empêche."
Voilà, c'est-à-dire que il comprend le
fait que il y ait une colère mais il dit
même quand tu as une colère, il faut se
retenir. Il y a des limites qu'on ne
peut pas franchir. Elle vient de là
cette citation. Quand
le peuple français va commencer à avoir
de la moutarde qui lui montre réellement
au nez, il va falloir que le peuple
français s'empêche.
Il faut toujours s'empêcher. Il faut
toujours se petit rodéo sur le périf
avec des cords traînés à la corde. Non.
Le principe des limites, c'est un c'est
un principe de civilisation, c'est
fondamental. Mais là aussi, il y a une
question d'exemplarité.
C'est-à-dire que c'est justement à ceux
qui ont le pouvoir, la parole publique
de maintenir ce principe d'exemplarité,
de se dire qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
fait pas, des choses qu'on ne dit pas.
Vous savez, George Jorel appelait ça la
dessence commune. Moi, j'appelle ça la
vergogne. Voilà, on se on se tient.
Question internet. Le le contrat social
n'est-il pas cassé ? Le vieux contrat
social disait "Tu travailles, tu
progresses, tu deviens propriétaire.
Aujourd'hui, tu travailles, tu payes un
loyer délirant, tu t'épuises, tu ne
construis rien. Bon, je rajouterai, tu
te fais ravager par l'inflation parce
que comme on a des goliot en guerre
économique,
quand la promesse s'effonde, la
motivation suit. L'angle mort du débat,
c'est la revalorisation du travail
lui-même. Deux points, salaire digne,
condition modernes, formation continue
réelle, management humain, partage de la
valeur.
Il a aussi une cheminée chez lui. Le
Père Noël descend par la cheminée. Non
non mais sa question elle est très
importante parce qu'il y a une dimension
qu'on n'a pas suffisamment abordée pour
l'instant et c'est pour ça que sur
l'inflation par exemple on peut ne pas
être tout à fait d'accord c'est que le
problème des politiques qu'on mène
depuis les années 80 c'est que pour
répondre à cette dérégulation
généralisée on a mené une politique qui
est une une politique de monnaie forte
qui nous arrimait euh au aux marques qui
préparaient l'entrée dans la monnaie
unique.
Ce choix-là, c'est un choix qui favorise
les rentiers, qui favorise ceux qui sont
déjà propriétaires.
Là, au sortir de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale, qu'est-ce qui a été fait ?
Alors évidemment, il fallait tout
reconstruire et cetera, mais la jeunesse
qui avait payé le plus lourd tribut dans
un sens, elle a été remercié.
C'est-à-dire que c'était un système où
il y avait de l'inflation et où du coup
on pouvait emprunter, on pouvait donc
rentrer sur le marché sur le marché du
travail, dans la vie active et cetera.
Aujourd'hui, les jeunes ne peuvent plus,
c'est un système qui est fait pour ceux
qui possèdent déjà, donc pour les vieux.
Et c'est ça qui n'est jamais dit. C'est
pour ça que la question de la monnaie,
elle est très importante et c'est pour
ça que on est là, on se retrouve avec en
effet une méritocratie qui n'existe
plus. Donc le le la base du contrat de
de la promesse républicaine, l'idée que
si on respecte les règles et si on est
si on est méritant, si on en veut, on va
pouvoir réussir. Ensuite, vous avez des
salaires qui suivent plus l'inflation.
Donc qui ait de l'inflation ou qui en
est pas, de toute façon, c'est les
possédants et les épargnants qui sont
qui sont favorisés. Et vous avez un
marché de l'immobilier qui est
entièrement verrouillé. On peut ajouter
une chose d'ailleurs, c'est que dans les
années 90, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
la dérégulation et le changement des
lois fiscales ont fait que les ce qu'on
appelle les bailleurs institutionnels,
les assurance, les banques qui
possédaient tout un parc immobilier et
qui le faisait rouler sur le long terme,
voyez donc des des loyers à peu près
corrects, on leur a dit "Non, non,
attendez, faut pas faire ça, faut faire
tourner les actifs." Et on a incité par
des règles fiscales à faire tourner les
actifs. Donc, ils ont tous vendu,
souvenez-vous, on appelait ça les ventes
à la découpe. Tous les bailleurs
institutionnels ont vendu leurs
appartements à la découpe et ont fait
exploser les loyers. Donc tout ça,
voyez, ça fait que ceux qui veulent
démarrer dans la vie, les jeunes, ben
ils peuvent pas, il y a pas de travail,
on peut pas se loger, on peut pas
emprunter. Donc on est dans un système
qui étouffe et après on s'étonne que les
jeunes fassent pas d'enfants. Voilà.
Mais rien n'est fait pour sécuriser,
pour donner la possibilité de se
projeter dans un avenir. Et ça, on on là
aussi on va vers des catastrophes, ne
serait-ce que parce que évidemment on a
besoin de faire des enfants pour
garantir un système par répartition et
pour garantir un minimum de croissance,
mais de toute façon, on a aussi besoin
de faire des enfants pour tout
simplement perpétuer une civilisation,
une culture. Je veux dire tout ce dont
on vient de parler est lié à cette
question là. Je veux dire vous parlez de
la guerre. Moi j'ai des enfants, j'ai
trois enfants, je les ai mis au monde,
je suis responsable du monde
un fils aîné qui a 17 ans.
Ouais. Il fait une chose du combien pour
que je passe commande pour sa paire de
rangers quand on va aller faire la
guerre avec Bruno c'est pour ça que
voilà moi je sais ce que c'est de se
dire mon fils pourrait être envoyé faire
la guerre dans un an il a l'âge de faire
la guerre je pardon mais ça me traverse
enfin c'est c'est pas seulement que ça
me traverse l'esprit c'est que j'ai
conscience de ça j'ai conscience que si
on ne change pas les choses si on ne
change pas de trajectoire on va vers la
catastr catastrophe. Donc je ce sens de
la responsabilité
euh les générations qui veulent pas
faire de gamin peut-être aussi non le
sens de la responsabilité de
il y a tellement le gras politique le
gras journalistique qui pulle sur ces
300 300 3300 milliards de dettes qui ça
fait perdurer le rondron quotidien de
toutes ces petites Nous on appelle ça la
génération WHCAS dès que la boîte elle
s'ouvre On les voit tous, ils arrivent.
Oui. Mia mia. L'Europe est en train de
faire ça. D'ailleurs, on n' pas parlé de
l'Europe qui va financer des vrais
médias indépendants, reconnu,
indépendant par l'Europe et Ursula. La
génération Wiscass médiatique. Bon,
revenons à à la guerre. La la génération
qui entend par Emmanuel Macron le
réarmement démographique. Tu comprends ?
Vas-y Louloute, fais des gamins mais on
s'en fout. Tu as pas de crèche, tu as
pas de pédiatre, tu as rien du tout.
Puis tranquille, tu as pas de prof. Euh
puis quand tu as des profs, bon, ils ont
la moyenne de cuit français. Euh euh
quand on voit ça,
oui, ça donne pas envie.
Moi, la génération qui veut pas faire de
gamin, je la regarde et je dis "Mais
gros, tu es responsable, je suis
d'accord avec toi. Notre culture
française livrée à cette bande de
troufion,
vaut mieux qu'elle parte que de leur
laisser pervertir ce qu'on a été."
Je grossis le trait, je fais exprès.
J'arrive pas à vous énerver. C'est un
truc de dingue hein.
J'ai le raisonnement inverse. C'est
parce que vous êtes une femme, c'est ça
?
Ah non non, c'est alors je je raisonne
pas en fonction de voilà de mes voilà.
Non
non, j'ai le raisonnement inverse.
C'est-à-dire que je crois profondément
qu'il y a des choses à transmettre.
C'est-à-dire que ce que ce qu'incarne la
France, le mode de vie qui que nous
avons collectivement inventé, l'idée de
la liberté humaine, la possibilité de de
enfin on est quand même le seul pays au
monde où on n'est pas en kikquiné en
permanence par Dieu, la transcendance où
on peut vivre en dehors de ça. Voilà
tout ça. chez moi, j'ai l'hôtel de la
dévotion pour Bruno le Mire.
C'est une autre divinité. Mais tout ça,
il faut au contraire le perpétuer. Il
faut au contraire faire en sorte que ça
soit un modèle. Je dire il y a dans le
monde entier des gens qui considèrent
que ce que la France a apporté au monde,
c'était quelque chose d'absolument
exaltant. Enfin, si vous vous imaginez à
quel point une des œuvres littéraires
les plus connues au monde, c'est Bruno
Lemer.
Euh non, les misérables. Les misérables.
C'est-à-dire que la France c'est ça,
c'est un pays où tout à coup on a
considéré que faire bosser des gosses de
5 ans dans des mines, le laisser des
gosses abandonnés
à mendier leur pains, c'était
inacceptable. Voilà, c'est ça la France.
La France, c'est un pays où on a
considéré que les peuples avaient droit
au bonheur. Voilà, que les les gens
n'étaient pas condamné à crever dans
l'indifférence. La France, c'est le pays
où on a écrit la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen. J'y tiens
parce que c'est en tant que citoyen
qu'on peut faire valoir ses droits où il
y a l'article 2, c'est-à-dire le les
distinctions sociales ne peuvent être
fondées que sur l'utilité commune. Mais
ça ça se perpétue. Donc si on fait pas
d'enfant, si on ne se bat pas pour notre
modèle, si on ne se bat pas pour la
transmission de notre culture, tout ça
va disparaître. Ben, j'ai tendance à
penser que pour le bien de l'humanité
toute entière, on a intérêt à perpétuer
ça.
On a quand même un un on a quand même
fait des choses pas belles.
Ah non, mais on a fait des choses
ignobles, monstrueuses, absolument
dégueulasses et qu'il faut enseigner.
C'est-à-dire que déjà euh je si on veut
comprendre la laïcité à la française,
faut enseigner les guerres de religion.
Faut déjà enseigner la croisade contre
les albouois, enfin toutes les horreurs
de ce genre. Vendéens aussi.
Voilà. Oui, aussi les Vendéens. Il faut
enseigner les guerres de religion,
c'est-à-dire le fait queon a été capable
religieux.
Non non non, là c'était les royalistes
contre les mais les guerres de religion,
il faut il faut expliquer que c'est pour
ça que petit à petit on aboutit à cette
idée de mise à distance de de la
religion de la transcendance et l'idée
que il faut préserver cet espace commun.
C'est ça permettrait d'expliquer à des
gamins qui aujourd'hui croient que
laïcité est dirigée contre leur religion
que non. C'est parce que nous on sait ce
que est dirigé contre le Vous parlez de
la Tourette là. Bah c'està-dire que on a
aujourd'hui et moi je fais des des des
interventions dans des collèges, dans
des lycées où évidemment que je vois des
gosses qui me disent "Mais la laïcité
c'est contre l'islam, c'est contre les
musulmans." Donc il faut en permanence
refaire leur raconter leur raconter
d'abord donc les guerres de religion,
l'horreur absolue, ensuite leur raconter
1789 parce qu'en fait la laïcité c'est
pas juste c'est pas un principe
juridique. pas la loi de 1905, ça c'est
la loi de séparation des églises et de
l'État. La laïcité, c'est un principe
politique qui découle de 1789 et de ce
concept génial, le peuple souverain.
C'est-à-dire que des citoyens peuvent
s'assembler et décider de leur destin en
dehors d'une transcendance. On n pas
besoin d'un Dieu qui nous dit il faut
faire ça. Voilà, on est libre. Donc
c'est si vous expliquez le truc comme
ça, vous arrivez à faire comprendre.
Ensuite, vous leur racontez à quel point
la loi de 1905 il a fallu se battre, à
quel point il a fallu en fait vraiment
attaquer le catholicisme à la godasse
pour petit à petit réussir à être libre.
Faut leur raconter que ça a été
extrêmement violent et ensuite faut leur
dire voilà la loi de 1905 c'est un
principe de liberté pour les individus.
Oui, c'est une loi qui est très libérale
pour les individus. En revanche, qui est
impitoyable pour les prêcheurs. Et
d'ailleurs, au lendemain de la loi de
1905, les juges utilisaient ça pour
torpiller tous ceux qui essayaient de
manipuler, de pratiquer du prosélitisme.
Bien sûr. Donc tout ça, on le raconte et
là ça passe. Fa boulot
juste
les guerres de religion, c'était des
guerres de religion ou c'était des
guerres économiques ?
Mais ça va avec. Il y a toujours que la
religion c'est l'emballage. C'est genre
genre c'est pour le crédible le guu si
tu fais pas bien tu vas aller enfer.
Alors c'est pas
tu peux tuer tu peux tuer le le mec qui
traîne dans le sable avec son chameau
parce que Dieu le veut mais il est sur
la route de notre business donc Dieu le
veut deux fois.
Non mais ça c'est les croisades.
Oui. Bah oui les croisades.
Oui d'accord. Ça c'est les croisades.
Mais moi je
on a commencé un peu par là quoi. Non
on est d'accord. Enfin, quand on parle
des guerres de religion, c'est la
réforme, c'est les c'est les
Non mais d'accord, mais c'est ça nous on
a connu, il faut lire Agripa Dobinier,
c'est absolument atroce. Et ensuite, on
a Henri I qui arrive et qui réussit à
réconcilier la nation. Moi je j'entends
toujours les les les mecs qui adorent
jouer aux petits soldats de plomb au
machin. Alors il y a Napolé journé
il y a Napoléon, il y a Louis X le grand
ro ancien premier ministre qui a du
duvet là euh
Gabriel Tal.
Ah oui voilà. Bah Henri I, ça c'est un
roi immense. C'est un roi qui réconcilie
la nation. Et derrière vous avez Louis
14 qui décide de révoquer les dit Nantes
qui lancent des dragonades qui
un veul pal toquet face à notre idole
Bruno Lebert. Changeons de sujet. On
arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview parce que bon comme vous ne
bougez pas, mon cadre est en train de
s'endormir. Il fait semblant de
travailler depuis tout à l'heure. Je te
surveille toi. Puis il y a rien
encore.
Intermittent du spectacle tout de grou.
! Ah ouais, on la reconnaît hein.
On trêve de plaisanterie. Ça fait quand
même 2h45 que j'essaie de vous faire
sortir de vos gon ça ne fonctionne pas.
On vote quoi ? Prochaines élections ?
Alors on verra ce qu'il y a à voter.
Pourquoi vous présentez pas en politique
?
Ça c'est trop tard. Ça veut dire ce que
ça veut dire. Vous y avez réfléchi.
Non, ça alors
c'est trop dangereux.
Ça veut dire Non, ça veut dire qu'il y a
il a dit non. Je sais qu'il y a des il y
a des gens a dit
il y a des gens qui m'en parlent.
Perico, il a dit non ou pas ?
Je je termine,
on va être très honnête. Je dis jamais
fontaine, je boirai pas de ton eau parce
que je déteste les gens qui sont à
l'inruptoire, ils savent ce qu'ils vont
faire. Dans toute ma vie, j'ai jamais su
où je serais 2 ans après, 3 ans après.
Min de l'éducation.
Alors, c'est très compliqué ministre de
l'éducation parce que si on me le
proposait, je pourrais pas dire non. Je
me suis il a dit non ou pas pour le
gangement politique. [rires]
Perico, il vit
il vit sa vie hein. Il nous arrive assez
souvent de ne pas être d'accord. Et
vous avez parlé de la guerre entre vous
?
Vous avez parlé de la guerre entre vous
? Mais on parle de tout entre nous et de
tout
et vous avez dit bon euh le bon le
premier là le plus intelligent des trois
celui qu'on va sacrifier en premier pour
Bruno, il va aller faire la guerre. Vous
en avez parlé ou pas ?
Alors Perico euh et comme moi là-dessus,
c'est-à-dire que
nous avons conscience de des risques et
de ce qui est en train de se passer et
donc notre but dans la vie c'est
d'empêcher ça. Voilà. L'engagement
politique, ça en fait partie.
Je vais partout où je me sens utile, au
moment où je me sens utile. Donc là, je
lance cette revue, l'audace. En fait,
c'est pas seulement une revue,
d'ailleurs, c'est un média, c'est-à-dire
c'est une revue trimestrielle papier,
c'est derrière des conférences partout
en France, c'est euh
également des interventions sur les
réseaux sociaux si évidemment nous ne
sommes pas cancellés. Voilà. Mais l'idée
c'est cancell
Non, là pour l'instant non non non pour
l'instant on est tout petit, on commence
mais voilà le l'idée c'est de monter en
puissance et de rassembler des gens et
d'en faire une agora. Donc le principe
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a
commencé par une campagne Ulule. En fait
l'idée c'était d'avoir déjà une
communauté. Vous savez à quel point
c'est fondamental de partir de ça ? Donc
on a fait une campagne, un crowdfunding
et euh maintenant on va vendre donc on
sera on sera en kiosque et en librairie
le 1er décembre, je le dis vous allez
voir ça va être magnifique parce que
c'est un bel objet. C'estàd que c'est
une revue.
J'ai voulu que ce soit du papier parce
que j'ai voulu que ce soit un objet
esthétique et qui est un processus de
production. on défend la production sur
le sol français et ben on fait vivre des
imprimeurs, on fait vivre des diffuseurs
de presse, on fait vivre des kiosqués,
des libraires, ça va avec. Voilà. Et
donc cette cette revue, ça va être un
camp de base pour tous ceux qui ont
envie de se bouger justement, qui ont
pas envie de regarder le truc
s'effondrer lamentablement. Voilà. Et à
partir de là, on va créer donc je vais
on va se balader partout en province, on
va agréger des gens. Voilà. Donc vous
voyez, c'est ça, c'est ce que je fais là
maintenant.
Ça va être financé comment toute cette
histoire là ?
Bah on a commencé par le financement
Ulul.
Combien ?
Alors on a euh là on on a euh
de à peu près 250000 € par financement.
Pas tout de suite.
Ouais.
En combien de temps vous avez levé
250000 balles ?
Depuis le 23 septembre.
Ça va vous éviter le calendrier Only
Fan. C'est bien.
Exactement. Oui et ça je pense que pour
tout le monde c'est mieux. C'est
ça c'est [rires] pas dit hein.
Donc
et Pericot il a dit d'accord ou pas
d'accord ?
[rires]
Vous allez l'inviter il vous dira.
D'ailleurs, Pericot, tu nous entends ?
J'en suis sûr. Tu es chaleureusement
invité avant Noël pour discuter euh
bouffal et sacrifice de chapon.
Non, ça va être beau. Donc le on a au
départ on est quatre coactionnaires,
voyez. Euh
moi Frédéric Cassegrin qui est ancien DG
de Mariane, Raphaël Schmidth qui est
banquier qui s'occupe de PME et qui a
décidé de nous aider et Mathieu Puiesau
qui a bossé dans la tech qui vit en
Allemagne et qui avait envie de mettre
de l'argent dans un projet de de presse
qui correspondent à ces idées. Donc vous
voyez, on est quatre petits
coactionnaires. Il y a pas de
milliardaires, il y a pas de il y a
rien. Donc c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
une campagne lul pour enclencher le le
truc. Et là, on a une fois qu'on a un
modèle qui est consolidé, ce qui est le
cas, on a ouvert
à des investisseurs très spéciaux, les
forces françaises de l'industrie,
c'est-à-dire le fond d'investissement
des entrepreneurs du Mine France. Donc
eux, ils vont venir s'associer à nous,
on les fait rentrer un petit peu dans le
capital de façon parce qu'il y avait une
cohérence quoi. C'est tout simplement,
il a mis un peu de pognon ou pas ?
Il faut que je vérifie sur la liste des
contributeurs Ulul.
Arnaud Arnaud, comment il s'appelle ?
Arnaudbourg. C'est ça. C'était
bleu blanc rouge, bleu blanc cœur. C'est
ça. Bah faut faut que je faut que je
vérifie s'il est sur la liste des
contributeurs. Non non mais sans sans
plaisanter qu'il a dit au moins 100. les
forces françaises de l'industrie. Voilà,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui se battent
pour produire sur le sol français, pour
payer leurs impôts en France et pour
faire de pour créer de la richesse.
Donc, il y avait une logique à ce qu'on
leur ouvre un peu le capital mais tout
en tout en faisant en sorte de garder en
fait la main sur le la dimension euh la
dimension éditoriale. C'est-à-dire que
c'est les fondateurs qui doivent pouvoir
évidemment décider de la ligne.
Est-ce qu'on se prend une petite
question internet ?
C'est vous le chef ?
Euh, je suis le chef. Alors, un chef ça
s'est cheé.
Exactement.
Je prends laquelle ? Tu veux cheffer
avec moi ou
euh
ça ? On va prendre ça. Ouais. Alors,
bonsoir.
Encore un auditeur très poli.
Ouais, il son et je vais je vais vous
dire quelque chose. Ça c'est notre petit
aparté entre nous.
comme YouTube nous shadow ban ou a
changé son son algorithme ou va nous
dire n'importe quoi pour
on leur a dit cet après-midi, demain ce
soir, on fait une interview euh
journalisme. Lâchez-vous sur le titre
comme on est shadow, on en a on va être
joueur. Et ben ils ont été hyper polis
sans sans savoir qui allait venir ce
soir. Hyper poli.
les titres qu'il proposaient
refléteraient leurs inquiétudes et et
leurs questionnements et on a été très
très fier d'eux et on est fier de vous
les gars et les nanas question bonsoir
selon elle le changement se trouve où
pour interrogation les regards doivent
se tourner vers les municipales les
élections de 2027 ou ailleurs
alors les municipales c'est fondamental
parce que c'est à peu près le dernier
élu en lequel les Français ont confiance
he le maire même
non c'est
Bruno de la Tourette
donc
le problème étant que là aussi il y a un
empilement administratif par le
notamment les intercommunalités où on a
privé les maires de leur pouvoir donc il
y aurait tout un travail à faire de
rétablissement de la démocratie locale.
Ce serait absolument nécessaire de
reprendre la main. par exemple, il y
aurait un truc assez simple d'ailleurs,
ce serait de faire en sorte que les
collectivités territoriales
et réellement des la main sur les
impôts, sur certains impôts puissent
avoir ce qu'on leur a retiré petit à
petit leur propre financement parce que
comme ça ça les met ça les
responsabilise vis-à-vis de leurs
électeurs. Ils doivent ils doivent en
répondre ce qu'ils font de l'argent.
Tandis que là, vous voyez, petit à
petit, tout a été recentralisé. Donc en
fait, personne n'est responsable de
rien. Bref, les municipales, c'est moi
je je crois profondément à la gestion
locale. Pour autant, ça va pas changer
la vie. Ça va changer à l'échelle de
certaines villes et il faut reprendre la
main. il faut essayer de de s'investir,
ce qui est encore une fois très
compliqué parce que le je la carte
territoriale française a été
complètement abîmée. Derrière, on sait
très bien qu'en France les institutions,
elles sont entièrement concentrées,
beaucoup trop d'ailleurs, autour de
l'élection du président de la République
et le l'élection au suffrage universel
donne un poids absolument
énorme à ça. Et en plus, dans l'état
actuel des choses, on sait très bien
qu'il se passera rien d'ici là.
C'est-à-dire que là, si Sébastien Lecnu
ne tombe pas, bah derrière les mecs
roulent. Il y a les municipales. Plus on
se rapproche des municipales et moins ça
va bouger. De toute façon, tout le monde
va tenir ses positions parce que vous
avez toute une part des des partis
politiques qui n'ont pas intérêt à ce
que les choses bougent et parce que de
toute façon, ils sont déjà tous en train
de se prés de se préparer pour 2027.
Donc les partis politiques, on parle de
la dizaine de cantines qui essayent de
de pour avoir des des votes. Là,
c'est quoi les partis politiques ? Ben
oui, c'est c'est bien le problème, c'est
que euh
en fait les partis politiques, je fais
partie de des gens qui euh considèrent
que d'abord qu'il lisent les programmes.
Oui. Enfin, quand il y en avait, c'est
que quand vous lisez les résumés des
débats par exemple au Parti socialiste,
imaginez-vous en 19 dans les années 70,
imaginez en 2025 les contributions non
en dans les années 70 les contributions
dans les pour les congrès du Parti
socialiste, mais c'était des trucs
monumentaux. N'importe quel mouvement de
jeunesse vous pondait des trucs mais
extraordinaires. Là, aujourd'hui, le
boulot de réflexion est plus fait. chez
les jeunes communistes, même si euh
non sur l'énergie, ils ont bossé hein.
Ah oui oui bien sûr.
Tous les alors les les communistes,
comment il s'appelle ? Sarah Knafou,
elle bosse.
Oui oui, ça bosse. Mais il y a il y a
des gens encore une fois il y a des gens
qui bossent.
Comment il s'appelle
celui qui est bon en mat là ? Bon part
bosse. Bonp bosse. Bah les les insoumis
ils ont un ils ont un programme, ça
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire. Oui.
Non mais on pas avoir la partition mais
c'est peut-être pas le moment de le
jouer hein.
Voilà exactement c'est tout le problème.
C'estàd que je pourrais vous dire
exactement en quoi je suis radicalement
pas d'accord avec certains éléments. Ils
existent pourquoi encore déjà ?
Ben parce qu'ils ont fait alliance avec
les insoumis et que ça leur a permis
d'avoir des des sièges.
Ah on avait oublié ça parce que sinon
ils seraient morts.
Ah bah oui oui sinon ils auraient
disparu. Oui.
On était en train de parler de quoi là
déjà ? Donc, on était en train de parler
de l'organisation de la vie politique
française autour de l'élection au
suffrage universel du président de la
République. Et c'est tout le problème de
notre vie politique, c'est qu'évidemment
ça personnalise à outrance le l'élection
et en même temps dans la mesure où on a
retiré au peuple français à peu près
tous les leviers, le seul qui leur reste
c'est ça. Donc on va pas leur retirer
ça, ce serait une dinguerie. Donc il
faut faire et si elle dit que les
élections elles sont pas bonnes, on va
faire quoi ? On monte à Bruxelles la
chercher. Comment ça se passe ? Hein ?
Non, non, mais ça euh
un Paris-Bruxelles tranquille.
Oui, oui, oui, oui. Non, mais là, là,
pour le coup, je pense qu'il y a un
moment où les Français peuvent s'énerver
vraiment. Ils ont déjà montré qu'ils
pouvaient le faire. H 2018
le pouvoir en place a eu très pe 2018.
Heureusement qu'on a aboli le service
militaire
parce que si les Français avaient encore
une formation
de terrain,
c'est un des sujets hein. C'est
Mais bon, on va revenir au service
militaire, vous inquiétez pas. Les
Allemands sont en train de nous donner
la marche à suivre. Euh question, je
vais je vais la poser quand même mais
vous n'allez pas y répondre. Je vais y
répondre à à votre place.
Vous m'autorisez ?
Je vous autorise tout. C'est vous qui
menez l'interview.
Son mari, il vote à droite pour
l'interrogation à l'extrême droite. Et
ben son mari, quand on va le recevoir,
on lui posera la question. Et de toutes
les façons, la femme, elle vote pas
comme son mari.
Exactement.
Il fait ce qu'il veut et on se frite sur
beaucoup de choses et il est euh comment
dire ? C'est bon, j'ai répondu. He, vous
êtes pas obligé de oui. Non, mais voilà,
je j'aime bien qu'on puisse pas mettre
les gens dans des cases.
Je trouve ça toujours intéressant.
Mais le problème, c'est qu'on met
beaucoup de gens dans les cases pour les
ostraciser, pour leur faire fermer leur
leur bouchou, les choses comme ça.
Question internet que je ne lis pas, que
je vais découvrir avec vous, que je n'ai
pas lu, pardon. Bonsoir. Le 4e pouvoir,
faiseur de roi, est en train de
s'effondrer, entraînant une panique chez
les dirigeants qui n'ont plus qui n'ont
pas la maîtrise des nouveaux acteurs.
Pensez
pensez-vous que les journalistes ont les
moyens de produire de l'information sur
ces vecteurs ? Ne sont-ils pas eux aussi
dépassés ? Bah bien sûr, mais c'est tout
ce qu'on a dit depuis tout à l'heure.
Ils
sont pas dépassés, ils ont un bon
réflexe de leur haine. Ils vont bien
maintenir leur petit place et puis quand
les Russes vont arriver parce que bon
comme ils étaient pas à genoux, bah là
ça va poser problème.
Alors c'est très intéressant cette
question parce que on voit à quel point
il y a eu une panique dans les médias.
Parce que d'abord, c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure, il y a un
principe économique, c'est-à-dire que il
faut bien comprendre que la mane
publicitaire, elle est partie chez chez
les gars femmes. 80 % de la publicité
est captée par Facebook, Google. Donc
les tous les journaux qui avaient comme
modèle économique, la publicité là sont
en train de s'effondrer. Les chaînes de
télé sont touchées, les radios aussi.
Deè point,
ça a pas l'air d'être touché. Non
non mais je c'est ils sont pas touchés
enfin ils sont en train de de grimper
enfin la la publicité est en train de s
de s'amenuiser petit à petit. Ça c'est
le premier point. 2e point pour la
presse écrite en particulier, la
catastrophe, c'était déjà euh Google qui
captait les contenus sans les payer. Il
a fallu les droits voisins. Sauf que en
fait, comme les pouvoirs publics en
particulier en France n'ont absolument
pas soutenu, Google a signé des
partenariats avec certains médias.
C'est-à-dire que
non
le monde en Australie en fait
le le gouvernement australien a dit aux
différents médias vous tenez bon vous
vous laissez pas faire par Google vous
exigez le paiement des droits voisins et
on vous soutient réalité ils ont fait
plier Google nous qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ils étaient aux abonnés absents.
Je me souviens, je on est allé voir le
ministère de la culture et de la
communication et cetera. Abonné absent,
rien à faire. Moralité, tout le les
médias, la presse écrite étaient paniqué
parce que Google faisait un chantage. On
vous payera pas les droits voisins mais
on veut bien vous payer trois cacahuètes
et ils ont réussi.
On va vous dééférencer il
Bah voilà, c'est ce que je disais. Donc
jour, nuit jour nuit. Voilà, on vous on
vous éteint. Et le monde a été le
premier à signer un partenariat avec
Google et les autres ont suivi les uns
après les autres. Ça s'appelle la
technique du salami. Et bien maintenant,
qu'est-ce qui arrive ? Les intelligences
artificielles, chat GPT et le monde a
été le premier média à signer un accord
avec Chat GPT. Donc ils sont référencés
mais on se doute bien que Chat GPT va
pas signer un accord avec tous les
médias. Donc ils en référence
quelques-uns et puis les autres c'est
tant pis pour eux. Ils se font pomper
leur travail, leur contenu et ils ne
sont jamais rémunérés. Donc en fait tout
ça pour dire que le journalisme tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui peut
potentiellement disparaître dans les 10
à 15 ans à venir parce qu'il y a plus de
modèle économique
et ça n'a pas l'air
de d'intéresser qui que ce soit. Si
quand on écoute les journalistes, ils
ont toujours des super syndicats
extraordinairement bien pour emmerder
tout le monde et que voilà qu'on va
défendre vos intérêts, que j'en passe
des meilleurs. Les syndicats de
journalistes là, ils ont commencé à ils
ont pas commencé à essayer de faire
valoir pourquoi ils ont payé ou pourquoi
on cotise ou ils ont fait le salami ? Il
est bon le salami. Non.
Non mais c'est tout le problème. Mais
c'est alors la question c'est est-ce
qu'il faut faire valoir les intérêts des
journalistes ou est-ce qu'il faut faire
valoir les intérêts du journalisme du
vrai journalisme ? C'est pas exactement
la même chose.
Je plus sois je plus sois. Euh
tiens, en parlant de ça, les fake news
là, euh
les fermatrol
en Russie, ils étaient à 4500 m², ils
sont partis, ils sont passés à 14500 m².
Bon, on a arrêté de se fighter avec eux
à partir de 2019
et c'était très rigolo. D'ailleurs, on
avait attrapé le numéro 2 du ministère
de l'intérieur
avec caméra et on lui dit "Bon écoute,
tu es gentil avec tes fermes à troll, tu
es en train de pourrir la relation
franco-russe là, tu veux pas leur dire
de se calmer un peu là ?" "Ah oui mais
tu comprends, c'est une cellule privée,
bon on peut rien faire." Bon excuse à
deux balles.
Bon euh en France on en a des fermes à
troll mais bon c'est des trolls des
troll très pané donc puis quand ils
touchent pas leur subvention ça marche
pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On renforce le
budget de l'éducation nationale par 50.
va falloir,
j'ai pas fini la question.
Pardon ?
On renforce l'éducation nationale par 50
parce que endurcir, forger et apprendre
à résister dans son sa petit cerveau de
jeune, ça se fait dès le départ
où on continue d'arroser plétor de de
pseudo fact checker ministère de la
vérité que vas-y que je te pousse que
j'ai toujours raison et tu comprends. On
est plein de copains à dire la même
chose donc on a forcément raison.
Euh, on fait quoi ? On fait la stratégie
éducation nationale ou la stratégie
guerry hybride Hollywood, Union
européenne,
les méchants, les méchants.
Voyez le le discours d'Emmanuel Macron
là il y a quelques jours pour expliquer
que il fallait absolument
se préparer, que les réseaux sociaux,
c'était une grande catastrophe.
On part de la question de du rôle des
réseaux sociaux sur les enfants qui en
effet voilà qui est une catastrophe
absolue.
Et on arrive à quoi ? une déclaration du
président de la République qui finit par
dire "Vous comprenez
très rapidement quand on va sur un
réseau social on arrive avec des idées
d'extrême droite qui sont poussées.
Donc en gros, on passe de la protection
des enfants face à des mécanismes
d'algorithmes qui ont pour but de les
manipuler.
Donc de faire bouffer de la pub. Voilà,
de leur faire bouffer de la pub et de
leur faire acheter ensuite des
cochonneries fabriquées en Chine.
Et donc on passe à ça.
Ça peut être fabriqué ailleurs.
Oui, d'accord. Enfin, moi je préfère que
qu' soit pas manipulé par des
algorithmes et qu'on achète du fabriqué
en France parce que là au moins ça paye
ça paye des impôts ça et parce queil
faut il suffit d'expliquer aux gens que
quand ils achètent sur Chine par exemple
bah ils votent pour un système où à un
moment donné on va leur demander de
payer de bosser jusqu'à 67 ou 70 ans
puisque on les fait acheter des choses
qui ne qui ne permettent pas
d'entretenir le modèle social. Donc il y
a un choix économique à faire, mais
c'est pas le sujet. Le sujet c'est la
déclaration. Donc on passe de la
protection des enfants à bah tout
simplement la régulation des idées,
celles qui sont bonnes et celles qui
sont pas bonnes. Et c'est ça la
catastrophe absolue. Il y a un sujet sur
le rôle d'abrutissement généralisé des
réseaux sociaux et la manipulation.
D'ailleurs, je commence à en avoir
ralbol de des supposés libéraux qui
expliquent mais après tout, c'est la
liberté des gens par exemple d'aller
consommer une fois qu'ils ont vu des
pubs sur leur sur leur timeline et
cetera. Euh la liberté c'est la
manipulation. Le libéralisme s'est fondé
sur l'idée que nous sommes tous doués de
raison. C'est la raison universelle.
Donc l'individu raisonnable, autonome,
responsable, dans ces cas-là, il peut
faire ses arbitrages. Mais quand on fait
du neuromarketing, de la manipulation
par les algorithmes, elle est où la
liberté exactement ? Je donc si on
autorise ça, en fait, on n'est plus dans
un système libéral et on n plus en
démocratie puisque la démocratie est
appuyée cette idée de de la
responsabilité. Je peux me faire
son problème ? Non mais c'est très pané.
S'ils sont pas capables de résister à
mon neuromarketing d'enfoiré, bah c'est
qu'il mérite de bouffer de la merde.
Alors non, c'est que nous avons euh des
on va dire euh un cerveau qui est
formaté depuis des millénaires et qui
donc va nous amener à répondre à des
stimulis malgré nous. Et donc c'est pour
ça que l'éducation existe parce qu'elle
permet de mettre à distance ça, de
comprendre le fonctionnement du cerveau
et de savoir que quand on agite comme ça
des stimulis qui vont faire marcher la
dopamine, ça nous manipule et cetera. Si
si on l'explique pas aux gamins, ils ne
peuvent pas le comprendre ça. De même
que ça nécessite tout simplement de
transmettre une culture, une culture qui
va leur permettre de pas euh considérer
que le but dans la vie, c'est de
posséder des objets à la con qui ne
servent à rien, qui sont dans dont on a
détruit peu à peu la qualité parce que
ça coûtait moins cher à fabriquer. Donc
on va leur apprendre à aimer ce qui est
beau. accessoirement, on va leur
apprendre à fabriquer par eux-mêmes avec
leurs mains. À chaque fois que je croise
des ministres de l'éducation nationale,
je leur suggère de mettre des cours de
de bricolage et de couture à l'école
primaire parce que ça ça rend
intelligent, voyez. Non mais couture
chez les mecs, c'est vachement bien.
Bien sûr,
ça permet de se recoudre soi-même. C'est
euh bah évidemment, ça c'est très
sur ça s'apprend très tôt.
C'est ça. Non non, c'est pas couture
pour les filles et bricolage pour les
garçons. C'est couture et bricolage pour
tout le monde. Pourquoi ? Parce que vous
avez des gamins qui sont pas forcément
au départ doués tout de suite pour
l'abstraction. C'est pas leur truc. En
revanche, par la manipulation d'objets,
on arrive à l'abstraction. Parce que je
peux vous garantir que pour faire de la
couture, il faut une intelligence, une
capacité à visualiser dans l'espace et
cetera qui est extraordinaire. Donc le
les savoirs manuels, ce sont des savoirs
aussi intellectuels. Donc faire ça dès
le départ, c'est donner aux enfants la
capacité à agir sur le monde, à modifier
la matière et donc à aimer produire, à à
retrouver une fierté à produire et
ensuite à regarder comment les choses
sont faites et donc à pas se laisser
refourguer des cochonneries. Vous voyez,
c'est par là que vous arrivez petit à
petit à donner les anticorps. C'est pas
en censurant les idées qui conviennent
pas, vous voyez ? Or là, au nom de la
protection de l'enfance, ce qu'on ne
fait pas, parce que ça en revanche on
régule pas hein pour les enfants, et ben
on va aller vers de la censure. Je pense
que c'est la pire manière de faire.
L'identité numérique, ça vous bote, ça
vous vote pas ? C'est bien, c'est pas
bien ? Alors, je vais avouer très
franchement que ça, j'ai pas encore
bossé suffisamment dessus. A priori, je
suis pas voilà, je suis pas très très
chaude, mais je n'ai pas de Voilà.
Question internet, bonsoir. Vous ne
perdez pas un peu vue de vue votre
mission ? En tant que journaliste, votre
force, c'est de chercher l'info,
compiler les données et nous les
présenter clairement. On compte sur vous
pour les fait pas nous dire ce qu'il
faut penser.
C'est vrai. Ah
oui, c'est vrai. Mais sauf qu'ils ont
oublié ça surtout au monde. L'éditorial
ne prend-il pas trop d'importance et le
manque de journalisme ne rend-il pas
aveugle ? Point interrogation ? À quoi
bon faire de l'éditorial sans donner
point d'interrogation ? Alors, je suis
entièrement d'accord
que les choses soient claires. Moi,
d'abord, je suis maintenant
éditorialiste. C'est vrai que je fais
plus d'enquête de terrain parce que tout
simplement je je dirige un journal. J'ai
dirigé Marianne et ensuite maintenant je
dirige l'audace. C'est-à-dire que c'est
pas moi qui fait le travail de terrain.
Ensuite euh
la toute la différence c'est que quand
j'éditorialise, je le fais sur la base
d'un boulot, c'est-à-dire des lectures,
des connaissances. J'évite de parler de
ce que je connais pas. Mais évidemment
qu'un média lui, il doit s'appuyer sur
des journalistes qui apportent de la
donnée. Alors attention, ça se réduit
pas à ça le journalisme. Je me méfie
beaucoup des gens qui te qui vous disent
le journalisme c'est juste rapporter des
faits. D'abord parce que les faits ça
existe pas. C'estàd tout simplement à
partir du moment où vous racontez des
faits, il y a déjà une subjectivité qui
intervient. Je quand je j'interviens
devant des devant des classes sur ce que
c'est que le journalisme, je leur cite
cet exemple.
Public ou privé ?
Bah les deux, tout
rémunéré par rémunéré.
Ah non, pas rémunéré. Non. Et euh bah
non, quand on va voir des collégiens,
c'est pour leur voilà, c'est pour leur
expliquer des choses. Et donc je leur
dis, "Écoutez bien euh
quand je vous donne la phrase, par
exemple, ce matin,
une poule a été violemment percutée par
une voiture qui passait sur la route,
cette col.
Voilà. Alors, vous avez vous réagissez
pas exact. Écoutez bien la deuxième
phrase. Ce matin, une voiture n'a pas
réussi à éviter une poule qui picorait
sur le bas côté.
Cette cogne.
Voilà. Alors vous, vous avez mauvais
esprit, c'est cette conne dans les deux
dans les deux dans les deux cas.
Globalement, on s'aperçoit que quand on
dit une poule a été violemment percutée,
a priori c'est une victime. On se dit la
bagnole roulait trop vite, qu'est-ce qu'
foutent là ? Alors que quand on le dit
en disant une voiture n'a pas pu éviter
une poule, là on se dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle foutait là ? parce qu'elle était
pas un peu trop sur la route et cetera.
Donc vous voyez, dans les mots qu'on
emploie, on va induire une
interprétation et même les chiffres, ça
peut donner lieu à ça. Moi, j'ai bossé
pendant des années sur l'éducation, les
questions d'éducation. Vous aviez euh le
ministère de de l'éducation nationale
qui vous donnait les chiffres de la
direction de l'évaluation et de la
prospective qui disait que le niveau
montait. Voilà, 1985 à 1995. sont les 10
glorieuses de l'éducation nationale
parce qu'on a doublé le nombre de
bâcheliers. Bon donc comme h de moyenne.
C'est ça.
Voilà comme disait Churchill, je ne
crois que que les statistiques que j'ai
moi-même manipulé. Donc la question
c'est pas seulement de donner des faits,
il faut donner des faits. Il faut en
rendre compte, non pas de manière
objective puisque ça n'existe pas, mais
avec la plus grande honnêteté
intellectuelle, c'est-à-dire en étant
capable de donner les faits, même quand
ils viennent démentir euh vos propres
croyances, vos conceptions. Et ensuite,
il faut replacer les faits dans un
contexte, c'est-à-dire avoir
suffisamment de culture, de
connaissances pour pouvoir dire "Alors
là, il y a-t-elle fait mais d'où
vient-il ?" Vous voyez, pas typiquement
dans l'éducation nationale si là on voit
que il y a de de nouveau une envie
d'aller euh d'aller de de mettre en
avant le sujet des rythmes scolaires, là
c'est ce qui viennent de nous trouver.
Bon bah, si vous connaissez un petit peu
tous les précédents, vous vous souvenez
que euh en 2012 arrivé des socialiste au
pouvoir, Vincent Payon qui avait qui
était un type qui avait réfléchi à
l'école et cetera et qui se lance dans
un truc sur les rythmes scolaires. On a
passé 2 ans à temps plein sur les
rythmes scolaires déjà et donc là, ils
veulent recommencer, voyez. Mais s'il
faut il faut pouvoir replacer dans le
contexte, expliquer pourquoi on en
pourquoi on en est là, expliquer, vous
voyez ? Donc c'est pas juste les faits,
c'est l'effet leur décryptage. Et
ensuite une fois que vous avez fait tout
ce travail, vous pouvez à un moment
donné essayer d'interpréter les faits du
moment que vous le faites sur la base
non pas de du doigt mouillé et moi je
pense que mais sur la base de
connaissance. C'est pour ça que
pas une petite fiche Wikipédia écrit par
quatre militants qui ont décidé de vous
ravager donc c'est pour ça la question
c'est pas de dévaloriser l'éditorial
aujourd'hui vous avez certains médias
qui ne fonctionnent que sur des des
éditaux et encore c'est même plus des
éditaux c'est de l'opinion en effet il y
en a pourquoi parce que on en revient au
modèle économique des médias ils sont
tellement fragilisés que la seule chose
qui est un modèle économique qui marche
C'est h pages avec que des
éditorialistes qui toutes les semaines
réécrivent le même éditorial et font de
l'opinion et qui disent ce que leur
public veut entendre parce que il faut
se radicaliser au fur et à mesure pour
capter la niche. On a plus que des
médias de niche. Ça c'est une
catastrophe.
Il y a de clébar quoi.
Alors oui, c'est ça. C'est que dans la
niche, il y a des il y a des clébars en
effet.
Donc le journalisme ça coûte cher
le journaliste ça coûte cher ?
Oui. Le vrai journalisme ça coûte cher.
Et vous savez comment on fait oublier un
clébar ?
Non.
Non. Bah soit vous lui vous tabassez la
gueule, ça finit toujours par vous faire
mordre.
Ouais.
Soit vous lui donnez pas à manger.
Non. Ouais. Je fais pas de blague. Non
non non mais je comprends bien. Mais
tout à fait bien entendu.
Donc ça obéit bien clébarque a faim.
Non.
Bah c'est tout le c'est c'est tout le
sujet. Encore une fois, faut toujours
revenir au modèle économique. Mais si
vous voulez comprendre pourquoi on a
plus que de l'opinion, faut comprendre
que c'est une question de modèle
économique.
Question. On parle de Clébar qui a faim.
Vous savez un Clébar quand il a trop
faim et qui fait 80 kg, vous rentrez le
soir et que vous lui pas donné à manger
parce que vous êtes un débile mental.
Parce que au lieu d'avoir un instinct de
leader qui montre les choses et qui fait
mieux vivre, vous préférez taper et
affamer. Normalement le chien de 80 kg,
il vous attend derrière la porte puis un
de ces quat il vous fait votre fête.
Pourquoi les journalistes, ceux qui ont
encore le droit de porter ce titre,
parce que dans l'âme, dans le cœur et
dans le cerveau, ça c'est reste encore
des pointes de diamant pour nous le
peuple. Pourquoi les journalistes ils
font pas un peu le ménage chez tous ceux
qui croûonnent et qui croûent à tous les
ratelier ? Pourquoi il il se
il curent pas un peu le bordel ? Ils
sont pas encore assez affamés ou ils
sont tous en mode 13 kg un peu chien
chihuahua ?
Je pense que ils sont en position de
faiblesse. D'abord parce que on a
uniformisé la profession par les école
de journalisme qui sont un principe de
en gros de Ouais. d'affaiblissement des
compétences. C'està-dire que tout
l'intérêt du journalisme, c'est que ça
ça recrutait des gens qui avaient vu
autre chose, qui avaient fait qui
avaient exercé d'autres métiers avant. à
partir du moment où vous formatez
absolument tout, vous interdissez vous
interdisez la pensée, vous interdisez le
l'originalité
et derrière euh si vous avez des gens
qui ont pour objectif
de faire carrière, mais ça c'est un
principe qui est valable pour de pour
tout, c'est pas seulement dans le
journalisme, c'est aussi dans la
politique. Si vous avez des gens qui
veulent absolument faire ça et qui ne
conçoivent pas que à un moment donné on
pourrait aller faire autre chose, mais
là aussi ils se mettent en position de
faiblesse. Il y a rien de pire qu'un
politicien qui a besoin d'être réélu
parce queil se voit pas faire un autre
boulot. Je le principe c'est que on
vient alors ça c'est autre chose mais on
vient servir et puis après on rentre
chez soi et on fait autre chose voyez.
Et à partir du moment je vais vous dire
c'est ça doit être parce que je suis
claustrophobe. Moi j'ai toujours exercé
plusieurs métiers. Voilà. D'abord,
j'avais plusieurs
plusieurs médias et avant ça, j'ai
enseigné en même temps que j'étais
journaliste. D'abord parce que je
considérais que quand j'écrivais sur
l'éducation, c'était bien de savoir ce
que c'était que de tenir une classe, de
de de de se confronter à la difficulté
de transmettre et cetera. Et puis c'est
aussi parce que faut vous ménager la
possibilité de claquer la porte. Je faut
pas être dépendant, c'est un principe de
base. C'est si quand ça vous convient
plus, il faut pouvoir partir.
Il faut pouvoir partir du boulot.
Ouais.
Ou il faut pouvoir partir pour son
boulot.
Oui, pour faire pour continuer à faire
ce qu'on croit devoir faire. Voilà.
Bon, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Il y a encore 25000 questions
mais comme ils ont pas fait
d'intelligence collaborative à faire
monter les questions les plus
pertinentes, bah on va pas se prendre la
tête à lire toutes les questions une par
une pendant qu'on vous écoute en même
temps parce qu'on a pas le cerveau
capable de faire tout ça entre leurs
questions pertinentes. Il faut qu'on
suive un petit peu ce que vous racontez.
Euh on arrive à la fin. Est-ce qu'il y a
un sujet qu'on a pas traité ? Parce que
là on a traité les fake news, pas les
fake news, les ingérences étrangères, la
qualité intellectuelle de nos
politiques, de nos journalistes, de nos
salles de rédaction, de ceux qui les
subventionnent. Est-ce qu'il y a un
sujet que on n pas encore assez abordé ?
Il y a revenir de toute façon.
Il y a plein de sujets qu'on a pas
abordé donc oui, il faudra revenir.
Le dernier livre de Bruno Lemire.
Non, ça on l'a abordé hein. Ça ça ça
vous
avez pas vu ce reportage ? Je crois que
c'était de France Télévision du temps où
il faisit il faisait quelque chose
d'intéressant sur Bruno Lemer où il est
dans son super bureau, il prend une
figurine d'un duong qui lui a qui qui a
été offerte par une délégation
je pense Katari ou quelque chose comme
ça ou Emirati.
Il prend la statue, il dit bon je le
fais trivialement. Bon, je sais pas ce
que c'est que cette merde mais bon, ça
m'a été offert par des gars. Si
l'ambassade du pays en question il voit
ça, mais il nous prend pour qui ?
Vous voyez, tout à l'heure je vous je
vous parlais de la vergogne. Vous allez
trouver que je suis obsessionnelle, mais
la capacité à se tenir la dignité, vous
savez le le tout simplement l'idée que
on incarne quelque chose, qu'on
représente quelque chose et que donc il
y a voilà, il y a il y a une forme de
dessence, il y a des bref, j'ai eu une
éducation sans doute un petit peu à
l'ancienne mais je pense que
c'est quoi papa ? Il fait quoi maman ?
Elle faisait quoi maman ?
Ah mais moi je suis fille de médecin,
médecins libéraux. Il y a médecin et
médecin. Il y a médecin protologue,
médecin généraliste, médecin plombier,
médecin neurologue.
Mon père était gastro-entérologue,
chirurgien proctologue cacaue.
Voilà, il s'occupait du système digestif
et ma mère était
à Saint-Antoine.
Non, non, non, non, non. En banlieu
médecin libéral en banlieu
euh à Deuil la Barre.
Deil Bar
et et ma mère était ophtalmologiste.
Voilà. C'est toujours maman qui a raison
de toutes les façons.
Et j'ai euh et donc j'ai été élevée par
des parents qui m'ont expliqué qu'ils
avaient fait médecine parce que dans la
médecine, on est au service des gens.
Voilà.
Et pourquoi papa il a fini trou duologue
et maman Oftalmo ?
Alors pourquoi ?
Parce que parce que le système digestif
ça permet de faire de la chirurgie et
puis ensuite il a même fait de la
gériaterie mon père. s'occuper et puis
mon père est quelqu'un qui a c'est un
médecin avec du cœur et donc pour
s'occuper de personnes âgées, il faut
avoir une empathie profonde
surtout quand on est gastroérologue.
Exactement. Mais c'est vrai mais c'est
et ma mère a choisi les yeux parce que
alors elle aurait adoré être psychiatre
et puis finalement elle s'est orientée
vers la l'ophtalmologie parce que le le
d'abord l'œil c'est quelque chose de
magnifique, c'est absolument
merveilleux. Et donc j'ai moi quand
j'étais enfant, je voyais des des photos
de de fond d'œil. Voilà, des choses
comme ça.
Heureusement que vous avez pas débarqué
avec une coloscopie à table. [rires]
Non, en effet, en revanche, comme mon
père était un ancien carabin, je peux
vous assurer que j'ai eu droit à toutes
les chansons de carabin, les
contrepéteries, les charades tiroir. À
l'école, j'avais un succès de dingue. Je
vous ferai ça la prochaine fois, vous
verrez. Je suis sûre que les les charad
à tiroir vous maîtrisez pas.
Non. Euh question internet, qui pourrait
qui qui pourrait représenter une gauche
souverainiste pour les prochaines et
prochaines présidentielles ?
Alors là, oui, il y a il y a des gens
qui
Olivier Fort
alors non non non non non non.
Pourtant, il est beau Olivier Fort, il
est grand, il souverainiste,
c'est un leader, c'est charismatique.
C'est un Bruno Lemè en puissance.
Non.
Oui, se casse. Oui, se casse. Connaissez
pas la terrifiant parce que de C'est
vrai que depuis depuis quelques mois, je
me dit que un un pays dont le destin est
suspendu aux décisions d'Olivier Fort
est un pays qui ne va pas bien.
Oh, qu'est-ce que vous êtes dur. [rires]
Qu'est-ce que vous
Mais pour ce qui est de la gauche
républicaine, on verra. Mais en effet,
il y a ce courant qui découle de
chevinement qui a été porté à un moment
par Montebourg et qui doit absolument
faire la jonction avec bah tout
l'héritage de Philippe Séin. C'estàd si
vous vous réécoutez le discours de
Philippe Séin,
alors sur les finances et puis celui sur
de 92 sur Mastrich. Mais tout y est,
tout y est. Donc voilà, c'est ce courant
là qu'il faut faire revivre évidemment.
Alors qui ? Bah on verra. Vous savez euh
il y a des tas de gens, ils sont pas
pour l'instant visibles, ils sont pas
ils sont pas en avant mais je
voilà, je sais moi qu'il y a des gens
formidables partout. Il suffit de de les
rassembler. C'est le but de créer une
espèce de d'émulation.
Trois bouquins pour notre communauté.
Alors, trois bouquins,
l'Empire souterrain. L'Empire souterrain
qui est un livre de Farel et Abraham qui
raconte comment les États-Unis ont
manipulé, ont concentré les réseaux de
communication, les réseaux financiers
pour créer des goulaux d'étranglement et
imposer leur pouvoir. Ça a donné
évidemment bon toutes les problématiques
d'extraterritorialité du droit américain
et c'est un bouquin fondamental pour
comprendre où nous en sommes et les
risques parce que ce qu'ils expliquent
bien c'est à quel point en essayant de
créer ces goulau d'étranglement et
d'acculer leurs adversaires et bien ils
risquent de mettre la Chine dans une
position où elle aura le choix entre
soit se dire bon allez ça va passer on
fait le ron soit faire la guerre. Donc
ça c'est le premier livre. Deuxème
livre, Queen Slobodian
qui est un historien canadien
spécialiste du néolibéralisme qui a
écrit ce bouquin. Alors le le titre
français est très mauvais, le
capitalisme de l'apocalypse, c'est pas
ça du tout. En fait, c'est une analyse
sur toutes les tous les moments où ont
été inventés des zones franche qui
permettai de créer des paradis fiscaux
en dehors des États. Donc ça part de
l'histoire de Singapour, de Hong Kong,
ça passe par la city entièrement refaite
pour être le une espèce de de zone hors
contrôle dans Londres. On y apprend par
exemple parce que ça autant la City,
Singapour, je connaissais très bien tout
tout ça, autant je ne savais pas par
exemple que en Afrique du Sud à la fin
de l'appartide des idéologues se sont
dit que ce serait peut-être une bonne
idée de créer un état blanc séparé des
noirs qui serait là évidemment aussi un
paradis fiscal où on échappe à l'impôt.
Et en fait, quand vous lisez ça, vous
comprenez quelle est la mentalité d'un
Elon Musk, d'un Peter Till. Vous
comprenez en quoi il y a un lien entre
le libertarisme et le l'idée de de
ségrégation, l'idée qu'on va se créer un
endroit où on a le droit de choisir avec
qui on vit et évidemment on exclut tous
ceux qui vous ressemblent pas. Enfin,
déjà discuté avec Eléon Musk ?
Non, non, non, jamais.
Vous az déjà passé un peu de temps avec
lui ?
Ah non, non, pas du tout. Et Peter,
non Peter non plus, je les lis mais je
les je ne les connais pas bien sûr. Donc
voilà, mais ce livre-là, il est
absolument passionnant, il est
fondamental.
Et euh un troisème livre, et ben
écoutez, je l'ai cité tout à l'heure
puisque de temps en temps faut prendre
un peu de hauteur. Tucidide, la guerre
du péoponise parce que si vous lisez
Tucidide, d'abord vous comprenez comment
on arrive à la guerre. C'est-à-dire que
c'est d'ailleurs extraordinaire par par
exemple le déclenchement de la guerre de
141 ressemble terriblement au
déclenchement de la guerre du péoponaise
et comment un jeu d'alliance finit par
faire en sorte que tout le monde tombe
dans le même enfin tombe dans cette
guerre. Et deuxièmement, si vous lisez,
vous vous apercevez aussi que vous avez
la l'explication de ce qu'est
l'impérialisme. Tuides raconte que c'est
l'impérialisme athénien qui a conduit
Athène à sa perte et que Athène dont je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
c'était une démocratie et que Péricles
décrivait merveilleusement la
démocratie. Le problème c'est qu'Ahè
croyait pouvoir utiliser dans sa
politique extérieure le contraire des
valeurs qu'elle défendait à l'intérieur.
C'est-à-dire que il y a un épisode
extraordinaire, c'est l'épisode avec
l'île de Méos. L'île de Mélos essae de
rester neutre dans cette guerre, de dire
"On se mêle pas de ça, ne nous obligez
pas à venir." Et les Athéniens leur
disent "Vous êtes avec nous ou contre
nous." Les méliens disent "Non, on veut
pas." Exactement. Exactement. Et ben que
et que fait Athène ? Et ben, Athè rase
l'île de Mélos et on voit tous les t
tous les habitants en esclavage.
C'est-à-dire que la démocratie impose sa
volonté par la guerre. Ça finit toujours
mal.
Vous avez lu euh chronique de l'assassin
économique ?
Non.
Est-ce que euh vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose d'impérissable
avant la guerre.
lire
et pratiquer le on va dire le pessimisme
de le pessimisme de la lucidité et
l'optimisme de la volonté.
Natacha Polonie, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]